busy as you are there is no excuse to
miss any of these six events including
of course the air things Masters as well
as the plan that we're commentating
today everybody gets a chance to get in
and these six events are going to
feature tightly contested super
tournaments with large prize funds I
mean really what more could you ask for
than a circuit of this magnitude with
these prizes and featuring players of
this caliber for some of you who maybe
prefer to to learn your information
visually audibly then you might be
actually seeing the schedule hearing
about how the tour is working for the
first time right here maybe you didn't
follow the follow the Articles and so if
that's the case you saw the schedule you
know what you need to mark down and you
know that you need to look forward to
this whole year but Donya and I are now
going to talk about how this thing works
we are starting as he said with the air
things Masters plan and what is that
what does that mean for everyone as I
said the broad tour what you really need
to know is that if you win one of those
six events you're in otherwise two spots
are going to players who performed their
best over the entire year but each
individual event will qualify players
via a play-in tournament to pre to match
play which Donnie and I will cover today
and then eventually a knockout on the
following week most of the time
sometimes there's a longer break
depending on whether it's going to be a
live final event somewhere the basic
rules of the game Dania are that if you
finish in the top you get to compete in
division one the winner of division one
gets that coveted seat directly punching
their ticket to the finals at the end of
the year but the winners of Divisions
two and three also have a ton on the
line not just massive prizes Donya but
if you win division two the next play in
the next match play and knockout around
you're already in division one if you
win division three you're in division
two this allows us that balance right
that balance of rewarding the top
players in the highest prizes but
everybody is competing for something
every single event
yeah and I would broadly categorize
things as two major sort of things items
at play there are the winners of the
tournaments themselves and that there
are their large prizes so divisions two
and three are mostly fighting for big
prizes and these prizes are really big
obviously division one uh there are
prizes at stake but there's also the
ticket to the major events of which
there are six so I think Danny when you
see this on the screen at first it can
be a little bit overwhelming but I
actually think the format is really
simple three divisions divisions two and
three fight for prizes the winner of
division two gets into division one the
winner of division one gets into one of
the final tournaments in final
tournaments gets into the gets into the
finals 100 to stay focused on the Swiss
right here I guess we'll just talk about
that we're Donnie and I are so excited
we've been talking about this thing for
months now so there's a lot of energy
coming out if you can't feel it the
energy is palpable between us right here
um but to remind you about the Swiss so
as of today what they're playing for are
the top 12 finishers are going to
compete in match play to get into
displacement so what you're about to see
with all these guys that are registering
for the tournament by the way been
texting with Vladimir kramnik to reset
his password we've got Ali Reza ferrugia
Peter so many people are just showing up
last minute but they're competing to be
in the top 12 to get into division one
the next 24 division two the next 32
division three we're going to be talking
a lot about that as the day goes on so
let's keep rolling through this
Dania you've been mentioning the prizes
I think it's time for us to maybe give
the fans a snapshot of that because it
is big money at stake obviously everyone
wants to punch their ticket directly to
the finals and ultimately be competing
for that half a million dollars in cash
at the end of the year with our live
event but first place end of next week
has already taken home 30 grand but even
if you only win a division two or
division three prize it's not that bad
for a few days of work
oh I think Danny this format and these
prizes addressed two abiding criticisms
that essentially have been circulating
around the chess worlds for a long time
one of them is that the prizes tend to
accumulate at the very top there's like
two or three big prizes and nobody else
wins anything that's criticism number
one and criticism number two has been
listen you basically have to qualify a
million times to the finals in order to
be eligible for any prizes this price
pool addresses both of these issues 76
people get a prize and you don't
necessarily need to be in the top ten
you don't need to beat Hikaru and
farusha to be eligible Danny for a
significant prize that makes your
participation worth its while I think
both of these things are going to
attract a much larger number of grand
Masters that you can root for not just
the big dogs I love that I love how you
stated that again it's 235 thousand
dollars in total for those who maybe
don't like to to read boards or do math
good
people like me just see that number at
the top 235k every single one of these
six events of course again half a
million million dollars at the end of
the year as well Dania we've broken down
the prizes of course we know that the
rumors are are out right who showed up
today and uh word word travels fast
let's talk about the notable players
that we anticipated that we're gonna
show up because indeed they did the uh
the list of notable players starts right
there at the top probably of course the
uh the number one player who hasn't been
directly seated we're going to talk
about why Magnus and Wesley earn those
spots in a second but Hikaru Nakamura
right there at the top but a pretty
interesting list to go with that
including a uh a very underrated when it
comes to chess.com rapid Donya 2483 Ali
Reza faruja he's been sandbagging that
kid he definitely has been sandbagging I
was looking at the tub where is the guy
vitted nipponishi you start panicking
where's farusha he's at the very bottom
of the list something tells me he's not
going to be at the bottom of the
tournament standings but I've been
pushing for this really ever since the
cgc a bigger pool of players to root for
again not just the same seven eight
players we see in a lot of the stale
super tournaments but really everybody
for multiple generations and whoever
you're rooting for they're probably
playing in the Swiss stage Peter Fiddler
vidit all countries represented all of
the top players but also a lot of the
young up and coming GMS and alireza
farusia who's finally playing in a
tournament Danny I know it's not even
just that it's an online tournament it's
it's a tournament right I mean obviously
there's a reason people talk about it we
know that alireza uh listening in and
and his brother and family they're big
fans of these shows and so of course
when we talk about it it's not not
because anybody is doing anything but
just wondering where is Ali Reza he he
probably has the biggest fan base who
doesn't get to see him play as often as
they would like and so to see farugia
show up for this uh quickly that rating
will probably change from 2483 to
something else I don't have word whether
Ali Reza has been recruited for any of
the protest League teams that's of
course another big event that just
kicked off this week and and of course
we'll be rolling over the next few
months so that'll be interesting to see
whether anybody can recruit him and we
see we see chat having a good time
talking about the 2483 there but let's
talk a little bit about about this list
right we know that Magnus Carlson and
Wesley so have been directly seated
right at some point we'll we'll we'll uh
we'll remind everybody what that is in
fact maybe maybe we'll do that right now
if we want to talk quickly about the
Swiss stage format because I think some
people are wondering why would you why
would you do that right why doesn't
everyone have to qualify their way in we
are big on the meritocracy here at
chess.com but let's go ahead and bring
up the format and explain to everybody
that obviously our goal was to bring
some very big things together the
Champions chest or the head run for a
couple years at chest 24. chess.com's
number of events from the global Chess
Championship last year to the rapid
Chess Championship and ultimately we
looked at we looked at how to get this
party started the right way in a
celebration fashion and it made sense to
seat the reigning champions of those two
major events Magnus Carlson and Wesley
so and ask everyone else to jump in the
fold and let the meritocracy begins if
you will and so Daniel
that's really what this is about right
six people will be joining Magnus and
Wesley in that eight player knockout
starting next week coverage of course
will be brought by our friends in the
Oslo Studio Robert Hess there along with
David Howell and Ivanka Huska and and
Kaya and others but your thoughts on the
format here and just whether what you
expect to happen next week with six
other players joining Magnus and Wesley
well I think it's all about balance when
you think about who you want to fill the
finals of an event you don't want
everybody to be invited and you don't
necessarily want to leave one spot open
for qualification because then you have
you know a traffic jam of grand Masters
and there there's sort of an element of
chance if you have only one qualifying
spot so I really don't think that
anybody Minds Magnus Carlson and Wesley
so getting invited I think they've
earned it through their chess careers
and of course Wesley through his
performance in the cgc as the biggest
most notable online event not just of
the year not just of the decade but
really of all time and Danny I really
love that we're really opening up the
field we're not just having that one
symbolic spot we are really giving more
than one top Grandmaster a chance to
qualify and I I think this strikes a
very elegant balance between inviting
the players who have earned it and
opening up the rest of the spots the
players who actually now have a chance
to earn it I love it love what you said
and I think that that's exactly what we
were trying to accomplish so hearing it
from you sounds better than any way I
could say it right the balance between
making sure the top players have their
chance and that the fans know that
they're showing up to watch their
favorites over the last decade or so but
also really helping to slowly establish
something we've always wanted to do in
chess which is every every major title
every major event in theory if you had
your way would have had some sort of
path for everyone to join right and that
doesn't mean that someone starting chess
today can be world champion next year we
know that but the point is having a
meritocracy to a degree where possible
should always be the goal here and I
think that's what we were trying to
establish and we're pretty excited to
see where we landed with that balance of
top players uh helping to kick things
off and every event requiring a
meritocracy system if you will you got
to show up on the plane to get in and we
in and we see the prices are worth it so
uh what we're what we're experiencing
right now we're four minutes behind
server start time time and obviously no
way no way not to just to call it out
everyone in the world has been talking
about it because everyone in the world
has suddenly decided to start playing
chess over the last 45 days so we are we
are at Peak server time right now I'm
being told we're going to be restarting
uh the the tournament we're going to be
restarting the server to allow for uh
for maximum stability Donya I think that
means you and I are going to be talking
a lot about this format and turning this
into a format education show for the
next half an hour from what I can
understand
um the uh
I'm just checking in
um but all right
let's go let's go back to the uh the
note the notable players list while
we're waiting here
okay okay so we are gonna take a very
quick break
don't go anywhere Johnny and I will be
back we won't keep you waiting we're
going to give you as much content as we
possibly can as we get set to kick this
thing off uh we uh we know you want it
we want it to
um gives us a chance to refresh our
coffee everyone go grab a snack when we
return we will be getting closer to
kicking off the first event of the 2023
Champions chess store on chess.com and
that of course is the air things Masters
plan
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
to the 2023 Champions chess tour it's
not groundhog day but we've done this
before I'm here alongside Grand Master
Dania narodiski to kick like I've been
here before Danny
I have a dream I just woke up am I
sleeping all I know is we just had the
best we just had the best tech rehearsal
of all time and we are going to kick
things off for those of you who've been
with us since we first went live about
an hour ago we do appreciate your
patience and it will be worth the wait I
promise you that the best chess players
in the world are here the Champions
chess tour is kicking off baby and it is
the air things Masters playing right off
the top Donya why don't you tell
everybody what the schedule has for them
this year of course we start things off
with the air things and go ahead and
break it down for us well I have a sort
of appeal to the audience to make but
when we talk about the specifics of the
format I'll make it then here we start
with the broader calendar the air things
Masters is coming your way from February
6th February 10th the play in today is
going to qualify six more players to the
air things masters with two spots
already taken up by the amateurs Magnus
Carlson and Wesley so there are five
more events on top of the air things
Masters and all of those culminate in
the CCT playoffs and the CCT finals both
of which are coming your way in December
of 2023 Danny so year-round events
year-round action and everybody is going
to get a chance to partake in it and
what you need to know about those events
is that the winner of each of those
events gets a spot directly in to the
finals you see there in December two
other spots will be given to those who
perform the most consistently and at the
top of the standings throughout the year
we'll talk a lot more about that of
course as we get into things but that's
what you need to know eight players will
be there at the end right now let's talk
about things for today Donya because the
Swiss is going to kick things off the
play in Swiss to be at stack and so to
be exact and so what exactly is at stake
for all of those players who jumped in
here on Friday
well I'm going to delve into this slide
Danny but just to get something out of
the way I think some people watching
this might already start getting annoyed
when they see this slide and they might
start thinking well this is too
complicated trust me when I first
learned about the format I had that
initial eye roll but as I delved a
little bit into it I started to give it
a chance and I realized that the format
is not only simpler than it appears it's
also elegant and actually gives a lot of
people a chance to qualify so my appeal
to people watching is to spend two three
minutes with us to understand the format
and I promise you that you're going to
understand exactly what's going on why
things are the way that they are and
everything will be made clear so suspend
your disbelief for a little bit now the
key thing to understand here is that
there are 76 players who qualify across
three divisions the top 12 finishers are
the stars of the show they move on to a
Swiss and then six of uh they move on to
a uh knockout six match play six six of
the winners occupy the six spots in the
upcoming air things Masters
there's division two the winner of
division two gets a direct spot into the
next major and division three is also
important because there are big prizes
on the line and Danny it is my
understanding that the winner of
division three gets a direct spot into
the following play-ins division two 100
they can win make their way to the major
right okay but the most important thing
to understand is that this is the right
balance between top players competing
for top prizes and of course everyone
having a chance in theory to become the
Champions chess tour champion at the end
of the year those 76 players will be
playing in match play today as soon as
the Swiss is done there will be a break
and Don and I will have all the action
to describe what's at stake once again
when we get there but let's talk about
the prizes as well because there's a lot
of people here uh to take home some cash
you see there is big money at stake with
all six of these major events not only
the five hundred thousand dollars
waiting at the end of the year to win
division and one at the end of this next
week February 10th is 30k in cash but
even division two ten thousand dollars
division three five thousand dollars in
addition to the stakes as done you
described it you want to move up and
standing so that you have a chance to
ultimately punch your ticket in Donya
not bad cash there as well as the points
you can see right next to it those are
the leaderboard points available for
each one of the placing finishes
indeed and the leaderboard is important
because two spots uh into the grand
finals in December uh are punched
through the top two spots in the
leaderboard with the other six spots of
course going to the winners of the six
respective Majors but I'm going to
repeat what I said at the start of the
show Danny for those who are just
joining us I think that the wide prize
distribution really addresses one of the
biggest criticisms I've had and the
public at large has had which is that
chess prizes tend to accumulate at the
very top and then Peter out once you get
to fifth or sixth place we're talking
about an event with over a hundred
Grandmasters you want to give everybody
a chance tons of players they make a
living off of online events now that's
the new normal and I love the fact that
the CCT has responded and addressed that
criticism so even if you don't have a
realistic chance of earning that spot to
one of the majors you're still playing
for big prizes significant prizes
division three you win division three
five thousand dollars and you get a
chance to qualify in the major if you
win Edition addition to the following
plan I love it you said it better than I
could and you did say it better than I
could at the beginning of the show too
we've got 9 000 on Twitch roughly almost
10 000 of course many other viewers
scattered throughout the interwebs be
with us the day is only just beginning
and the top players are showing up in
force let's show everybody who's some of
the top names some of the biggest names
are that are already here you see right
there at the top you've got your lunch
just off Duda in the car Hikaru Nakamura
but all the way at the bottom there you
also have Ali Reza farouza uh who uh who
joined joined late and his rapid rating
we've actually we've actually given it
an update there uh he he joined and
hadn't played rapid for a minute so he
was way way lower rated uh uh when he
when he first joined about 45 minutes
ago but okay Dania this is what we
wanted to see this is what we expected
to see frankly probably the only two
names missing from that list people are
wondering where's Magnus and where's
Wesley so we'll talk about that in a
minute let's focus on these eight names
in front of us and uh I'll ask you to do
that hard thing give me a give me a
prediction who performs best today of
these big names
well the question is do I go Old
Reliable or do I go out on a limb
obviously I think the name that
everybody's eyes tend to gravitate
toward is he Kara Nakamura he has the
most proven track record by a country
mile in terms of his ability to qualify
his ability to come through clutch in
these events I mean every RCC weekend
weekend he essentially qualified cgc
when it matters he shows up but Ali Reza
farouza the guy hasn't played OTB chess
in a while he's going to be hungry to
show the Chess World that he hasn't just
been sitting around twiddling his thumbs
he's been studying he's been training
and the way he's been playing bullet
recently Danny I think alireza fuja
definitely is going to make the top 12.
and I have I think he has a great shot
of punching his ticket through to the
first major yeah I think uh we'll be
there's no way we won't be talking a lot
about ali Reza where in the World is
Carmen San Diego where in the world has
Ali Reza farusha been and what will he
be doing uh not just in this plane today
but if he does indeed punch his ticket
to the knockout outstage net week next
week what is HE capable of but okay we
mentioned there were two big names
missing from that list let's let's bring
up the Swiss stage format so that we can
describe to people exactly what we did
here the kickoff of the 2023 Champions
Chester are now on chess.com is the
merging of the Champions chest door as
it previously previously was for the
last two years and of course the
chess.com Global championship in the
rapid Chess Championship all those
events as Donya said we had a tough task
to combine the top players being happy
and the fans making sure that they had
those top players to watch but also
everyone having a great opportunity to
win big cash prizes and those two top
players that have been seated Magnus
Carlson and Wesley so were were seated
for a reason Dania they are the
respective reigning champions of the
Champions chess tour and the chess.com
Global Championship which is why those
who saw the beginning of the format 12
players from the Swiss will play in a
match play to decide six to join Magnus
and Wesley with eight players competing
in The Knockout next week
I think it's an elegant format you're
giving the top players there due while
giving a lot of other players a serious
Fighting Chance and speaking of Fighting
Chance Danny I think we are two seconds
away the gong is going to sound the time
control is ten plus two that's been a
very popular time control for good
reason we're gonna get a good cross
between entertainment and high level
chess and speaking of high level chess
whoops sorry I misclicked I pulled up
some weak players there I don't know
what they're doing
Hikaru can we watch someone or somebody
else I was gonna say you you speaking of
high-level chess you picked you picked
Hikaru and and Evgeni tomaszewski what
is wrong with you anyway sorry my house
has had a life of its own recently jokes
jokes aside that's what this event is
going to bring you it's funny because
obviously we all are already looking
forward to The Knockout next week nanya
and shout out to the team and also
waiting you're probably watching Robert
Hess David Howe Ivanka Huska Kaya Tanya
everyone who's there but I think that
this play-in for all six of these big
events that are going to happen
throughout the year will have just as
many fans showing up and be excited
because it's that moment where it's a
it's almost a free-for-all right you get
how often do you get names that we're
looking at here with farugia hikarus
Fiddler rajaba varoni and Yanda Palm
machine right Vladimir krummick by the
way shout out to the 14th World chess
champion popping in for kicks and gigs
and here we go Donya let's do this thing
listen I always say this some people
roll their eyes at this but I love it
when different Generations compete in
the same event I love it when we have
different formats all as part of the
same tournament whatever you like
whatever gets gets you going whether
it's a Swiss system whether it's a
knockout whether it's match play you're
gonna get a little bit of everything and
as I said before at any of the time
control perfect cross between yeah we're
gonna get some time scrambles we're
gonna get some craziness but we're also
making the older players happy with that
two second increment
it's not just the older players it's not
just the older players who want
increment down oh wait did I just did I
just literally point out that I'm old by
saying I wanted oh my gosh that was like
a Moment of clarity I just had an out of
body experience I I also like they keep
telling me I'm gonna start wanting
increment you know when I hit my late
20s early 30s it ain't it hasn't
happened yet but I can definitely
appreciate its positive impact on the
quality of flight quality of play on the
subject of quality of play Danny Hikaru
getting a very tough pairing in round
one tomashevsky is no pushover no that's
not a that's not a fun pairing to get
when you're when you're uh hoping to get
a dub to kick things off but let's be
honest Dania there will be no hey that
was a that was an easy pairing to get
right I'm sitting here looking down the
list of games in my monitor on the side
to help you as we navigate this thing my
man I I can't I can't fuse the next game
you gotta choose it because I'm like I
kid in the candy store you want farouja
you want Yolanda Palm machine who do you
want to jump to next I've got borugia
taken on goo Kesh I'm around you I mean
can we go to can we go to farusha gukesh
we can use it yeah it's a pretty
composition any cars game he's played
kind of a a regular quiet opening so
this game uh is going to proceed along
pretty positional lines for a while
perfect opportunity for us to head to a
more tactical display in farooja gukesh
Ali Raza has the white piece is
definitely an E4 opening Danny this was
a rosalimo sicilian and alireza trying
to orchestrate some Shenanigans here on
the queen side
I like it I mean I I quickly looked at
it and maybe liked white more than I
should I promise it wasn't farusha
farouja bias itis but I like the three
on two that white has with C4 leading
the way it's dynamite after all holding
back the b-pawn push and the D5 Square I
don't think that eval bar to me gives
credit to the Practical struggles black
has here done in tell me if you think
I'm right that it feels like White's
pressure maybe even the B Pawn can push
you have Bishop F4 coming I feel like
some of these some of these pieces for
black are gonna have a hard time finding
squares yeah far is it definitely
hunting for gold on the queen side
practically speaking whoa Bishop F4 in
this position almost wins the game
outright black is a little tactic with
Knight to F3 check
um it captures the bishop but man is
this tenuous farusia could slide his
King over instead he presses the gas
pedal gets his Knight to B6 these are
exactly the kinds of complex middle
games that he excels in but gukesh I
mean he didn't have the greatest event
in tata but he finished very strong and
he's someone who really wants to prove
his ability to compete with the best of
them Danny in online events where he's a
little bit less experienced love it we
see the chat is already pumped Ali Reza
playing chess poggers Where Have You
Been Ollie rezzo farrugia the world
wants to know but okay uh Knight to B6
played and uh I like that he's
postponing C5 Donnie I think it's
instruction instructive to point out
that while you have a grip you want to
keep the the pieces held back if you
played C5 you actually open up the score
D5 maybe for blacks tonight maybe the C
Pawn uh is actually good right where it
stands so he plays Knight B6 instead and
it's actually kind of tricky for black
to find an improving move here
yeah this is a hard position to play for
both sides white as you're hinting at
runs the risk of overextending if you
grab too much space you start weakening
key squares black just has a problem
finding squares for his pieces because
he's essentially confined to the last
few ranks I have my eye on a move like
Queen to C7 trying to pin the Knight to
the queen but then Ali Rosa could
support his Queen and grab a little more
space with b2b4 white could grab the
bishop pair on the next move if he so
desires so good cash definitely thinking
about going Bishop 80 okay Bishop C6 so
he says you're welcome to take my Bishop
but then my Knight's gonna slide back
and kick your queen out and then my
Bishop can slide over to B4 so Ali Reza
it's like driving a bus I mean one wrong
turn and you're gonna fall off a cliff
here yeah
I love it I love how you uh broke that
down I don't know how to drive a bus by
the way I was gonna say do you have your
CEO because you want to know a fun fact
about Dan Dan has a CDL okay Dan knows
how to drive uh a uh a a commercial bus
long story previous life don't want to
talk about it any Hooters
um there's alireza and uh he wants to
talk about about his position do you
even know what a CDL is
I assumed it's a commercial driver's
license oh okay sorry it's not hard to
figure that out don't you think I don't
know my abbreviations
all right
looking looking uh looking Dapper
looking focused uh and
gonna gonna do everything he can today
to make sure he punches his ticket for
The Knockout next week there's a lot of
prizes in store and I think if Borussia
had his way he would just show up when
the air things Masters Donya and then
disappear again for 12 months and come
back and win the championship in
December so I think he has big goals for
the next 10 days of his life yeah that's
kind of been his modus operandi uh
through through the years as we see the
intensity on Ali Reza farouza's
expression this is a nine round Swiss
even though essentially all these top
guys they're trying to make one of the
top 12 spots and we know from the RCC
how far a loss in the early rounds can
set you back so they're taking it
seriously from the very start I like
Bruce's position gukesh starting to drop
a little bit on the clock I also have my
eye on some guy named Peter svidler who
I wanted to check in on uh if you don't
mind at some point yeah I'm I'm open to
that let's let's give one more thought
on what's gonna happen next year while
we have only res on camera because you
pointed out white can't play Bishop F4
highlight that again for everybody if
Bishop F4 Knight F3 oh oh but wait now
now if you play Knight F3 is there G
takes F3 and The Bishop's hanging no
what does black have there is no I think
black sacrifice is the bishop and when
you go for Bishop diesel
here there is E5 interesting oh E5 so
what's the move it's not Queen G5
because White's Queen defends that
square it looks like there's something
but what is it Rook takes D4 doesn't
seem to work either maybe just Knight
takes E4 is simple because F2 is it is
Knight takes C4 just the attack on F2
you're absolutely right White's pieces
are stuck on the queen side they once
mattered but they don't anymore
this is fascinating
because I was actually going oh wow
we've seen several moves okay what
happened here we saw Bishop to G5 and
Rook takes D4 from gookesh as he
surprised if you missed it oh feroza
definitely missed it that's another
tactic he ain't going for Knight F3
Danny he's going back to C6 those
retreating Knight moves the hardest type
of move in chess and I'll tell you what
after Rook takes D4 Knight C6 there's
also the problem of Bishop B4 white
could end up losing both of his Rooks
right now yeah you can see by farusha's
reaction his poem is almost extended I
don't speak farouza facial expression as
fluently as I do Hikaru I'm currently in
school studying to improve my farrugia
my farrugia um body language reading
skills but but this was definitely like
a wait what and I think he missed I
think he missed Rook takes D4 and I
think he's gonna have his work it out
for him I'm happy to jump to another
game remind everybody you can choose
your own adventure of course you can
watch the games directly at chess.com
events you cannot watch them directly on
the live server or you shouldn't be able
to because we're using our private
server fair play mode if you do find a
way to watch them directly at chess.com
play let me know because you're not
supposed to cough cough but you can go
to chess.com events or stick with us
right here on Twitter Youtube wherever
you are and we will guide your ship
let's choose another game donor you're
in charge go ahead take it away flip the
script when ready but we gotta come back
to the final moments of farusha good
cash before it's over go ahead no
question let's bookmark this game let's
make a mental note we'll come back to
this one I was looking at svidler but
I'm seeing so many other amazing names
from nepo to Carolina let's check into
Peter let's give him some a little bit
of love I don't think anybody will mind
that then maybe we can check out Fabiano
caruana I'm just looking at this
position and I'm thinking this is some
juicy stuff Castor is a nightmare first
round opponent that's Rodrigo Vazquez
one of the strongest and most
experienced Blitz players on the site
you always see him in top 10 in title
Tuesday and he's already sacrificed to
peace he's got and right to work
yeah I'm uh sorry I was also doing that
distracted kid thing you were bringing
it up and I'm like I'm looking at
Bobby's game I'm looking at nepo's game
I'm looking into cars game what is the
what is the world we live in how excited
are we to have everybody here in this
event all right but I will give you the
chest attention as if you need it Donya
um you're pretending like my opinion
matters A5 though this is a game right
out of my book I mean can we just play
Bishop takes B4 or show everybody why
that's Checkmate I mean Just for kicks
we can some of us are visual Learners
awesome there you go okay yeah I don't
think Peter spitler is a visual learner
yeah I think he's dead in his head he
does Queen controls the B1 Square this
is of course a discover check followed
by a Checkmate something tells me we
won't see this on the board and we do
not svidler pushes the seep on and says
two can play at that game speaking of
discoveries the pawn discovers the
Queen's path to B5 which will be a very
nasty counter check again black is no
black is not down a piece I thought he
was for some reason but he's not well
normally when you get 55. normally when
you get this kind of pressure you are
down to piece uh in this situation
you're not uh but I love C5 from Fiddler
as you pointed out that Queen to B5
check is super irritating to deal with
for black we see uh we see some love for
swindler in the chat swindler's not a
bad nickname for Spindler it sounds like
the Riddler and Peter schidler had a
baby which would probably make for a
very tricky chess player if I'm honest
it would indeed but Peter svidler is
just and he ages like fine wine
obviously he is now known as one of the
Premier chess commentators but I think
he's gonna try to prove uh in this
tournament that he's got some chess left
to play and some guests left in the tank
Queen C2
speaking of gas left in the tank is
there anything left in Black's attack
here this is a natural move but the eval
bar is having none of it probably that
check on B5 Danny followed by maybe C6
maybe Queen takes B7 although The Rook
is gonna hang with him I was gonna say I
think the idea is Queen B5 checking on
you but the following is Bishop to C4
which both protects the Knight on B3 and
develops The Rook to guard the D1 Rook
so if I had to guess svidler has indeed
already played it I think the follow-up
move that puts black on notice will be
Bishop to C4 and I'm I'm guessing with
no evil I I'm out of my out of my depth
here
um guessing moves from a former
candidate Peter Fiddler and and I don't
know if you know but Donya noradinsky
he's okay at chess too but but I think
that's the right idea whoa oh he doesn't
play it
and he wants Bishop C4 in response that
almost straps the queen but I think he
might have missed Knight C2 check here
and I see Judas trades Queens
well or or I would have to take on C2
presumably and then go well I was gonna
say his team
193 and it's over
it wins the queen oh my gosh did Fiddler
blunder Knight C2 or is he going for
that Rook sacrifice on C2 followed by
this is unnecessary Danny he didn't need
to sacrifice a piece
apparently 1922 wasn't even the best
move
he's he's showing confidence in his body
language that and in his in his speed of
movement right he played it very quickly
but I'm not sure I'm not sure he likes
one
there's a simple win here for black you
can take the bishop yeah CD looks very
scary but the King has this E7 square
and then you're gonna build a little
defensive cocoon around it by bringing
the Rook to d8 the problem when you're
down a rook uh is just that you need to
prove something incredible and white is
just running out of pieces after the
king gets to E7 yeah it looks impressive
but Spiller is going to have virtually
no compensation Castor can win this game
with a couple more accurate moves
a lot of love for Peter Fiddler from
chat right now but honestly uh not not
the not the love that he's feeling for
his own position on the board right now
no I think he knows he let this one get
away Castor taking his time before
deciding whether he's going to take D2
or not but I think we're gonna use this
time and opportunity to check in another
game just so everyone knows today's
gonna feel a lot like that in moments we
are trying to balance following by the
way Vladimir kramnik look at that dub
the 14th World Chess Championship one of
the first to strike Hikaru Nakamura Ali
Reza for rusian Yanda pomach I can't
name everyone Fabiano caruana we're
gonna have moments today that make you
feel like we didn't catch every game but
don't worry 12 players are getting
themselves into division one for match
play when that break happens in a couple
hours you will have all the focus in the
world this is designed to be fun and
crazy and we're along for the ride and
I'll tell you what someone's gonna be
annoyed because there are fans of
everybody but bear with us because there
are nine rounds and we promise to cover
everybody in equal portions you know you
just can't get to everybody every round
so we're gonna try to find the
entertaining games this is very much an
entertaining game it features the queen
sacrification
right it's out of desperation
he's going to win the bishop on e4 he
also has Knight to D7 Intermezzo does he
throw that fork Fork it a queen of four
it's I I think gukesh might be saying
alireza
this is what happens when we don't play
well don't play in serious online events
for a little bit you got to get your
tactics sharp right away because I came
to play and I'm gonna be rhyming all day
hashtag TGIF hashtag don't forget to tip
your waitress
um actually without without Queen F4
this would work to Perfection G takes F6
and if Knight t7 Queen F4 hits that Rook
on D2 lpdo loose pieces drop off alireza
is gonna have to take on e4 and pray he
does clearly insufficient compensation
for the queen he's got a minute 30 on
his clock this should be a win for
gukesh unless he blunders a fork or some
sort of sudden attack on his King but
white doesn't have enough really to
create anything uh against Black's King
which is which can just hide away on h8
if necessary did you just say lpdo
is that I did that I'm supposed to be
aware of from your from your other
comment I mean
hey you're the abbreviation guy so I'm
I'm stunned that you don't know what
that stands for uh CDL lose pieces drop
off apparently
um I thought it was like you know back
in the 90s when every boy band was
abbreviated
um but okay we're gonna stick it right
here Rook takes E4 Knight E5 both guards
the D7 square right and activating the
pony
activating the pony okay now can you
activate the Rook you want to get a pair
of Rooks off if you catch because that
greatly limits White's ability to create
active counter play he does just that
this is winning for black take the Roku
Queen C7 may be very natural play hit
him where it hurts and if white loses C5
the game ends Danny so Arusha he's gonna
have to go B4 support that pawn with A3
and continue praying probably A5 can be
thrown in now for black white will play
A3 anyway but there's all kinds of
weirdness with the Knight coming back to
C6 at some point the B4 Pawn is tender
um black and even play moves like F5
King G7 King F6 right stabilize and
expand very tough position especially
given the Perugia it will be under a
minute here in 18 seconds
excellent move by gukesh White's pieces
just don't have purchase and this is
Ultimate desperation alireza is going
all in I think he's gonna take B7 and
he's going to pin all of his hopes on
that C5 Pawn which is going to become
past if he can eat up that B7 Pawn first
he defends before can go cash use his
active Queen combine it with an active
Knight but Danny that requires
calculation and three and a half minutes
by hukesh A very wise decision by
alireza this is his last chance and it
may just work I've seen so many of his
swindles he pulls wins out of the most
improbable places
agreed I'm I'm actually it's funny the
eval bar is still favoring black as it
should but I'm actually looking at this
and looking at good cash taking his time
with a little more nerves than I did I
kind of like that 995 and that plan I
was describing with F5 and bring the
kingdom because I feel like you've made
it very concrete and if B7 Falls
remember A6 is falling don't forget that
Bishop on F1 yeah it's playing it so I
think black might have to play A5 right
now to try to start undermining things
in a hurry
I agree I'm also looking at Queen to C1
with the idea of getting this Knight
actually to E2 and knocking the king
away obviously that Bishop on F1 becomes
a Sitting Duck by the way quick side
note as you see on the lower left hicaro
has won his first game as is Jana
pomnishi as is Dimitri on draken so some
of the usual suspects Danny off to a
pretty good start as has Alexi serona
that is Misha Nick for those who don't
speak chess.com username as has
Christian perilla which is the count
look shout out to Christian getting a
dub to start things off there
one of the founders of the c-squared
podcast if you're not checking that out
him and Fabiano carawanna bringing you
some long-form content on YouTube good
stuff
okay okay here it goes this is this is
uh this is what time pressure does this
is what farugia does
he's quickly and immediately met Knight
D4 with Knight C4 Donnie he was on top
of this the B7 Pawn still under Fire and
by the way now Knight D6 is potentially
on the agenda with F7 being something to
watch out for there is a voice in my
head that says farrugia is not going to
lose this game I know it feels to me
that there's been a momentum shift yes
the yes black is still winning and the
reason Danny that Knight D4 was a
mistake by gupesh at least practically
is that now you cannot go Queen C1 and
that is a crucial attacking move if you
go E5 which very well might be the
correct move you're creating serious
weaknesses and allowing the Knight to
jump into D6 there are some mating
constructions against the blacking there
and now go cash is down to 90 minutes
this basically has become a bullet game
yeah 90 seconds and and by the way that
was that was what I felt that regardless
of what the eval bar said I was feeling
nervous I liked the night on E5 earlier
preventing that Rook from coming to D7
whatever I said for some reason
activated Siri maybe I should maybe I
should ask Siri whether farooza is going
to come back and win this game uh
because the future the future is
farrugia as many have said
um all right okay E5 comes but here we
go the bee bell bar slipping look at him
look at him scooch his way in after E5
like all right here we go
gotta be some chances because the light
yeah exactly Knight D6 Bishop C4 light
Square problems and he's got some
Knight E3 is a very careful move that
actually might be the key to the kingdom
here prevent the queen from jumping into
C1 because that's gokesha's only idea
but Peru's just too gritty grabs the
pawn allowing Quincy one pretty shocked
at this move what is his follow-up now
he plays Knight E3 what is the idea well
now but 92 you're exactly right get this
night off of e3 if you're a good cash
but time pressure is sinking in it's a
game for a reason boys and girls I would
go C6 and then Knight F5 Danny and try
to create threats against Black's King
I'm with you I'm with you what a Gambit
that is Donya look at you being all
bullet and spicy you got those you've
been eating your Wheaties this morning
C6 Knight takes Knight F5 holds the G7
Square everyone which threatens all
kinds of mating tactics against the
black king
exactly and I don't even know why I put
this on the board we have all the reason
for Roosters to do that it is on the
board underremitted is gukesh first of
all don't move your knight second of all
solve the problem of your king and he
does with H5 and now alireza could start
targeting some of those weak pawns can't
take A6 that's illegal maybe go A4 can
you create complications with only 20
seconds now on the clock for white yeah
nervous if gookesh holds this and proves
us wrong you can hear it in our voice
we're expecting a farouza comeback it'll
be an even bigger shout out to the young
man from India who many have also
circled as one of those guys who will be
a future Contender for the title uh all
right Queen to be one
we're trading nights here that's that's
actually really good for white because
A6 will fall for sure and the bishop and
Rook are two of the best pieces at
holding down a long distance
relationship dania's been trying to hold
down long distance relationships for
years and it hasn't been hasn't been
easy has it
it has not how did you know maybe Siri
told you that as well Knight takes
before gukesh taking a chunk off of
White's punch and if you're all he has
to take that Knight take A6 put a Pawn
on B5 and enjoy your life with five
seconds on the clock he's gonna do to
look for Adventures the rook and Bishop
they communicate well that pawn is going
to B5 the bishop will protect it this is
is is a very diff I don't even know that
black is better at all anymore right I
mean objectively
not objectively but tell you what gukesh
needs to do he should have put the queen
up he won he missed the opportunity
train put it on B2 and start pushing
those King side pawns the idea open up
white skin because it's so easy to miss
a fork with no time on the clock go F5
be bold go cash and he is there he is he
does it you called it he does it
okay okay you're right yeah this is much
harder practically for white than I
realized the bishop and Rook are holding
the B Pawn but then what do you do you
can't Advance it any further now that
that Queen is on that perfect square
behind the pawn oh what a trap Queen
takes B5 Rook takes E4 is an immediate
draw don't take that poison Bond gukesh
now with five seconds Queen B1 and bring
your king up to E5 prepare F4 Danny if
he can squeeze this through I think he
wins the game wow wow yes no
wrong way don't yell at him he's like 12
years old man be nice he's a kid
go back to E5 if you're a go cash and
then play F4 okay oh but H5 H5 seconds
hello is it tender it's tender ah you
know what else is standard any the B5
Pawn
he goes for it
should be a drawn out take some Rook G3
maybe he's gonna win
this oh my gosh
oh my goodness you shush your mouth when
you're talking to me Ollie Reza gonna
come back and win this you gotta be well
now white can't lose this is obviously
still a draw Danny but White's King is
so safe your goal with white is to push
your Pawn look for Pins very easy to
blunder if you're black queen H6 Rook G6
for instance one second make a move oh
my gosh oh my gosh arugia doing farrugia
things
Fast and Furious 10 featuring farrugia
but Vin Diesel should consider a casting
call
for farusha uh Rook G4 and H6 Danny Here
Comes it's winning Johnny
I should say no whoa he had H6 he didn't
do it still has it
no this is over he's gonna put the
rookie on H3 but he has to be careful
about a Perpetual Queen G5 King goes to
the first rank yeah Queen C1 we know oh
my gosh uh oh SpaghettiOs I think he
might have walked into a Perpetual yeah
I jinxed him there Queen C2
Queen C2
is he gonna try to cover with his Bishop
he has to Queen C3 is the move here and
he finds it diagonal checks prevent
inter positions
Queen G5 again and we're already there
three times three times Bob's your uncle
Borussia was winning it's funny because
playing H6 instead of of bringing the
Rook behind the pawn when you called it
Johnny was winning but for rusia
Borussia is uh probably doing exactly
that right now look at him he's he's you
know what he's doing he's reviewing his
game right now hitting that game review
button lucky he's got a diamond
membership gets to review gets to review
his games
um all right some of the games that are
still going this is one of the last
remaining games for Russia could have
pushed that pawn once one move earlier
and he would have won video with the
black pieces is he winning no this is
going to be a draw why it's gonna take
all of us we've actually got the door
other Bishop just walk into the corner
and give up the night for free to show
the kids how it's doing give up the
night
do something fun all right now they're
just now they're just toying with us
delaying the start of the next round boy
am I excited about what's going on here
oh my gosh already entertainment all
around there are still a couple games
going oh this is still in a middle game
and the position incredibly clogged up I
mean against Hammer Danny and this is
like board 70 we're talking about young
Ludovic hammer and a mean top of the buy
who played in the Tata steel Challengers
they're like 50 boards down which speaks
to the insanity of this event
now can you speak to the insanity of
this position I was gonna say like the
insanity of the event only matched by
the insanity of the position can
somebody walk their King to like H4 For
Me Just for kicks and Giggles like just
put the Play Imaginary chess here there
is no breakthrough obviously blackhead
black does have one potentially with the
move before but uh yeah there's nothing
nothing to this position sorry for that
uh
you know what I do I put the G8 Rook on
C8 but these B6 stroke on A6 and in
Hammer's time pressure B4 is not to be
trifled with but I don't think or sorry
an immune system pressure yeah I don't
think camera is going to go for it it's
just not his style
he doesn't he accepts that this game is
meant to end peacefully trading Queens
although hold the phone is he going to
block it oh my gosh he's gonna walk his
King all the way all right everybody
this is your chance if you needed to use
the restroom or heat up your coffee it's
the time because I think we're gonna be
in this position for the next 17 hours
it really depends on on the disposition
of the players now hilariously F5
followed by G6 is a serious idea here
because black can't take with the H
spawn because H7 actually promotes with
the King on f8 but I think neither
player is really thinking in that
direction but I mean might have brought
his King to H4 to take a risk here and
play F5 and he does oh he does it oh my
gosh he's going oh my gosh oh my God
Hammer had a million ways to prevent
this Danny he should have kept his Rook
on E8 in order to keep E6 protected
after FG I think he forgot that the H1
promotes he's gonna have to take with
the F1 and hope for the best dude what a
heads up fine by you Dylan what a heads
up fine by amine Tava to buy for those
who don't know remember that name now
you heard if H takes H7 and you get a
queen if F takes you could even just
take E6 right away I guess you should
right and then King G5 to follow but
this is this is
is he gonna play King G8
white could obviously lose this as well
don't yeah
that's the funny thing is maybe maybe
all the hype was for not because
you may have pushed a little too hard
and white could get checkmated on G4 I
think that's what amine missed after
rookie fourchek the king is pushed away
and that's good G5 yeah Hammer's gonna
win this I think you overpriced oh
what's funny is I was suggesting King G5
instead of taking E6 sort of
accidentally but that was actually the
correct way for white to actually still
go for the draw not go for the win but
instead he goes for the win by taking E6
and black has now turned the tables
but that's one of those losses where you
take your hat off and you applaud and
maybe the gods of Chess are going to
applaud and give Amin a lucky break
because this game is not over yet he's
going after H7 he has a pass Pawn
already Cameron needs to find a way here
to keep that H6 spawn contained while
pushing his own passers he's got a lot
of choices and only 30 seconds to make
them no not at all he was supposed to
play rookie seven first to guard the
seventh rank stopping Rook D7 and then
oh my God why could very well win this
I
I'm happy to be here speechless
now I think the game's gonna end in a
Perpetual check I think Hammer's gonna
take the pawn on C3 and perpetually
check White's King because there's no
other way to stop H7 after The Rook
moves out of H7 which it is if he's not
gonna lose on time and he doesn't
draw no he's going for it now
oh my gosh this is terrifying
checking in on the standings to my left
ear by the way everybody don't worry
this is the only game still in progress
here in round one of the Swiss portion
for the air things Masters playing so
thanks for being with us don't go
anywhere the day has just begun and you
can see the leaderboard to the left
there are a bunch of the biggest names
in the game already got their dubs
Judah was lost according to the chat so
some early swindles here this game just
has an endless number of stages every
time we think there's resolution the
players find a way to keep going but I
finally think amina's forced to draw in
the event of The Rook trade White's
pawns are unapproachable and so are
blacks the Kings have to shuffle this is
a draw what a game and what a fair
result honestly yeah honestly Poetic
Justice
uh it's fun to see that while the white
pawns are not connected in the same way
the black ones are done yet this is an
instructive you know King and pawn
example for the viewers that if you get
those pawns a Knights jump away my coach
always used to say the king is stuck in
a cage because if the king tries to go
around to C7 and B6 the other Pawn
advances and they stay a night's jump
away and the king is frozen so a fun
little instructive Point as you go too
far well now you lose you can't go too
far all right game on the second round
has begun welcome to the air things
Masters playing so much at stake here in
the 2023 Champions chess tour as we are
officially underway it has been a long
time long time coming for the shout out
to the whole team it works super hard to
get here both the chess.com crew those
who joined recently to the chess.com
family from the PMG group of companies
Dania
I'm just I'm just excited I'm like a
little kid and I'm a big fan of yours I
know hi big fan here big fan of Don well
I'm a big fan of yours that's uh that's
quite interesting how that works the
two-way street Danny but I'm excited to
be here I feel like I've reached into
the cookie jar and found like my
favorite treats no please the floor is
yours no I was gonna say what what is
going on in this interesting little
opening with the Knight coming to D2 by
by Hikaru but you're right as long as
you don't get your your hands stuck in
the cookie jar then we'll have plenty of
cookies to watch all day because we can
go here I've got yonda Palm machine
taken on Alexander Linderman that's a
fun one there for those who follow
Linderman we've got uh We've I mean so
where do you want to go where do you
want to go YouTube let's go to Yan
because Hikaru again he's played a quiet
opening he's actually shown a propensity
for one D4 in his recent Blitz Games so
Hikaru I think chooses an opening or a
first move and he essentially plays it
for a couple months and then he switches
it up here he's playing an offbeat
trumpowski pretty quiet position let's
go to Yan's game all right I'm going to
click into it Alexander Linderman one of
the top American players now for many
many years total nightmare opponent in
Rapid Danny because he plays very
quickly in classical as well he is just
one of those guys that nobody ever wants
to face in any tournament completely
completely agree uh like you known Alex
for a very long time uh one of those one
of those just super underrated players
as you mentioned especially in the rapid
format because of his he's got a lot of
confidence plays very quickly right now
holding his own a little bit worse
against the uh one of the two
Challengers for the world title in a
Yonder Palm machine and uh
what do we got here was this was this a
Petra from an exchange French I didn't
see the beginning of the game it was a
pet shop I was a pet shop good call yeah
yeah and it's one of those typical Petro
Physicians or white see a tiny bit
better you could ask why and I'll tell
you it's because partially white has
this little Pawn chain that's keeping
the Knight on C6 incredibly restricted
black doesn't have that equivalent which
means D5 it's not a huge weakness
because it's hard to attack but it's a
little tender and nepo could consider a
very nepo-like move in 95 saying I'll
let you get that night off the board but
you're gonna have to give me the pawn on
D5 I'm calling it I think nepo's going
95 here or Knight F1 if you want to be a
little bit more positional yeah
I kind of like 9f1 and educating me here
asking for all my friends in chat who
aren't Grandmasters isn't 95 helping to
clarify a little bit of black situation
I obviously if you take it the rotates
and you're forking then I don't have
five and the pawn on D5
but do you really want to help black
clarify that night that's blocking the C
Pawn because black does eventually want
to play C5 but how many is it just that
concrete that 95 is strong because you
can't take it well first of all I'm
going to clarify something else I think
nepo Nature has called during the game
which does happen sometimes uh now I'm
gonna take that opportunity to address
your point after 95 the issue is very
concrete conceptually you don't want to
allow black to get rid of the Knight but
as I mentioned 95 rookie Five Forks the
Knight on F5 and the pawn on uh D5 you
would like to bring the Knight back to
E7 if that is occupied by the bishop the
problem is if you support the Knight on
C6 uh even worse things await you
because now after rookie five the bishop
is undefended if the Knight moves here
you might lose a piece and finally Danny
that only leaves one option you have to
move this Knight away giving White full
control of the center allowing the queen
to hit the other night and now you could
carry on with your life you could try B4
and Knight C6 Yan loves these types of
concrete ideas Jan also poses problems
very early in the game which is what
makes him so incredibly successful in
the rapid time control I think more so
than other players he looks for these
problematic ideas as early as he
possibly can if of course he ever comes
back to his computer I was going to say
right now he's got a different type of
problem it might be that he didn't
calculate what he had for breakfast or
how much coffee he drank there exactly
he's back at it he does indeed quickly
play Knight to you how long did that
take him Danny a little second I wasn't
on the uh I didn't have him on the clock
there but uh no you're right nepo does
pose problems let's also remember that
nepo has become a little bit of an
expert in this line not someone you
think of immediately when it comes to
the Petrov guys like Wong how guys like
Fabiano caruana Dania but we know that
he prepared the Petra for his world
championship match versus Magnus Carlson
in Dubai in 2021 and so and and we've
seen him play more of these games
recently in his career so he's becoming
a bit of an expert on all the little
idiosyncrasies of the move orders in the
Petrov there's a common piece of Chess
wisdom Danny that I call total BS on
pardon my French which is that if you
are a expert in an opening then you hate
facing it from the other side and that
might be true emotionally but if you're
a Petra player which John now has been
for several years you might not like
facing the Petrov when you're on the
other side uh of the shoe but but you
don't know as you said all of the
idiosyncrasies you're gonna know all of
the little ideas a little waste and
needle your opponent which you can
definitely do on the white side of the
Petrov this is precisely what Jana's
doing Alex he kind of admits defeat
there with Knight B8 and nepo continuing
to tighten the screws and you know
squeeze things up on the on in the
center he's now much better so his
slight Advantage has morphed into a more
serious and more enduring advantage
I love what you said there I actually
think it's instructive for a lot of our
motivated improvers out there shout out
to the hashtag chess punks movement I
think it's funny Daniel when I was
younger I almost tried to design my
repertoire so I never had to face my own
openings but if you do the math is
actually not possible but that's the
emotional bias we have we don't want to
face our opening but as you just
described being an expert in something
actually makes you even more effective
at playing against it and even though
it's an emotional thing like you said
you're on showing just how well he knows
the white side of an opening that he
used effectively uh as black against
Magnus Carlson and so I just I love that
point I think I think players out there
trying to map their repertoire should
take note of that and really just allow
themselves to dive into learning and
becoming experts in a position rather
than trying to emotionally navigate
those circumstances so yeah and if you
want to really become an expert in
opening you actually should play it with
both colors because as I said when the
shoe is on the other foot you just get a
different perspective you you deepen
your understanding of what ideas are
actually annoying and John's showing us
how to pose problems in the Petrov his
Advantage has stabilized can we go to
Fabiano caruana's game can we give
American players oh my gosh oh my gosh
we're completing each other's
sandwiches I was literally just gonna
call that game out because it had
because it had all my all my favorite
things opposite side castling positional
weaknesses for both sides complete
disregard for where our pieces should be
placed it's like I'm playing chess on
this anymore I need to interrupt too
you're naming all of these factors
you're forgetting one thing which which
already pre-determines the result of
this game
would you care to tell me what opening
black plate ah the French it's over
white wins okay we can we can actually
just move on if you'd like I yeah I
don't know I mean I think just for the
purpose of the chat we'll discuss the
position but essentially the result of
the game is predestined so kobalenko has
played a French this is actually a very
typical type of situation with opposite
side castling that arises in What's
called the win hour variation black
brings that dark Squad Bishop out early
black is in huge trouble Danny and it's
not because the king's on the queen side
it's because of the weaknesses in the
center look at that monster Knight look
at how weak the pawn on E6 is on a G6
the open B file Danny The Rook can move
to A1 and trap the queen E6 or k110 oh
my god he has some major problems to get
out of and and you highlighted in the
winter where black brings that Bishop
out and you see that trade on C3 happen
which is how do I got those double pawns
but Rook gay one it's over 985 Queen B4
I mean car one is like two accurate
moves away from just ending black on the
queen side and I'll tell you how he does
it okay do it you go do it before real
quick B6 now you bring the Rook to B1
black is paralyzed let's make a random
move for black now I like oh my God
keep going keep going
yes
oh my gosh I love it I saw Bishop F4
coming as you were instructing me and I
was sitting there like a kid just like
feed me feed me spoon feed me I love it
this was awesome man
yeah Cowboys was in big trouble you
might say well what black is just gonna
sit around and allow that Over My Dead
Body black is so paralyzed you know he
has his hands full with the weaknesses
in the center and that's how the sides
of the board are related Robert Hess
would I think be proud of this
observation he likes to cut the board in
half or cut the board into three
segments White's not attacking the pawn
on E6 white is using that pawn to tie
black down so that he could effectively
operate on the queen side not over just
yet I think I spoke a little bit too
soon but Fabby should finish this one
off maybe rookie B1 to start
I think I think uh okay he does he does
exactly what you said he's also you know
just deadly focused looking great with
that haircut by the way Fabi looking
fresh cut down the fro uh and uh Chad's
saying Favi looks happy which is funny
because anytime you're reading Fabiano's
body language as a means to evaluate how
he feels a little a little part of him
dies inside because he hates that which
is why I continue to do it he hates it
but uh This is Just Awesome by the way
can someone on the staff uh staff
watching this just impersonate Bobby's
account and upload an avatar picture for
him normally I would ask a grand master
before I do it but I know fobby will
deal with it later don't do it right now
because it'll kick him out of the live
server and then we got other problems
but he should have he should have not
not a blank Pawn there
um any Hooters but Bobby looking fresh
Bobby looking like he's about to move to
two of two as long as he puts this one
away and uh
and good stuff and and again kids don't
play the French that is a very Fabby
move right there Queen B4 was winning
Queen C1 also looks fantastic he's
massaging he's enjoying the position and
when I say black is paralyzed I'm not
exaggerating Queen B7 nope Rook takes A5
try to move your Rook You're Gonna Lose
E6 try to move your knight Queen's gonna
get to E5 Queen's gonna get to E5 anyway
and that check on B8 is going to send
the worlds Crashing Down
I love it the queen slides to E1 Here
Comes Queen E5 you actually can't stop
it
like oh how many times are you in a
position how many times are you in a
position down here where a queen is
obviously trying to move to a Central
Square and there's not a single move on
the board that can prevent it pawns
don't go backwards the pieces can't
maneuver this is such an instructive
lesson in the weaknesses of a color
complex and the dark Square dominance
white is capable of in a French that
maneuver by the way was sick Queen B2 to
C1 at E1 and E5 now how many times do
you say those words
kovalenko just you know biting some
chunks off the cake side Fabby says ask
me if I care I call this pinching a
dinosaur he is looking squarely at the
center and at the queen side okay
kobalenko eliminated whites Bishop a big
deal white still has all the pieces that
he needs he's now up in exchange and
white could even go in for the kill with
Queen D6 you could even just ignore that
Knight because it's in the Lion's Den on
G2 it's not getting out of there
I love it I I want to see this finish
because I think we're moments away just
for fans to know Borussia looks like he
might be bouncing back with black we
could check over there lachus SQ which
is Yonder Palm machine uh also in an
interesting exchange exchange sack
versus Slenderman so many games will try
to get to him
um as you know we are only in round two
here as we kick off the 2023 Champions
chess tour and the air things Masters
plan
um
Hikaru also still in battle in uh in
this particular round too a really
interesting one he's he's actually on
the worst side of a position right now
so we might want to go check out let's
do that uh the biggest streamer in the
chess in the chess category here in a
second
is going to resign literally any second
now because he's lost one night he's
going to lose the other one on G2 and at
this point Checkmate isn't the problem
the problem is why it's going to trade
queens and be up a full rook in the end
game and Igor admits defeat what a
textbook game did that was an amazing
game I recommend people in the chat to
look at that from the start textbook
game and that's what 10 plus two
produces you get that quality of Chess
speaking of quality of Chess you can
expect quality from ikaru and clearly
you can expect it from his opponent he
car was in big trouble here with the
white pieces
I agree and for those who don't know who
he's playing here uh that's one of the
stars for the previous shangdu pandas of
course China will be back in the protest
League it's been a minute but uh the
protest League always brings a huge a
huge the strong team from China and this
is um this is a position where Hikaru
has his work cut out for him don't you
yeah but he wins about 95 of losing
positions so I'm not getting too worried
yet Rook a to d8 was an alpha move I
think if I read his opponent right after
Rook takes A7 he actually wants to push
the pawn to F3 and get the Rook to D2
and he just senses that the threats
against whites King are going to be
overwhelming the problem is that when
you're playing Hikaru no matter how many
pieces you have around his King and I've
experienced this firsthand countless
times he is unimatable the rules of
physics do not apply when you've got
your forces around hikaru's King it
acquires super powers every time you
start talking about your own experiences
versus Chicago I want to check your
pulse I'm going to make sure you're not
having any flashbacks I want to ask you
if we should do some trauma therapy you
know uh yes all those things because he
does he does leave a mark uh and when he
when he swindles his way out of out of
tough positions even even uh even
against the world's best players but
right now though let's let's give credit
where credit's due there's a reason
hikaru's head is in hand uh because F3
and Rook D2 as Donya highlighted are
coming you can't take a seven
because of this idea or or can you
should we just
should we just take a quick little pick
here right can we just do it just not
only can you Hikaru does this all the
time he just doesn't buy his opponent's
main ideas I'm calculating this Danny
and I'm getting skeptical about F3 in
this position so is the eval bar Rook D2
yeah yeah that produces fireworks but
the simple Queen G3 well no that's not
the move apparently let's check why oh
and you want to know why Danny this is
amazing F2 and now the most
anticlimactic looking move ever you
actually take the queen
what are you doing you can't oh no not
working five no I said we'll get five
yeah yeah no I Mouse lift okay now Rook
takes C5 you combine it with the other
idea which is to get the Rook to E1
let's just stop it's a ridiculous idea
you just stop you shush your mouth when
you're talking variations like oh my
gosh but I don't here's the funny thing
I don't think a car who saw that maybe
he did but Willie's opponents see it
because
oh it's H4 H4 would hold the position I
see not Queen and win for white and to
win for white so long story short as
Hikaru takes on A7 black needs to double
back and go Rook F7 in the live position
which I'm gonna get to
right here I am really worried that
Shang Yu has missed the move H4 in that
position this is what Hikaru just spent
three minutes trying to find I can
guarantee you that he will play it this
is a big moment F3 actually loses the
game ridiculous
yeah I'm
he's thinking about it he's down on time
one of the other things that makes
Hikaru so hard to beat of course is
great stuff by black he finds it
straight
you is the person playing Black again he
plays for the Sean do pandas now I think
the China pandas in the protest League I
I I believe but uh shu shengyu is uh is
gonna be a name you get to know over the
next few months ladies and gentlemen
just be ready for that because he is
dynamite when it comes to these fast
time controls he helped lead the pandas
to a live finals in San Francisco the
last time we held it in 2019 and uh he's
a monster that you know China has become
kind of kind of like Russia Dania and
that there's just so many strong players
right the culture runs so deep Eastern
Europe you just get Grand Master after
Grand Master and China has so many
players you don't even know about that
are some of the best players in the
world and you look at their rating and
the rating doesn't necessarily breathe
fear into your mind because you're so
used to seeing the top guys and if they
don't have a seven in the hundreds digit
and a five or a six in the ten station
yeah whatever no not whatever and this
is what I love about these qualifiers
they're giving people new players to
root for and some of these players might
be a little bit lower rated they might
not get all the invites to the top
events but they will capitalize on the
opportunities when they get them and
Shang Yu is one of those players Rook F7
is a great move but Hikaru is not ready
to die just yet he tosses the queen out
of G5 I think he's gonna bring his final
Rook into the game and there's a sense
in which Danny maybe the eval hasn't
changed objectively but I feel like
Hikaru has repelled the immediate
threats after three though might still
be incredibly nasty he's lost but let's
see if Hikaru can hold on here uh for a
couple more moves to get black into time
pressure he's shaking his head because
Queen takes C5 would have been met by F3
and that would have blown open White's
King side so instead he knows he has to
sack The Exchange and he's going to play
Bishop C4 though
I I think that I think that as much as
he's shaking his head as soon as that
Bishop lands on C4 I don't care that
much about what the eval says I'm
looking at a Hikaru I know that shake
head nod you know what that was that's a
car number 11. yes he's acknowledging
he's worse but he actually already sees
the path toward rebounding that's that's
this that's a car number 11. he's
actually gonna come back and win this
game I'm calling it oh that's the moment
moment in his stream when he's been
losing and then you hear him say that
actually this actually might not be
somebody I think I better messed it up
and when he says those words or any
variation thereof you know you're in
trouble now what's the material account
black is up in exchange but white has
zero pawns for the exchange at the
moment Danny but Hikaru is eyeing these
juicy morsels on C5 and E6 he's also
looking at the pawn on E2 may seem
insignificant with the Queens on the
board with the Queens off the board
white is still going to have serious
chances because of that outside passer
and it's funny from a practical
perspective the eval from a concrete
perspective the eval is still better for
black but from a practical perspective
the type of advantage on the board
everyone has completely changed black is
not going to be going to be mating white
anytime soon although this was a very
good move coming to D2 black is going to
have to try to convert with that extra
exchange which makes it hard when you
have an open King if white gets Bishop
C4 the diagonals are getting frisky here
comes that eval bar already creeping up
for white this is a different kind of
game than what black had just a few
moves ago
so easy to lose control here black might
have to go all in take the plunge and
give up the other pawn and just squeeze
F3 at all costs Hikaru though might not
engage after Rook D2 white can bring the
queen up to F3 White's King is the
safest that it has been probably in the
last 20 moves wax King is starting to
feel a little bit uncomfortable with
this bishop coming to C4 there are some
mating Nets with the Rook takes H6 sack
Danny if the King goes out to each it I
know that sounds crazy but it can be a
reality in four moves hey if listening
to you sounds crazy I don't want to be
sane all right I love what I love what's
coming out of your mouth right now
Bishop C4 Rook H6 Queen pops up to the
maybe the G4 Square H5 or G4 yeah H5 and
queen H4 this is getting this is getting
spicy also
under 30 seconds on the clock that's a
big problem
at this point if Hikaru doesn't win this
game he's going to be very disappointed
if he draws he's not going to be happy
he knows that this game is turning
around with every move okay Rook D2 is
on the board now Queen F3 yeah
but given Black's time situation Danny
maybe he grabs this Pawn I don't know he
goes back to E2 I'm surprised that that
one I don't think that
that was an interesting move by hikar he
obviously likes his his A2 Pawn I think
that Queen F3 giving up A2 followed by
Bishop C4 was more what the doctor
ordered obviously it's it's not
something you do often when it comes to
Downing doubting Hikaru in these in
these formats and in these moments but
it looked like a strange decision yep
that was a very bad move by Hikaru I
mean he got excited at the prospect of
not getting checkmated too much so
because now the remaining Rook is active
Queen E3 Danny is a huge positional
threat the Queens get off the board and
black gets the rook td2 and white just
might not be able to push these spawns
in time not over though 23 seconds let's
see what Hikaru can come up with to
confuse matters here no but he's shaking
his head he also agrees rookie too
something was misevaluated there he did
he just flat out miss queen E5 Queen E3
or was there something else that he
thought was there that no longer exists
we're gonna find out because yeah yeah
no I this is bad this is bad Danny I
mean maybe he just pushes A4 and throws
caution to the win maybe that's what you
need and that's what he does but Queen
E3 still looks winning but I guess to
calculate that with 18 seconds it's
still a three result gaming car might
very well win this game
I've seen everything from him yeah I
have I have as well and I at the same
time you've given black a concrete
approach so unless you overthinks that
he needs to move he plays G5
at all we can get your king allowing the
a pawn forward Hikaru immediately kind
of kind of perked up a little bit Queen
F3 he's he's he's laughing in the face
of danger when it comes to Queen E3 now
and the a pawn is getting frisky uh oh
Danny it's gonna reach A6 guess what
that's a checkpoint as I call it because
that pawn is permanently defended by the
bishop black putting pushing his chips
into the center of the table and he
carved defending the bishop probably one
second he's gonna flag oh my gosh there
was G was there G4 and queen E3 okay I
don't even know but one second again oh
C4 what a move that would have been
intercepting the bishop but Queen E6
grade 2 Danny because he's threatening
Queen takes Pawn utilizing the pin
against the bishop yukara might not be
able to defend against that because
Queen B7 check abandons that Bishop the
Queen's gonna have to come right back
oh my gosh Chicago leaning in shaking
his head the nerves are real losing this
early it's not like your opponents get
easier in this format everybody if he
loses this game he might not be
qualifying for match play at least not
when it comes to division one so make no
mistake this is an absolutely huge game
in today's event and what a move the
bishop can now move fine Bishop C4 gets
mated in two moves with Queen E1 BC Rook
C Rook A1 Danny and queen B6 is
Checkmate you don't even need to take
the Acer it's made in this is Rook a11
Queen B6 is over mate oh my gosh oh my
gosh
with the upset heard round the world
here on Twitch here on chess.com just
like that we have drama everybody buckle
up this is what happens when you get a
whole lot of the world's best players in
one room this isn't gonna be a cakewalk
for any of them including the best known
as Sakara Nakamura so don't go anywhere
Dania we're gonna take a very very quick
break when we return it will be round
three as we kicked off the 2023
Champions chess store today with the
play-in for the air things Masters
hey everybody it's Danny here and as you
may know chess.com and chessable are now
one and I'm here to show you how you can
make your chest.com and chessable one in
just a few clicks to start let's log in
and connect our chess.com account I just
scroll right here above the browser and
click login scroll down and click
continue with chess.com now if you're
already logged into chess.com it's just
gonna ask you if you want to approve
that connection I'm going to say yes sir
but after approving it'll bring you
right back to the chessable home page
now the puzzle connect feature can be
found under Tools and you click puzzle
Connect Now what that does after you
type in your username is it's going to
pool positions from the games you've
played on chess.com create your very own
personalized chessable course and then
quiz you with the positions where you
may have missed the best move and the
more you play on chess.com the more
games it will have to quiz you as long
as your account stays connected it's
pretty sweet and it's going to help you
get better learning for the mistakes in
your games yes this is a pro feature
accessible but if you go to
chessable.com link you can get 30 days
of
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
welcome back round three is underway in
the air things Masters playing here as
we kicked off The Champions chess tour
in the year of 2023 in case you're lost
on the interwebs let's remind everybody
very very quickly because we got games
to get to of what is at stake today
Donya it's the Swiss stage ultimately
everything is going to come down to who
gets in to the top 76 and then even more
importantly who makes the top 12 for a
chance to compete in division one and
ultimately not just the knockout next
week but perhaps punch their ticket
directly to the finals on February 10th
so this is a big day we are deciding the
seedings for all three divisions that
will take place when The Knockout begins
next week but Dania I understand right
as we had to fill that break forgive us
everybody and a crazy ending happened in
the Perugia game that you're going to
show us yeah this happens during the
Hikaru game we can't cover everything
but we have to debrief this really
quickly then we'll get to the live
position in round three this is the
position alireza had with black he is
down one two
three pawns I can't you know four pawns
and he finds a Perpetual check or so I
thought as I was watching this unfold he
checks and checks and his opponent is
seconds on the clock ultimately his
opponent finds a maneuver where he gives
up one Queen and makes another but Danny
suddenly White's King is in danger
alireza manages to run away then he gets
his Pawn to H3 and white makes a second
Queen and he gets mated with a pawn this
was insane oh my she shows you that
anything can happen in time scrambles
those are not empty words we say to keep
people in front of the screen this
happens on a round by round basis
alireza has earned our coverage of his
next game against azerbaijani GM
received through our Bailey
what a crazy finish for those wondering
that was not paid acting by me I hadn't
seen the game yet we we all wanted to
get to it that was absolutely insane in
my head Donya I'm like what was white
supposed to do instead of allowing H3
there must have still been a chance for
a draw there but okay we're going to
focus on the moment and Shout out for
ruja who found a way to own it and get
that checkmate with a Pawn on H2
and he needed that win too because let's
not forget he narrowly skirted a loss
and on one made a draw against some guy
named gukesh now he really has a chance
to make a push but Dora Bailey he played
very well yesterday in the PCL
qualifiers yeah and the Ferocious
tacticians ended up losing their finals
match they didn't quite make it but he
is not a pleasant opponent
yeah for those for those who don't know
Dura Bailey uh uh one of the uh one of
the absolute strongest chess players in
the world Azerbaijan Grand Master and uh
he uh he is a force to be reckoned with
especially in these faster time controls
yeah he's a very strong GM he plays for
the win every game just like most
deserved by Johnny GM's white black he's
gonna play something on balance with a
lot of life and in this game he played
the night off maybe not the wisest call
against Sully Reza farusha and farusha
has gone very positional Danny he's
Castle kingside he's clamping down on
the D5 score and that's why he made his
last move Bishop G5 this directly
prevents the Breakthrough with D5
because white will take the Knight and
recapture on D5 with a fork last thing
I'll say Danny Queen B6 Queen takes B2
there was not a blunder because white
traps the queen with Rook have to be one
yeah and Knight A4 oh not 94 because
Queen D4 was for fb1 okay yeah great all
right so Queen B6 check wasn't a threat
he puts the King on H1 though just to
avoid any checks in the future
it's interesting you say Perugia played
positionally totally agree but that D in
that D6 Pawn right there at some point
is going to tell the story will white
find a way to get pressure on the D file
normally in a night or if you have a
bishop on E7 or something to guard that
pawn black is actually playing whoa a
dragon hello
Knight F5 sign me up buttercup let's go
for the attack I love it
what was that about playing positionally
Mr commentator says an angry alireza
farusa yeah he's like uh don't tell me
what I can't do it's not a positional
game
it's a Checkmate attack underway let's
just quickly show gf5 EF5 the bishop on
E6 would be trapped so white would not
only regain material but then have the
bishop pair and the light squares
bursting open toward the king side to go
with it yeah the problem isn't even the
bishop which yeah you're gonna give back
but after something like Knight D4 which
maybe is what black should do if you
just look at Black's King here with the
white Bishop controlling the light
squares something like Bishop H6 maybe
even F4 uh to blast the king Side open
just from a practical perspective with
six minutes left this is insanely Hard
to Handle alireza farouza he's feeling
it after that last window he's not about
to let that opportunity pass him by when
you Swindle a game like that Danny you
got to make it count in the next rounds
I love it and I love how you said from a
practical perspective because I think
for a lot of people looking at these
games these guys they understand that
it's a it's a fast time control it's a
rapid format and playing for practical
ideas like two Bishops facing toward an
enemy King that that's where you that's
where you pay your bills right there
right that's your money maker and
farrugia knows that even if objectively
black should be okay White's attack is
going to be very hard to deal with those
light Square problems are going to be
are going to be very very big
well he might have a pretty big electric
bill if he doesn't dim that light on his
camera on his uh camera there speaking
of bills but Bishop F6 Oh by Dora Bailey
he
he says yeah I've lost that battle but
let me try to take some heat off of
White's King side attack this is a very
dangerous move giving up your fee and
ghetto Bishop in any position uh is not
something you often do voluntarily but
yeah Danny if Ali Reza takes his own
dark squid Bishop is also a key engine
of the attack he can try Bishop F6 and
then Queen H6 but black can take F5 at
the right moment but that's what I
wanted to look at I'm sorry you got to
educate this International Master Bishop
F6 Knight F6 Queen H6
gf5 I even have Queen F6 if I want
okay now EF5 and that's your now I'll go
D5 and I'll keep the protective cover
alive and if you just throw caution to
the wind it's a common thing Danny over
sacrificing eventually you just run out
of pieces where are my minor pieces you
don't have any left so this is how
whites attack you know hits a brick wall
but alireza isn't gonna do that I don't
even think he's gonna take F6 I think
he's gonna find something a little bit
trickier yeah so I'm gonna go back to
the live board here I love it after
blacks Bishop F6 let's see what alireza
comes up with I love it I love it I want
more of it thanks for uh thanks for
humoring there uh humoring my uh my
desires to see how that attack might
play out you're right so now it looks
more like why she keep the tension
Bishop H6 is a candidate move that comes
to mind right even just like this is
crazy but even like Rook a to D1 right
you were gonna highlight it on the same
page as look at that visual just build
on the tension right get the water up
against the dam so that when it breaks
through it's not a trickle right it's a
flood and that's what you want to do is
build up on this pressure moves like
hurricane Z1 is why when you look at
these complex GM games it always feels
like their pieces are just
automatically on the right squares
nothing is hanging they get all those 50
50 positions to go their way that's a
false narrative it's because they make
these setup moves alireza is having none
of the setup moves he wants our initial
line and or Bailey doesn't take the
Knight he goes for your idea Knight oh
I'm skeptical about that one I got all
the squares covered for now Danny for
now he's okay Bishop takes F5 was better
your idea was definitely stronger for
some reason either that or there was
something there that neither of us saw
and neither did the computer but I think
we were right they got uh they got a
little bit of weight oh and he goes at
four oh look at that this is just this
is gonna be
you know TGIF it's Friday it's Freaky
farrugia Friday TM just made it up
Market gosh first version so first the
worst person to have this position
against and I've played enough 30 second
chess with him uh to know he's not
missing an opportunity for a rook lift
to H3 not to mention that F4 builds up
the tension on black center he's got
pressure on every side of the board
Center kingside I think Rook F3 is
coming next
oh boy is this going to be tough to
defend F6 is such a good move though I
know that White's still better with best
player everybody but that opens up the
communication let's talk about the sides
of the board again right the queen on C7
is now an actively participating
defender of not just G7 but also could
it go to F7 it guards the E7 Square the
H7 Pawn so Perugia kind of takes the cue
and says I'm gonna back up a little bit
I'm no longer maybe maybe okay with just
sacrificing my knight straight up
anymore let's go for the D5 Square
yeah he's backing it up but it's an
intermediate step to going forward again
Knight to D5 the issue with these types
of positions is that you've repelled the
attack congratulations I'll give you a
medal now you're positionally worse than
the centers now for Russia's eyes go
from the right to the left to that juicy
D5 Square Enduro Bailey is having to
burn tons of time to just keep White's
ferocious horses at Bay yep
I love it okay do we want to stick here
with Perugia we've got some other
players on 202 we paid off our debt
because we owed farugia a check-in given
that he won his last game if you just
joined us everybody where have you win
Where Have You Been he won his last game
with a pawn checkmating the king in a
crazy scramble I kind of want to look at
Vladimir kromnik's chess he's the 14th
World chess champion bro he shows up at
the last minute he literally texts me to
resend his password because he hasn't
logged in since the last time he was
kind of upset that he got flagged for
those of you who don't know the story
that's a you problem anyway vlad's back
he's playing in this event we got
increment let's see what the uh the
world Champion's up to
well Vladimir kramnik is one of my
favorite players he's also the only
former world champion that I've ever
faced In classical chess that was one of
the best days of my life even though I
lost the game and I'm not just saying
that those five hours I will never
forget in my entire life just the
feeling of sitting across from him
playing a classical game I gave him my
best he also played a novelty in the
grunfels that he had been cooking up for
10 years I happened to be the victim
moving on from that what an order no I
love this story yeah no I mean it was
amazing Danny and one of those things
you know you just always think about you
never forget you turn into in dark
moments just those memories uh is all
that really matters uh in your life but
right now he's making Curry alexanco's
life quite difficult with that pawn on
C5 supporting and not on B6 and that
night might turn into an even more
vicious pond I love it and and again
obviously I I gave the quick shout out
um to make sure I could tell the story
of him literally texting me to reset his
password but of course he's more than
just um frustrated about losing on time
this guy is still one of the absolute
best chess players in the world and you
see it when he shows up and don't be
surprised I'm calling it don't be
surprised if Vladimir karamik is Dancing
In The Knockout portion February 6th
through 10th right don't call it a
comeback he's been here for years this
guy is still just I mean he's a legend
he's the 14th World Champion he's a very
very underrated rapid player especially
with that increment that ensures the
quality of the chess will matter not
just the time scramble and there's a
reason he's two of two and and already
much better against alexienko listen
when people think of dominance over the
Chess World certain names comes to mind
kaspara Fisher Carlson kramnik might not
come to mind immediately but let's not
forget who ended Gary kasparov's
dominance over the Chess World it was
Vladimir kramnik in the world
championship match London 2000 he
defeated Kasparov in countless other
games and Danny topped that off with the
fact that kramnik in his prime was
probably the best Blitz player among the
super GMS something people might forget
so he is a nightmare opponent he's lost
a little bit of the speed he might have
lost a little bit of the luster he's
lost none of his incredible opening
preparation tactical ability and just
the ability to make life difficult with
both colors we see him there calm chill
he's chilling on his throne sitting on
who has a purple chair unless it's a
throne that is a throne look at that
thing that's a full zoom in on the
purple chair the Throne of the 14th
World chess champion is well intact uh
the the news of his demise greatly
exaggerated I'm sorry we don't get to do
this that often and this guy it deserves
it but I want to give one more shout out
to Chromebook because you mentioned me
while he may not come to people's mind
when they think of the greatest of
Carlson kasparovs Bobby Fischer's
whatever that is when we did our our
accuracy score ranking of the world
champions you can Google this right now
chess fans who's the most accurate World
chess champion ever which is the
accuracy score algorithm you see when
you do game review if you look at the
rankings there you might be surprised at
where Vladimir kramnik is ranked as far
as accuracy goes which means comparing
himself to the modern gods of the
Indians what quality of Chess did cronic
really play over his career forgetting
about the subjective sometimes results
and just his quality of his moves and
I'm not even going to spoil it for you
go check out just how good Vladimir
kronwick's career was in an article that
I wrote um several years ago when our
cat score which is computer accuracy
precision Score first became a big part
of our community
I'll tack on one more thing Danny
exploiting the fact that Alex senko
still hasn't moved after Knight B6 his
position is bad here he's got 90 seconds
kramnik also withstood a tremendous
amount of diversity health-wise people
might not remember this but around 2004
uh he developed a very rare and
debilitating case of arthritis uh that
persisted for several years during the
peak of his chess career so he was
managing that while also maintaining the
top level I mean I listened to an
interview with them and that raised my
respect for him so considerably I mean
to be able to manage that and keep your
chest level continue playing in
tournaments you know while he traveled
the world seeking treatment fortunately
luckily I think he's managed to keep
those issues at Bay uh and has for a
while now but Vladimir kramnik just such
an impressive figure uh we're blessed
with those kinds of Legends and
especially when they make appearances
which kramnik has today Queen C7 on the
board Alexa not ready to give up defeat
just yet he's trying to clarify the
situation on the queen side shout out to
you chat for bringing your A game here
purple chair sales just jumped 200
percent it's like a the the prince
reference you guys are you guys are
awesome thanks for uh thanks for playing
along having fun with us and uh hope
you're enjoying the show so yeah the uh
the Vladimir chronic chair and his
position a fantastic one H3 look at that
little Tempo move he wants to kick the
bishop off of the E2 Pawn before
deciding how he's going to take on D6
perhaps and then maybe maybe try to
grind home a very small advantage
against those Double D pawns on D5 and
D4
yeah it feels like maybe his execution
wasn't the greatest in the last two
moves on the other hand he's essentially
now playing without risk it's important
to know Danny that CD and Bishop F4 does
not win the exchange and not just
because black can take the Rook but also
because Bishop G7 and E5 intercepts the
pin so alexenko isn't losing material
Bishop to B4 also not possible black has
two defenses on that square a kramnik
move here I think would be something
like Queen A4 accumulate the pressure
threaten Bishop before and try to get
black to trade get control of the B file
speaking of which
Queen B4 that's a cram Nick likes to do
trade the Queens grind out that Russian
Schoolboy endgame advantage he's got a
three minute advantage on the clock
Alexa Yenko let's not forget also a very
very strong more of a rising star in his
right I don't know if we can call him
that anymore he did compete in the
candidates the coven postponed
candidates for those who remember uh
alexianco one of one of the top players
of course
from Russia and uh
and here he's going to have to defend
this worse end game against Chrome like
I'm sure kramnik is one of his Heroes as
well growing up
I I don't even have to pretend that
that's a fact I'm just sure it is so no
there are some things that you can just
take for granted ramnik he's
contemplating where to put that Queen
whether to move the queen he can play
Bishop before and get into the end game
in a slightly different way capturing
the queen with Tempo he does the same
thing on the other side and he sets a
trap while he's at it Danny you might
say that's a blunder Queen takes up four
wins a piece no it does not the counter
Desperado Queen takes A8 picks up the
exchange What A sly little devil Danny
guess what Bishop B5 another trap Queen
takes type four wins like a couple of
cowboys just sitting down play a board
game ain't nothing ain't nothing better
than on a lonely six months in North
Carolina you just sound like this for
the rest of your life man I'm telling
you all right uh this is this is gonna
be a slight end game pull for chromic
whether he gets the dub or not or
alexienko holds he's obviously off to a
pretty decent start here in the plan
um some other games of course some other
big names underway the standings there
you can see on the left on the left
shout out to Nicholas theodoro not a
name you know as well he's already on
three of three uh and uh many others
part of me always wants to check in with
Hikaru after he lost the game to see
what's in store for his position but if
you if you're spying other exciting
positions just just say the word and we
bounce to there I like the look of
andrekin Yankee but I also want to check
to hey car let's take a quick look maybe
at hikaru's game and then travel onwards
to Dimitri on Drake and I'm going to
click into Hikaru who plays uh not
curial uh
top Kazakh Grand Master that is a
nightmare pairing after her loss Danny
he knocked out Fabiano caruana at the
World Cup you swim in these Seas you
might get bitten every fish is a piranha
well it's what I said for those who were
tuning in obviously it's our job to
highlight drama but for those who know
us know that we're not faking it we're
just uh absolutely in love with what we
do and love the excitement and we said
it's hard if you lose this game if
you're Hikaru not just because it's a
loss but because the pairings don't get
any better it's not like you lose and
then get the Swiss Gambit where now
you're going to get a couple easy
peerings there are no games you can take
for granted so it's out of The Frying
Pan into the fryer literally for hakara
after losing now taking on through
mobile whoa and Juma Vibes Achilles seal
online I mean he always seems to be
better out of the opening has been his
time management and Hikaru is trying to
exploit that with some tricky moves he's
gotten all four Rooks off the board with
some tactics Hikaru is going to try to
focus his eyes he already has on that E5
Pawn there's a tight battle going on
around the control of that pawn if Juma
Baya wants to play for a win Danny he
tried D3 D4 but with one minute on the
clock I don't know if he should I think
he should just tread water a little bit
and uh this game might end in the draw
because neither side is able really to
do anything here
it's a good call
um jimabaya now under a minute though so
hakaro has that Advantage going for him
there's also the game by the way opari
Gregorian versus Fabiano caruana I I
don't know what to do you already
mentioned we've got 23 on Drake and take
it on you Young Yee the chess Panda one
two three baby uh I I mean let's
actually take a quick look at ondraken
versus Yu Yong Yi because it's not as
exciting as Gregory versus carwana we're
gonna get to this game evaluate the sand
game then we'll swing by carwana and
catch the end of his time scramble good
plans Annie and draken as the white
pieces here you can get also competed
yesterday didn't have his best event in
the PCL qualifiers uh oh he's lost the
C6 spawn just now I think Dima is going
to carry this one home he's going to go
back to D4 d5's falling wax pawns are
falling like flies here this has to be
winning for Dima yeah strange position
there suddenly uh one that looked like
equal we thought we'd be here for 30
seconds now we gotta stick around and
see the fun some good old friends
oh my gosh action everywhere Danny all
right our hands are tied we'll go back
to the to the end game we were just on
carwana of the household names that you
know in the game is the first to hit
three of three uh okay yeah it's over
he's losing on time Bobby winning with
black looks like he's brought some of
his best chests today but okay let's
head back to that end game we were just
in where Yu yongi is now desperately
trying to hold against Dimitri on Jerkin
uh oh and after that we got to go back
to the Hikaru game thanks heating up
there as well five seconds for you and
get two pass spawns to stop both of them
on the sixth rank on Drake it needs one
more shot he needs to blow on Black's
position and it'll fall like the three
little piggies House of straw Bishop to
G3 coming in he's the big bad wolf Honda
C7 is the big bad wolf there's another
Wolf coming to E7 and I think in that
ordered it Danny it's funny though the
Knight on the night
wait c77 sorry to cut you off
c77's doing oh okay yeah yeah he has to
give up the bishop with check and it's
over the queen comes to the board with
check
in my head I was just like no but black
can give up the bishop for the pawn and
then win that Bishop I forgot it was
check you give up the bishop the Knight
takes E7 with check and Bob's your uncle
and C8 okay exactly we uh we move
forward to Hikaru Nakamura if you're
just tuning in Where Have You Been
Hikaru suffered a heartbreaking defeat
against one of the the unknown soon to
be known stars from the China pandas in
the Pro chess League that is Shu zhangyu
and uh but now Hikaru is is really up
against it he could lose another game
yes to start this thing off we'll watch
the end of it I will say that kramnik is
about to win his game against alexenko
he did manage to convert that end game
yes he's just one but look at Juma bias
clock Danny this is what really has
killed his chances he gets these winning
positions but he just doesn't have that
additional gear that he gets into Hikaru
does let's see if Nakamura can create
problems he's much worse on the board
he's down a pawn White's got the
pressure on the king side blacks Knights
Danny this is perhaps the biggest
problem they have no score wears neither
of them yeah igaro knows it he owns it
he shakes his head he's like I know this
isn't great but I'm gonna do what I can
to mix things up on this now Mutual time
scramble
I thought he might be going after the E5
Pawn joomavive keeps it protected oh
careful now we're not he might try to
get his Queen around to E4 Danny but the
problem is if white over extends himself
you could get yourself mated you could
blunder a fork he doesn't care though he
wants to crush yukaro in this position
D4 making his intentions clear yeah D4
opens up the bishop on C3 to hit the B6
Pawn
Black's Knights are stuck Hikaru doesn't
quite know what to do
the Knight can't move because B6 Falls
if you play Knight C5 white will
probably take it then you gotta oh and
queen d8's Coming
Queen B3 was a devilish move threatening
the pawn on E55 that Juma Vibe knocks
the queen away any blunders C4 and there
we go oh my gosh that's the kind of
thing that happens
when you're facing off against Hikaru
and now in seconds
Danny that was the most important Pawn
on the board because they kept the night
at Bay now the Knight is like a tiger
out of its cage oh White's losing
everything that's crazy and Juma by
trying one last chance here but the
other night now comes back yeah and
comes through clutch defensively Queen
D7 coming I was gonna say now Hikaru can
get the Queens off the board Queen D7
was probably the simplest but Hikaru
wants more he's threat in Queen E2 by
the way uh
I think we need to his mate but kimchi
where's the decisive Crush I didn't see
the mate oh Queen H3 you can't even play
Bishop G2 Knight E2 Knight takes D no he
just takes ever all the pawns also
possible Queen takes H5 is even
completely when he's up three pawns by
now yeah I can just push that's it
What A Swindle all right save lost
positions crab cakes and football that's
what Maryland does saving lost positions
that's what Hikaru does and just like
that he's gonna keep his air things
Masters playing alive assuming he
finishes the job here against human body
what a crazy swindlish turnaround that
was
all it takes is one blunder and we're
just so used to hikar winning these
positions our expectations are so
outsized that when he actually loses a
lost position we're like how do you do
that 2650 opponent win this plus six
position but wait a second is still
trying yeah he is it's it's actually
kind of awkward made it hard for himself
and he only has six seconds oh Knight B6
was a nice move there uncapturable
because of the b-pawn
it shows you how hard it is to deal with
accentralized kingdanya and a bishop
pair the bishop here of the centralized
King are not easy
he's chopped off one Pawn But Here Comes
the others take B6 and Bishop E6 was a
draw oh my gosh you missed it
gotchaization
passive here no but the Bishops are so
irritating I mean look at them they're
just devilish making it super crazy you
could mate yourself if you're Hikaru you
have to be careful yeah but G3 wins
there's no oh he picks off the bishop at
his chances this game but he misses him
and Hikaru stays ahead with a win
wow he he plays Knight C3 that's uh
that's like a Hikaru Nakamura number 16
hand wave you don't see it that often it
means he it means he won but he knows he
didn't deserve it he deserves Moses win
so he's like ah whatever let's move on I
can't take this anymore all right well
uh you've got Chrome Nick on three of
three you've got Dimitri on Drake and
you've got Fabiano caruana and we've got
another game here levona rhodium with
white trying to get the win
win B7 who would you do oh sorry Queen
B7
no but the queen is on G2 is protected
so Levon gives up the Knight but you
can't take it because of Queen B7 what a
tricky move what a trick if you took the
Knight the skewer worked everybody Queen
B7 I think you can make a second Queen
you can take that pawn first lavon's
gonna win what a what an end game there
wow Maxine's king is too far away from
the H Pawn otherwise he could have taken
and gone H2
Maxim chigayv also someone you know and
and know him well from so many of these
events levonne aronian though gets the
win calmly
calmly does so we can we can take a
quick look at Lavon sitting pretty in
his big chair if we can he's got a
secret lab chair shout out to one of our
sponsors of the Champions chess tour
secret lab and uh lavon's got it along
with a nice little painting of a king
I can't tell if the king is falling if
it's a metaphor let's move on I'm not
I'm not I'm no good at art
well we got somewhere to move on I think
there's one game still remaining and it
is of course as we know from all the
title Tuesdays Danny if there's one game
left it's one of three end games it's
either Rook versus rook and one side is
playing rook and Bishop versus rook and
Knight versus Rook those end games are
notorious for being drawn objectively
but incredibly hard to hold with five
seconds on the clock
although after that little mistake by
white the king is out I don't know what
the move counter is that's usually not a
recipe for Success because you can only
Checkmate the King on the edge of the
board everybody and if we're close to 50
moves that just helped black big time
indeed but the King has once again
pushed to the side of the board this is
one of the defensive constructions I
think it's known as a poker in defense
where you basically keep tabs on the
bishop and do not permit White's King to
move in and close off its counterpart so
black Keeps The Rook in contact with the
bishop there are winning attempts
standing but they are also very hard to
find even harder than drawing this
sometimes is actually winning when you
actually get the king to the side yep
yep yep yep yep indeed and let's not
forget everybody that this game while it
may not have two of the household names
that you know there is a lot at stake
here remember the top 76 will move on to
match play and already have guaranteed
some spots for cash prizes and if you
win Donya pointed this out at one of our
one of our breaks as we were preparing
for the show everybody
in theory there's almost oh wait you
blunted into them you blunted into the
wind and white missed it it was Rook B6
you forced the king back yeah but that
actually there was a sequence after that
that was hard but now I want to hear
your point I think black is stabilized
again the the point is even if you're a
top Grand Master who misses out on
division one
winning division two guarantees a spot
in our next major event to be in
division one so there's so much at stake
with all three of the divisions and
there is not a single game here that
doesn't matter for any of these players
so it's just uh it's a fascinating
fascinating format shout out to the team
for that and it's something that's going
to make sure that people are focused all
the way down the stretch
yeah I agree Danny and I'm not one to
Just Praise the foreign
let me ask you is it easier
for a top player to finish 13th win
division two you sacrifice that you're
obviously not going to punch your ticket
to the CCT finals here at the yard
things Masters but you're guaranteed a
spot in division one when our next event
takes place in March is there a Swiss
Gambit potential where you just say yeah
if there weren't this many Grand Masters
playing and I'm gonna flip on Nico
Theodora's last game black has just lost
on time by the way that is infuriating
like three moves out of a 30 second draw
we're gonna show you the mate from Nico
Theodore's third win out of three games
let me quickly address your point no and
that's because division two might
actually look harder than division one
it's like the Western Conference in the
NBA the reigning NBA champions are in
eighth place some while tikara Nakamura
the one aronian could be in 56th Place
Good Luck winning division two yeah good
call okay good luck winning against Nico
Theodore when he's in this kind of form
look at that mate Danny this is sexy
Knight G5
Knight F7 and Knight F6 and you know
what I love about this aesthetically the
knights stacked on top of each other on
the G file and then stacked on top of
each other like a slinky on the f file
show them the end GTX F6 Queen H6 is
made just for those who as we said are
most visual Learners all the Vin Diesel
fans out there with their coloring books
there you go right there
um sorry I don't know why I'm always
picking on Vin Diesel or coloring books
first of all coloring is a fantastic way
to calm your brain it's actually very
good for mental health I don't know why
I said that I apologize I love you
coloring books Let's Move On talk about
the standings
um well the standings are wild look at
how many top guy I mean Vladimir kramnik
I always love seeing him at the top of
any Tournament standings you've got Dima
and draken caruana most of the usuals a
lot of The Usual Suspects on three out
of three but Danny are from everyone in
the field has thinned out considerably
borugia he's given up a draw Hikaru has
given up a loss and we're not even
seeing a lot of the top guys who are on
two out of three or even one and a half
out of three I'm looking for what games
are still going here because shouldn't
round four be underway
it is
it is and I just didn't go to it oh it's
underway let's go okay yeah let's go I
was experiencing decision anxiety I
didn't know whose game to click on but
RAV4 has just started Parham against
farusha is what I decided to click on
Danny but your call we can go somewhere
else I love it I love it just recently
we got a story right here right
obviously all there is a farusia no
longer representing Iran the country
with in which he was born Parham mugsulu
still from Iran so these guys are a
couple of former countrymen still
countrymen grew up together a couple of
the most talented people to come out of
the Middle East in the last several
decades so this is going to be an
interesting one with a lot of Fighting
Chess
and of course Iran just producing
incredible amounts of Chess Talent like
India this is just a great time uh to be
a chess fan because you've got so many
countries putting out exciting Talent
after exciting Talent speaking of
exciting alireza farusha one of my
favorite aspects of his style is the
fact that he plays the king's Indian
defense Danny I'm supposed to be
unbiased in every way as a commentator I
am not unbiased when it comes to
praising the king's Indian it is the
best opening against D4 we we will leave
being a biased for Robert next week for
Robert Hess next week in Oslo you and I
can be biased while we're here you know
Robert's not here to yell at us and say
stay unbiased take that Robert Hess
um watching somewhere from your
comfortable hotel room in Oslo I'm sure
it's wonderful
um anyway G4 look at this this is the
King's Indian where white is like hey
remember how black is supposed to get F5
and launch that King's Indian mating
attack uh not so fast I'm gonna be all
in with G4 and H4 and let's go
well a trick that only the king's Indian
insiders know Danny this is the secret
code word if you know you're a Kings
Indian player that pawn on H6 you might
think it's been hanging for five moves
what are the players smoking here Bishop
takes 86 is a trap because of Knight F
takes E4 this is uncommon you don't see
this in any other opening well here I
would actually take that Knight away so
it doesn't cause headaches then Queen H4
picks up the bishop and when all is said
and done and the bruhaha has subsided
black has not only a bishop pair but
easy access to the F7 F5 Pawn break
white is worse here so that pawn is
essentially Untouchable yeah so let's go
back to the live board because we've got
more tension on the king side that pawn
has inched forward to H5 Bruce just
dropped his Knight back and he still
wants to deliver that check to H4 in
response to G takes H5 you know it's
crazy this is uh a weird position okay
white plays H4 the other way to avoid
the check was to Castle along now but H4
I think much better because you don't
want to you don't want that Queen to
even be popping into that square H4 is
really interesting you're kind of
calling out the fact that if white if
black ever plays H takes G4 in some
positions you just play H5 right away
you don't even take back on G4 you just
bust through everything on the king side
now that you've got the pawn on H4 well
what I would compare the king's Indian
to is like that restaurant that isn't
amazing it's like a diner that's oh food
is just okay but you can never decide
where you want to eat so you always
default back to it black is always worse
and everything's Indian line you're
always almost checkmated but it's like
you know what the seats look like and
you know the coffee is good and you know
uh it's it's warm but it might not be
very warm on the king side if white
plays H5 taking the blankets off here
Arusha might be in some trouble he needs
to invent something fast maybe F5 to
meet fire with fire he meets fire with
his Knight as he brings it back to F6
well and he didn't parliam did not play
the move H5 that I I was suggesting he
took back on G4 and purusha is not going
to miss a beat to double down on
attacking the G4 Pawn but we might see
H5 now
even in the face of losing E4 and G4 you
can go all in in some of these positions
and just say let's go here comes the
Checkmate attack
um
or take five a night okay but it's rare
Danny it's rare he doesn't give up the
bishop but he does it because he wants
to throw caution to the win and I don't
know about G5 though now the Situation's
a little clogged up and black could very
well play I mean black might even
pre-move F5 and play that against
anything I know ferrugia he's looking at
that F1 he wants to push that thing
forward and get some real estate for his
Bishops it's a funny position don't you
talk a little bit before we check in on
some other games on the the way the
computers evaluate space right Pawn
structure I think I think the computers
like White's position rightfully so
right you've got these positional edges
but the long-term features in this
position if the Bishops eventually do
get out if the position becomes open and
that white king never finds safety on E1
guess what computers play positions
where their King is in danger of well
forever you know who doesn't play
positions like that well human beings
right this is a weird position where I
actually like perugia's practical
chances I do as well and Danny to that
point the king's Indian is one of the OG
anti-computer are openings because the
computers tend to over especially the
old computers not as much anymore
exactly they would give plus two plus
three ridiculous evals because white is
such a big space advantage and Black's
got some positional weaknesses that
computers can underestimate computers
can also be very nearsighted in these
types of positions where they think that
that space Advantage is just an imminent
win not so in human play as we see in
this position by the way looks terrible
if you look at it for five seconds look
at it for 15 and you might see well that
G6 spawn is hanging that Knight is
unstable that Bishop
to the game
Castle so Parham has to keep his foot on
the gas pedal but I don't know exactly
how to do that for rujo is a pawn up now
I think he's starting to recover here
is the oxygen exactly yes yeah yes hi
you know in 1972 Mikhail curvich okay
actually speaking of speaking of things
let's
it was Ripley it was actually real
results
all right that isn't here much anymore I
love it let's go look at a game between
two of the couple two of the guys on
three of three that's Dimitri on draken
and Nicholas theodoro because they have
had a spicy Affair and that position is
still
messy AF as the kids say which is Messy
as Bobby I've heard
give me an Advil and give me some
stockfish that's the only way I'm
figuring out what's going on here I'm
still counting the material okay so Five
Pawns versus six Pawns pieces four of
them rooked one of them for each player
Theodore okay he's not up upon any more
Dragon has just recaptured it this looks
like a king's Indian God all Haywire it
looks terrible for black Danny but the
evil bar holding steady maybe black will
bring his Bishop out and be fine here
and then go rook d8 and try to force the
Queens off the board I don't know what
do you think
uh I'm under so much pressure you asked
what I think of my I'm like the little I
am in me is so honored
um I also I also feel like black can
come to life quickly I know I know he's
underdeveloped but the moment that
Bishop hits F5 The Rook comes to d8
there is no material advantage I was
like you I was still counting things
because this position was such a mess
the more I look at it the more I feel
like black is actually kind of seen the
worst of it when I first looked at it I
thought is is on draken putting a knight
on F7 is this game almost over but no
yep black is defending and doing okay
you're exactly right and case in point
this was actually also a king's Indian I
guess they all know who's commentating
the night breaks drops back to F3 but
black is not totally and completely out
of the woods I think Nico should finally
bring his Bishop out he can breathe a
little bit but that pawn on E7 can still
be targeted with a well-timed knight D5
this bishop is hard to kick away black
can play B6 but then you're weakening
the long diagonal and white could still
put a bishop on F3 so I would say a few
more problems to solve for Nico only
five and a half minutes to solve them in
let's see if you can stay afloat the
next couple moves bring his bishop and
Rook into the game and then we'll start
talking about total equality okay okay I
love it how it's like it's like you're
telling your kid in the back seat like
don't you get excited right let's see
you let's see you be nice to your
brother for five minutes and then we'll
talk about pulling over and getting you
something to eat right some fried
McDonald's you know let's condition your
hands to yourself I love it so we're not
letting theodoro get ahead of himself
let's see if he can complete his
development problems on the queen side
and then we'll decide whether he's equal
let's uh let's keep rolling to some
other games all things being equal I
actually think there's some more
exciting positions Fabiano caruana on
three of three probably going on four or
four I mean the guy has brought his best
yesterday he's better in a position
where despite black having the bishop
pair he's in control of the dark squares
yet again a lot like the French he had
am I misreading the clock Danny is he
seven minutes up in a 10 minute game hey
there's there's two things I know you
did well there's two things I know you
do well one of them is read good one of
my eyes is always on the clock and
everybody in the chat knows it I have
not kept that a secret now black size
The Bishop's eyes to be exact are on the
king side the problem Danny is that
black is incredibly weak in the center
of that E5 Square backward Pawn
accompanying it White's Bishop ain't
anything to sneeze at in fact Bishop
takes G7 here should very well be
calculated maybe not worth opening up
the G file but fobby's wheels are
definitely turning maybe Queen D4 so
very easy
yeah it was actually Bishop E5 because
if you take F3 the queen can take you
hit the rook and if you take E5 the
Knight comes in so rather than 95 which
probably gives white an edge in any
opposite code Bishop position because of
the clamp on the dark squares but as
Bishop E5 a candidate move here Danny
Freddy stop saying good moves because
you remind me of the time that we played
in the World open and I cried after that
game and
can you throw in a couple blunders here
just to make you feel more comfortable
was eight years old the only time I
played him and beat him he's being uh
you're being Mom it's more like 14 and
already in FM so it wasn't too bad all
right all right Knight G5 Knight G5
flight Here Comes Queen H5 check and you
can't play G6 without the dark squares
falling apart now let me tell you what's
not coming yeah I think Bishop B5 was
better I'm sorry I think my all right go
ahead go ahead no I I was just gonna
make a small clarification of black
castles here that might be the only way
to stay afloat I'm gonna show this
really quickly this is important Knight
takes C6 is a huge blunder because no
you do not want to actually lose the
exchange at the end so still some tricks
still some traps to set if you're a
mitrava but the problem is that Knight
takes E6 I think you're right Danny
Bishop B5 is a great move positionally
but Fabi he sees Black's clock and he
might just be going for the kill with
Queen H5 maybe Queen D4 all of the moves
that were good before black castled are
gonna be good now as well oh he's taken
on C6 first oh we see something he's
smart when she sticks unbelievable dude
he smiled and you never see Fabiano spot
will someone clip it so I can shove this
and shot and Bobby's face later where he
says never read facial expressions never
read body language he literally just
smiled and and played a great move
um look at this guy to G6 look at the
minor pieces cooperate first the Knight
threatens made then the bishop threatens
made everybody's friends and black is
going to get massacred on the king side
here you can Stave off mate for a couple
moves but not for very long I think
sometimes you can look at a guy as soon
as you can look at a guy you know that
when he looks good he feels good Fabiano
caruana is feeling confident I I think
we're looking at the favor to win the
event today just not based on the 404
Sports thanks Captain Obvious it's the
quality of his games he has dominated
every one of his opponents to this point
here in round four
Bobby's just one of those guys when he
feels good when he feels confident he's
Mr seven out of seven in the singfield
cup nobody's ever gonna forget that
Danny so we know what he's capable of
when he his head is in the right place
when he's in the game yeah we got to go
to no young to promise okay is there
Queen concept six on the board
what is going on
I'm looking at him
that's a check made on F6 wait a second
Danny but black can recapture on e4
white skin could be the one caught in
the crossfire there that has to be
calculated
by someone who's not named neriditsky
maybe somebody oh my god dude Queen
takes F7 look at this line I gotta show
this okay yeah Bishop B4 Queen takes F7
but that doesn't work and you know why
because queensy one check King H2 oh my
gosh the queen H1 oh here there's Bishop
F4 intercepting Queen H1
Queen G2
the king gets to H4 oh Queen F3 is the
win
you trade Queens oh the King has to go
back
what a lion
did something crazy but something
different he let's go back to lifeboard
he took the bishop on Jesus now he
played it simple he took on F6 took on
G6 and he sang guess what I'm just up
two pawns the joke's on you guys
he spent a whole bunch of time looking
at that though he might say the jokes
obvious but there's no way when we first
joined that board he was not considering
Queen takes F6 because how often do you
get to sack a queen and made a king in
the corner with a bishop and Knight not
earth that was an incredible line Danny
I'm so glad we showed that and
definitely you can rewind the tape and
look at that again but Vincent kheimer
is looking at his clock he's looking at
the board he's shaking his head Jana's
gonna recapture on F6 and most
importantly Danny black has one check on
Z1 big whoop white just brings the king
up Jan should win this game
agreed Town population us love it when
we're living in the same city we should
consider that maybe maybe I'll come
visit okay let's move on to ferrugia
Parham as you said it's a king's Indian
by the way we called it I'm not going to
toot our horn but I am going to toot our
horn here we said this position was more
difficult for white in every practical
way and slowly but surely we don't know
how we got here black has kind of turned
the tables and is now flexing in this
king's Indian but Russia is looking good
Parham sacked in exchange in order to
make sure that his knight uh was well
established on F5 black lacks a light
squared Bishop to capture that Knight
but that doesn't tell the whole story
part of the story are Black's double
Brooks on the H file that makes it
impossible for white take to take with
the Knight because of Rook H2 and
getting a pair of Rooks off the board
would be a disaster for white because
the knights in and of themselves are
just not going to be able to hold the
fort I don't know what Parham should do
maybe he should take with the other
night but that involves getting away and
removing the pride of your position
Borussia should be winning here but with
that Knight sitting on F5 it's never it
ain't gonna be easy until the last move
is made here
agreed but he but uh he does also have a
90-second advantage on the clock which
makes it hard for white he's got the uh
berugia looking focused look right now
dialing it up a little bit to ensure he
finds his opportunity what's that
starting to I don't know I think it's
not that I was going to suggest Bishop
page six I don't think this is as
winning as I thought it was Borussia can
deliver that check on C1 White's Gang
has a path down those light score bang
bang bang bang he can end up on C6
before long and that's probably the
safest Square on the board Danny C6
right here is where the white king wants
to be that's actually I'm not kidding by
the way that is I know and I I knew you
were which is why I was like that's
hilarious that that is true like King to
B3 objectively good like
I mean Bang Bang
it's wild
um
so
can you play Knight takes G3 here I
think you can that check on C1 makes you
recoil but as you're saying as we're
saying it sends the king in the
direction that it wants to go anyway and
the move A4 is just like those arrows
pointing to the right Trail you'd be
three straight away you can't wait he's
just like get me there now okay there's
some problem with the move I don't I
don't have the engine on Don and you'll
have to tell me because I don't know why
the computer doesn't like it
well it might be a four check and then
Rook A8 but again the king will get to
B5 you could try to make its path hard
Danny with a move like C6 sounds absurd
but by getting a white Pawn to C6 you're
closing off the end of the trail and the
King could get caught in the bushes
there but for Russia he goes Russian
Schoolboy mode and tries to get the
Queens off the board let's not forget
he's up in exchange I was just gonna say
and that was the best engine move what a
mind-blowing finally available I didn't
even realize until Queen H5 the farugia
was up the exchange like I wasn't even
thinking about it I mean I know
obviously the Knights versus The Rook
but like he's now in convert mode he
doesn't need to Checkmate that white
king run into B3 A4
he's going to convert the position and
try to use his Rooks well like Jan with
Knight takes G6 Bishop F6 the players
know when to create fireworks they also
know when to dial it back and play those
simple moves and we take those moves for
granted Parham is desperate right now
he's trying to create counter play in
the center but he's hamstrung he
couldn't play Queen takes D6 because of
the force so there goes his King it's
running a muck on the queen side yeah
but Ken farouza bring the hammer down
here on the king side I don't see
exactly how to do it White's got the
squares covered for now oh oh what a
move Queen E8 Queen E8 wow this is
amazing oh my gosh honestly Parham
survived a crazy king walk versus
Fabiano caruana at Todd of Steel I don't
think he's surviving this crazy king
walk versus Ali Reza ferrujo
yeah Lyrica just came and chopped down
the king's pathway King B5 doesn't help
okay Parham might as well take the pawn
queen E8 King has to go back to B3 a
forking will go all the way back to
where it started Danny this is still not
over let's not pretend the game is over
okay okay I'll stop pretending but I do
like the idea of playing A4 oh he goes
to A3 he doesn't allow A4 with check
okay 58 Maybe
I'll just get the ladies off the board
use the D file for the Rooks and uh you
know
ship this one home
our arm's not going to cooperate though
he's lying on his queen dancing and
dodging and Meandering and there is a
check on D3 but it can be covered with a
pawn and the King can restart its
Journey potentially
this is a crazy game between F7 and
steady attack C4 but you can't take it
Danny because you get checkmated there
potentially on G7 so yeah peruz is just
trying to sort of consolidate his pieces
taking a breath here it is very much a
three result position obviously the eval
bar favors black for a reason everybody
but it can be evil in these scenarios
because one move and that thing's gonna
shoot up and give your old guy a heart
attack here that's this guy your boy
falls off his chair when things like
that happen I'd spend a Tempo on Rook G8
there make sure you have h8 for your
king now Rook H2 by the way is in the
mix you could promote that pawn but that
has to be calculated
I don't know if you can get away with it
the black king gets Mighty vulnerable
there man I love how you just sometimes
one of the most enjoyable things in life
is slipping into an accent you didn't
see coming it's so incredibly satisfying
you know what I'm saying man it just
happens and then before you know it
you're back in normal and it's like it
just there are very few things that's
fulfilling in life than slip yeah go
ahead you found more okay the glass of
extra sweet lemonade some house razor
faroogia and you got everything you need
in life Rook H2 is on the board perfect
calculation Danny Knight H2 GH Rook
trade King takes back H6 there is
covered by the bishop G1 by the pawn H1
by none of White's pieces because he's
not gonna have any left and Parham has
to bring his Rook back he's on his last
legs here but these guys they never die
Danny that's one of the themes of this
Swiss these swindles they happen because
the players just keep their legs
churning like Marsha and Lin or Marshawn
Lynch when he's getting tackled by 10
players I gotta throw in a sports rep
and sorry everybody no it's true it's
nothing like seeing the uh you know it's
uh it's locked up up top but it's a
party down low right you know he's uh
he's being tackled but he's not quitting
and that's what parham's doing here
um I'll let that one slide okay
all right what does black do here how
does he finish dude Bishop C1 is coming
and B2 is falling in some weird
positions I know you can take H2 but I'm
just pointing out that there's some
weird threats over there like you could
play Queen B7 and induce B3 and then
Bishop C1 comes with check it's almost a
beautiful mate but Wild
the King has just started and restarted
its Journey for Russia has one minute on
the clock I'm leaning Danny in favor of
a more solid approach I think G2 might
win Knight takes no he goes for the
Danny wrench approach always a wise
thing to do and she knows where the
wisdom is at he plays Queen B7 he's
threatening to take on B2 if B3 has
played Bishop C1 comes with check it
also hits me before
I I know Queen E7 check is on the agenda
for white but E4 is also tender
it's a mess and five seconds to figure
it out Rook H1 is forced here I think
you can't take that one he does take the
Rook verucia could even Queen in this
position he could recapture The Rook the
question is can white orchestrate last
second last Stitch counter play against
the king you know why I think the answer
is no Danny Queen to B4 check actually
is possible with this position
the Queen's get off he finds it finds it
dominates the night the night can't come
back to G3 and stop the pawn this is
incredible that was an amazing ride
what a finish by farugia ferrugia knows
how to finish
that is that is such an I know we're
freaking out everybody but that was such
an instructive moment to keep your head
under pressure and remember that you're
not committed to this wild Affair of
sacrifices and checkmates and perpetuals
simplifying the game never forgetting
your opportunity to keep your eye as I
like to call it seeing the forest
through the trees that move Queen before
check taking the rook and it's over I
love that loved that was very well said
Danny I was listening I hope you didn't
mind that I flipped on the Hikaru game
in the meantime speaking of finishing
he's someone who knows how to finish he
is going to finish Muhammad oh no that's
not maradly that's another as everybody
Johnny Grandmaster he's going down the
pawn on D7 is queening promotion is the
order of the round Danny yep well
despite losing that second game Hikaru
Nakamura is staying in the thick of it
he still Trails the leaders Vladimir
kramnik Fabiano caruana Dimitri on
draken are and and then you have
Nicholas theodoro because they drew that
game so only two players on 404 guess
what we know we're watching next round
everybody Vladimir romnick versus Bobby
owner carwana baby sign me up
the battle of the generations love to
see it both players in great form but
the action this round isn't quite over
blue Baum as I flipped on has just
defeated Peter smidler so the German
Grandmaster is very much in the race and
now I'm going to flip on Ray robson's
game he's still playing trying to finish
off aquarium 76 not sure who that is but
whoever it is he's going down as well I
think
too
okay he
I I don't know who aquarium 76 is either
I clicked on it but Ray Robson everyone
knows the caterpillar whom is spicy so
uh that's
that's Ray Robson the best puzzle solver
in the world
but can he solve this puzzle no he
cannot he just blunder his Bishop king
f8 and the Knight can't keep contact of
the rook and defend the bishop at the
same time he's got to push his spawn he
thoughts his Bishop Rook H2 and black
still has a passed a bond Danny this is
a wild end game actually I think Rey
might Swindle this one though Rook takes
F4 no he's pushed at H7 oh he's gonna
get checkmated or is it King E6 no oh my
gosh wait
wait what oh what's going on 26. I like
King E6 here because that sets up made
threats he pushed the pawn to E6
there's oh my God one second you have to
be super careful if the black king gets
out
what is going on here
oh my gosh rookie one F5 is the other
Pawn I was just gonna say the pawn on A2
is just as big of a problem as White's
pawns oh my gosh
A1 this is wild two pawns and a knight
versus two Rooks how often has this
happened and Ray could win this easily
easily very very rare do you see some
sort of uh Dynamic like this on the
board
but it's a three result position for for
sure a single move in that eval bar is
gonna is gonna punish a mistake the evil
bar is just itching to to Skyrocket and
Aquarium using his Rooks wisely he might
just take the Knight and try to draw
this
by the way Jacob is whoa two bullets on
the seventh rank versus two Rooks
Danny I don't know what the move was
there I think he had to check the king
perpetually with the Rooks and take one
of those pawns that was the draw to do
it oh my God has to win this but he is
with nine seconds this is indefensible
yeah the uh the queen does beat The Rook
theoretically everyone regardless of
what uh the situation is on the clock so
Rey should win this uh but what a what a
freaking crazy game with the two paws of
the seventh rank you know what it was
down here if you checked with the H rook
and the King goes to the second way then
you use the Rook on B4 and you can check
on the fourth Rank and he can't get out
and it's a draw that's what it was sorry
yeah because you you lose one of the
pawn no you're exactly right that was in
my head
yeah black is still holding for now and
there's a lot of stalemate traps here
that's one of the the reasons that you
can mess this up Rey is trying to
essentially Force The Rook onto a square
such that such that the queen can Fork
it he's not being successful yet black
just somehow you know he's thrashing
around like a fish out of water but he's
not losing his breath just yet and
where's the fork
you know he has the third ranked defense
going I don't know if I ever told you my
heartbreaking King and Rook vs king and
queen story Donnie I was playing Eugene
pearlstein shout out to you Jane miss
you buddy Grand Master Eugene pearlstein
and I and I executed the third ranked
defense which is what this is even
though it's flipped onto the f-file and
I literally held it he held it
I'm sorry he drew three times repetition
I held mine until move 48 and then
blundered
but it's it's a very hard thing to win
and we see the third rank defense the
key is you have to play you have to play
Waiting moves that are very hard to find
like in this position
okay the key is you have to play
it's always some random computer move
like King yeah it's like team D4 or
queen D6 or something and the King can't
can't hold in the same way because
you're threatening what you want is
basically this I'll give the
philosophical win you want to threaten
things like Queen H2 where you further
separate the king and the Rook right if
the queen gets to a square like that so
when you put the queen on D6 and you
force the king over to you know like H3
or something that's the idea you can
play like King E2 and then centralize
the queen and eventually the third
ranked defense becomes the second ranked
defense and that's how you win but all
right I'm rambling and that was that was
that was wild that was wild
oh man you know what else is wild
what's that Danny the air things Masters
because it's what you're watching and
I'm gonna give a shout out right now
because the air things Master's main
event begins this Monday it's February
6th boys and girls players will recharge
over the weekend and then we are right
back at it with non-stop action
competitive chess of the highest level
we are bringing it to you the week of
the with The Knockout rounds Monday
through Friday at 8 A.M Pacific time is
when it starts it comes to a head this
time next week on February 10th when we
will Crown the winner of the first event
of the 2023 Champions chess tour don't
miss chess history being made it's right
here at twitch.tv chess Donya and I are
right here we're not going anywhere so
much more action ahead tune in as the
air things Mastin Masters play in
continues when we return
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about no
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
we are back as the first event for the
2023 Champions Chester on chess.com is
underway it's the air things Masters
plan shout out to our sponsor air things
and shout out to everyone who's been
with us this day feels like it's just
beginning and there's still so much more
ahead let's talk about the schedule
Donya speaking of what's ahead we know
that we are in the first event of what
is the Champions chess tour this year
your quick highlights from this schedule
well it's just an incredible assortment
of tournaments six in total right now
we're watching the play in that we'll
see to six players that will join Magnus
Carlson and Wesley so two players on the
screen there who are already seated into
the first major of the air things
Masters February 6th Danny you don't
have to wait long Hikaru Nakamura is the
third person in the photo he hasn't made
it yet he will first off to be one of
the top 12 players to make it into
division one and then one of the lucky
six who win in the match phase and make
their way to the air things master so
the path is long the path is arduous and
the path
is trying to be blocked by the likes of
Vladimir kramnik and Fabiana caruana who
themselves want to take a stab at the
air things Masters but Danny it's
year-round action I love that the CCT
season ends in December you got
months-long action every month of the
year I love it I love it I love it and
you know what we've been talking about
how Vladimir cruel 11 11 11 11 11 11 11.
level up all right anyway
um I we've been talking about how
Vladimir karamnik is still one of the
best players in the world as if as if we
needed that memo but I I get the feeling
when he plays in these events that he's
basically showing showing us things
showing us prep that he never even got a
chance to use before retiring look at
the time used on the clock Tanya he's up
almost two minutes against one of the
best prepared players in his generation
in Fabiano caruana and and he's got a
good position as white he's not great
no it's okay okay we'll get into it in a
second I I just wanted to contribute to
your great point I think I'm not the
only one who feels like the last four or
five years have lasted a lifetime
um because enough has happened to last
us a lifetime but Vladimir crowning
didn't retire you know in the 1960s he
retired like four or five years ago and
that's not such a long time he is still
following chess news he's playing in
Rapid events so I think some players are
thinking of it the wrong way Gary
Kasparov he's had some unfortunate
tournaments in the last couple of years
but that's because he retired in 2005.
that's an 18-year Gap so cram Nick is
still very much active he knows his
openings his opening preparation is
still relevant Danny what I'm trying to
say is that he still has every shot at
qualifying and being a menace to the
other top players they aren't thinking
of this as a walkover no like you said
he uh he only retired a few years ago
and he's remained active as a
commentator he's commentated on some of
the biggest chess events he's written
chessable courses right he's staying up
on all kinds of information to make sure
that he can educate and disseminate his
knowledge for the masses in the years to
come and he's also continued to play
from time to time and whether it's
exhibition events no castles chess
events we know that he's been working
hard as the chess advisor for Google's
Deep Mind crew that worked on the alpha
zero project for those who don't know
prom deck was involved in that before
anybody knew he was involved in that as
the confidential chess advisor so so
you're absolutely right and don't be
surprised again like I said if he's not
only Dancing In The Knockout next week
but but turning some heads and doing it
what a wild story that would be if
Vladimir crombeck was competing in our
Championship tour final come December I
would I would lose my my giddy little
school girl mind I would lose it as a
fan
oh first of all he's got to survive this
position he has against one Fabiano
caruana this particular game I don't
think has gone Vladimir's way in the
early going we have an end game that is
encouraging kramnik is an incredible
endgame player but what's not
encouraging Danny two things in
particular the placement of the white
king which has lost its castling rights
that might not seem significant in an
end game but Black's got enough pieces
uh to cause that King a lot of headaches
especially if a rook gets the d8 second
thing I'll point out is the pawn
structure why it's doubled pawns on the
B file are sitting ducks and there's a
weak square that accompanies them Bishop
to E6 to B3 is a maneuver kremnik has to
get his pieces out very quickly he's got
to find shelter for his King he's got a
lot of items on the to-do list
okay fair airfare and he's also playing
Fabiano caruana as we know Bobby's also
you know decent decent yes Jen well have
you on okariano exactly I love you yeah
you know exactly exactly you know ever
since Bob you wanted was showing up oh
the chess scene yeah yeah I remember
alone
I remember okay I remember when five you
want ocariano needed a phone book Jen he
needed a phone book to see over the
chessboard yeah exactly and you know who
else was there at the tournament FM
gether who is also there and epic
together right you know all right puffed
on his cigar okay let's get back to the
game Fabiano has castled kicks I feel
like the world has continued to turn
economies have grown and collapsed and
you know we're still imitating yes sir
I love Yasser I love Black's position
here yeah I look I actually I actually
am yeah slowly eating my words because
Chrome makes time Advantage is
disappearing as we watch it before our
eyes Fabiano's position has gotten
better so Vlad started out on the right
foot Bobby obviously did whatever he had
to do to to calculate the correct
approach in the opening use this time
wisely because he's in a pretty good
spot now and uh we've got we've got a
lot of other games to look at of course
we can't
what no keep going I had an eye on
nepo's game and it seemed to me that he
blundered in exchange but now I think he
didn't blunder in exchange is it okay if
we take a quick detour let's do it let's
head over to Yolanda Palmer she's game
we've also got hitkara Nakamura taken on
Nicholas theodoro to check in with at
some point oh yeah even though Theodore
is a half a point ahead I don't think
that's a pairing that he wanted against
Hikaru no it is not and we will go there
next for sure but hopefully I can be
forgiven I saw this and I was like whoa
what is he on doing it turns out that
Queen C2 is a Saving Grace because you
are not only hitting white screen but
what's defending the queen is the very
same Rook that is hanging this
construction ensures a black I think is
more or less safe and the Queens are now
off the board yeah nepo is doing oh
still unpleasant Knight C8 is in the
cards here as well
yeah this feels like one of those
positions that sneaky
sneaky turns into a decisive result eval
bar equal Pawn structure basically equal
optically nothing nothing screaming at
you but somebody's going to get control
over the open file and then their Pawn
whether it's the a pawn or the d-pawn is
going to become weak and this could run
away quickly
it could and Jan brings his other Rook
to B2 that's a great move because he
takes the sting out of Knight C8 but I
do feel like the end game has more or
less stabilized so probably a good time
for us to to go to that Hikaru game
which I'm really antsy to take a look at
Let's Do It Let's Take a Look Yonder
Palm Nashi versus gookash will keep our
eye on it but agreed Hikaru Nakamura
trying
to get his way back in it here at the
air things Masters playing this is the
first event of the Champions chess tour
the air things Masters will be brought
to you in a week look at this
part is actually doing fine I think but
that pawn isn't going anywhere that
extra Pawn doesn't look very happy
Nico's last move was also accompanied it
with something called a draw offer which
something you are was not really known
to take much but he might in this
position because those pawns on the
queen side white is licking his lips
looking at that A4 Pawn theodoro offered
a draw
let me get you there let me go to there
oh I see yeah exactly Jen exactly
Ricardo declined the draw Theodore
offers a draw hey
Cara said take that joffer and put it in
a place where the sun doesn't shine D to
C8 it's a risky decision because he is
worth Sandy Let's uh make no bones about
that white can take that pawn on A4
black that is an extra Pawn so he
Theodore would be restoring the material
mounts but he would also be creating a
massive weakness on B3 which I think
Hikaru is planning to defend with C4
yeah it's a weird position though
because
it's it's it was also a psychological
Thing by by Theodore you offer a draw
when you know you're about to get the
edge to kind of get it in the back of
your opponent's mind for the rest of the
game remember that draw you didn't take
are you regretting it it can make you
play even worse than you would otherwise
right how many times have you been the
victim of a psychological Ploy like that
by your opponent
because you keep running the tape right
had I taken the draw I would have been
better in the tournament it's not just
the draw for you declined it's the
subsequent tournament standing maybe
forfeited so you get into that worst
position you're absolutely right Danny
and Nico knew that icaro would not take
this draw not uh with his tournament
standing having already dropped a pointy
car is mad he wants to prove it in the
next couple of rounds so Queen to C4
Nico is not actually rushing to take
this Pawn he wants to take it under the
right circumstances Danny and the right
circumstances are those in which Hikaru
will not be able to play C4 to cover the
other Pawn Yeah
agreed
populations a little bit of shuffle a
little bit of a shuffle there in the
nice Hawaiian shirt there I wonder how
many Hawaiian shirts Hikaru has in his
wardrobe by the way like what's the over
under on that what do you got on that
yeah he's doing the Mark Zuckerberg
where it's like a new one every day
probably 11 definitely over over 10
double digits I would say okay all right
we'll get well we'll get up maybe a a
vote a poll on that twitch chat how many
how many Hawaiian shirts does Hikaru
have in his wardrobe I'm gonna put the
on over under a nine and a half
so you got to go either nine or ten
we'll find out about that later all
right
um
black is worse but
it's not that big of a deal as long as
you find the Right Moves In the sense
that if you could just pass in this
position what does White's next move is
what I would ask right how is white
improving on it well Quinta I think it's
time Nico might have overcooked it a
little bit and he might be regretting
not taking that pawn with his Rook
because now if he takes that pawn of
this queen Hikaru counters with Queen
takes H5 and you can't take B3 because
the Rook hangs it's a weird position
Danny I'm struggling to make heads or
tails of it it's even hard to say that
you know white is necessarily better
because white could also be worse if he
doesn't find the right time to take the
pawn and then forfeits that opportunity
man this is a pretty crazy position even
though the material is symmetrical that
doesn't tell the whole story the
position can still be and is incredibly
complicated here yeah and Hikaru is
already going to be considering taking
H5 even at the cost of E6 it's it's not
so clear the H5 Pawn
is is obviously Under Fire by the queen
on F7 currently the queen on C4 hits C6
so you don't really want to do that if
you're black as it takes a check but but
it's it's a really it's it's a
calculation and something you gotta
weigh if you're theodoro because it's
not so obvious whether you want to allow
that
and that's why Nico is taking some time
there's a lot of candidate moves here
Rook to G6 comes to mind if you want to
defend the pawn Rook to D1 Queen takes
A4 obviously is always the movement he's
decided to play it now is this the right
time to take that pawn I think it is
he's brought the Rook to C4 uh Danny
very smart yeah he's given up the H5
Pawn that's painful but he's gonna take
B3 I think and he's gonna have that past
a pawn I think Nico is keeping a small
but very stable and annoying advantage
on the board
yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah man in the meantime
craziness in Ollie Reza's game as well
but we don't have to go there we can
we've got farrugia taking on the player
who beat and Cameron Nakamura that is
Zhu is showing you
from China of the China pandas uh it's
what is going on here farusha is on on a
mating net
and we will go back to the Hikaru game
but this is ridiculate wait he's up a
rook he's got two Rooks in black as one
what happened he's just up a rook
I'm
he's just up the Rook I can't believe
this I mean really sacrifice there are
the remnant standing of some sort of
attack that black had earlier in the
opening but
not what is left of that attack where
did The Rook go
well it was it was one because ferocia
was up a minor piece I'll rewind three
moves can you sacrifice the minor piece
his attack failed Danny and then farouza
turned it around on him a devastating
Chuck on F6 black is about to lose both
of his Bishops and so he had to give up
another exchange he's trying to make
something of the center but your pawns
aren't going to win the game you're down
a freaking Rook Bruce has just got a
couple more solid moves to make if he
consolidates gets his pieces out he'll
win but that's not a given not a given
yet not over yeah the black Rook is
coming to fa the bishop on C5 and The
Rook on f8 will hit F2 as we said a long
distance relationship that's been
working since 1611 the rook and Bishop
are the longest lasting long-distance
relationship known to man
the rook and Bishop there you go
um all right but ferrugia is going to
take this one I uh I kind of want to
head back to the the game between the
two tournament leaders that of course is
the the only two guys on 404 Vladimir
chronic and Fabiano caruana just to at
least pay it off because it might end in
the draw from what I'm seeing it's an
optical Bishop position but if we could
quickly go back there and check
we've got um
you know father is pushing a little bit
but if the most likely result is a draw
these two guys could be joined by other
co-leaders uh for those who get get a
win on three and a half right now and
very good news for those with three
points because they will get a chance to
creep up a little bit and start
challenging those at the top Bishop to
A6 is the last move now obviously this
is a two result game black is up a pawn
Fabiano did not blunder the bishop there
Rook to F1 was a huge threat he moved
his King out of the way Danny I can see
either scenario unfolding I can see
Vladimir holding the position forcing a
rook trade which would basically be an
immediate draw I can also see Fabby
milking black White's clock down trying
to get his Rook active and trying to go
afterwards King side pawns eventually
yeah well in this case Vladimir kuronic
does have the increments so he can't be
flagged
to uh to remind him he's not allowed to
complain if he gets flagged in this time
control because he has an increment so
the gloves are off on that one can't
complain about flagging when you have
increment thems are the rules
um but
I agree with you Fabi is obviously the
one in control here it's a it's a two
result position for for him Will he win
or will it be a draw with an extra Pawn
in the obstacle Bishop ending uh
Nicholas theodoro and Vlad and Vladimir
Hikaru are Vladimir Hikaru and Nicholas
Fabiano
it all starts to blur together after a
while man you know that
um Gary wrench yeah shall we go back to
that game let's do it let's do it
it's very very complicated right now
in the theodoro job it's complicated but
it looks bad for Hikaru on the board and
on the clock which probably means he's
gonna win but look at the adora's queen
right before we left Danny Theodore
snuck in that Knight E4 move which I
thought was really cool not just to look
cool but he's also challenging both of
Black's weak pawns obviously the Knight
is and has been Untouchable for the last
few moves because of the Rook on C8 gosh
can a Hikaru hold this together all of
his pawns are falling here
E6 is falling with check although he'll
probably play Queen F7 if that happens
and then the D4
the D4 Knight has to move at some point
um importantly black is up a pawn here
so again Theodora would only be
restoring material equality
yeah
okay fair point
Hikaru and the uh
the pineapple neon light in the
background
um
but he's under time pressure right now
he's down a minute
yeah like like you said he's in a worse
position and he's down a minute that
means he's probably gonna win it you
know yeah he's he's right where you know
he feels most comfortable he's already
swindled one game this tournament
against Ronald unfortunately Nicholas
theodoro is not to be trifled with in a
Time scramble he is one of the best
bullet players on the site he's
ridiculously fast and he has just
snagged that pawn but not with the queen
he wants to keep the Queens on the board
Danny important clarification Rook to B6
here looks like it wins the night I
think the queen can slide up to A7 and
counter challenge black snide on D7 this
game has just been a head-spinningly
complicated now for a very long time and
hikaru's clock continues to dwindle he
does play Rook B6 can he breathe some
clarity into this game in order to be
able to survive with the time that he
has left
it's a good question I wonder if he'll
take a Perpetual not to say that
theodoro has to accept it but you could
play you could play tickle with the
queen there I mean you get you don't
want to move the Knight no that you
can't do I was gonna say Rook to D60
Carlos is clearly playing for a win he
wants to keep the ponies on the board
and he wants his Pony somewhere around
if he also doesn't want to get mated so
we'll watch out forgot to move White's
not out watch out for D1 as well Rook D1
check would force a trade and black one
in a media Perpetual if he wanted it
between Queen H5 and D1 most likely so
uh theodoro has some tricks to figure
out will that time Advantage dwindle
away still up a minute on the clock
against Hikaru but uh hikara would would
much rather have a mutual time scramble
despite theodoro's bullet skills in this
position he doesn't want to be down down
time for the rest of the game the real
question is who's going to blunder first
I mean it's not one of those positions
where we see 50 moves of positional play
the center is wide open pieces are
hanging and as the clock continues to
dwindle it really becomes the only
question I'm expecting some wild eval
bar swings here and in a certain sense
it's almost easier to be black here but
especially if this B8 Rook makes its way
to date uh Danny and the Knight moves
out of the way your move Rook D1 that
might not only be a Perpetual that'll
actually be Checkmate if black can stack
their Rooks on the D file
that would be wild watch out watch out
for D1 I always say I I think I've never
said that in my life but I just said it
um
watch out for for D1 A wise man once
said
the uh
I I was I was I was spying at the other
games because there is so much action
again the best part of the air things
Masters playing and all the plans we
will have the Swiss portion is going to
be one of those where
not for the faint of heart let's hope
it's always on a Friday so that people
can you know and start to enjoy their
weekend after these events because these
play-ins are nerve-wracking and non-stop
action
God Danny I love these moments they may
seem tedious but the clock is dwindling
you know the action is coming and these
are my favorite moments this is when
you're going up in the roller coaster
and you know the fall is coming here we
go buckle in Knight F4 Rook T1 trade of
Brooks Queen comes back it is
centralized G5 is threatened G5 is
threatened D5 and we live shout out to
you
Nico's like give me that draw or give me
death
okay it's a car we're gonna take it now
or does he want more no Nico now down on
time to Cara wants more he wants the
whole thing and not just he wants the
whole thing he wants the queen he wants
to snag that lady with rookie 8 and Nico
can do the same with Knight G6 but with
30 seconds left the clock situation has
flipped Danny forktown population U on
E7 that's a forking problem you got to
watch out okay the Queen's gonna run
back Hikaru shakes his head maybe he
regrets
regret something I I didn't read
hikaru's head shake there as well as I
normally do I'll have to double check on
the instant replay later if that was The
Confident Hikaru number seven or Hikaru
Nakamura number 11 as we said
um 395. Danny how easy is that to
blunder The Rook would have been trapped
Nico though sidestepping the landmines
and he is starting to encircle the pawns
on the queen side that's what we started
with right that was his original Mission
and now he's finally coming back to it
after repelling ikaru's kingside counter
play Nico's definitely still better his
pieces in the center are loose though so
it's still anybody's game 30 seconds now
for both players here we go and Hikaru
is shaking his head because like you
said it's only getting easier for Nico
from here he's parried the king side
problems the queen will come to C3 B3 is
a threat c5's a threat let's not forget
that A3 Pawn is actually passed you may
not know it right now but it's a past
pawn and it could start pushing here the
pawn has passed Black's counter play is
in the past Black's time Advantage is in
the past what's not in the past Hikaru
is 10 seconds he centralizes his Queen
he Parts waves ways with the B Pawn but
if you take it you have to reckon with
Knight B6 and then C4 what a weasel this
guy I think the car just pulls these
tricks out of nowhere
no Queen B4 in response Nico is amazing
Nico Nico calls the Tactical Bluff wow
and sees that he can go for by the way
olly Rosy farusha did get his win he
currently is in clear first likely
joined by carwana and kromnik after a
draw there
Hikaru now would be happy to get a draw
himself with both players gonna be he
might get it but they're both going to
be under 10 seconds and theodoro could
play for a win yeah but he doesn't I
mean Theodore decides hey I've got seven
seconds my king is weak if Hikaru
doesn't go for a draw in this position I
would be shocked I don't think he's got
maybe Rook C5 but that is just totally
Brazen I could see him doing it oh my
God he does it Hikaru going for the
baiting net Danny it's Queen d8 and Rook
takes C4 wins the second party missed it
oh Queen d8 and Rook C4 would have held
D1 and won the Pokemon that was winning
he misses it and now Hikaru still has a
draw if he goes Rook D1 and he uh oh no
but there's Queen H3 no but there's
Queen E5 there wins the B2 Pawn I think
he car is gonna hold this one he's gonna
take the draw finally
is Nico going to go King G3 no
no he accepts it oh my gosh I can't take
anymore I'm getting too old for this
bleep let's go okay chromic
speaking of guys getting too old chromic
not too old for this stuff he drew he
holds on still tied for first along with
Ali Reza farusha and Fabiana Carmona
Danny
ragnanza's heart is beating fast because
he's got two passers he's got a win in
the bag solemn is one of those guys
that's often overlooked incredible
player but he's gonna lose this one
performance and taught a steal Danny oh
Prague keeping Pace with the crowd there
right you got La Quang Liam there we
haven't even talked about that guy
that's a former World Blitz Champion you
got to know him when you see him laquan
Lee M from Vietnam there you've got you
cash keeping I mean
the third place finisher and the
candidates tournament is just casually
playing on like board 30. I mean what is
this tournament
just casually whoa
take the pawn so we see a knight and
Bishop may now Danny fun fact Min Lee uh
played a game last round I don't
remember who it was gladora I think
failed to mate he goes for the previous
round will rajabov be able to take up
the mantle here he's got the king in the
wrong corner he needs to Shepherd the
king over to A1 this is an easy one he's
the king's already there Knight F4 take
H4 with the bishop yeah it's actually
right where you want to be already you
bring the Knight into F2 and that holds
the H1 Square so Knight D3 Knight f
Knight F2 or 9h3 oh 93 still mate Knight
D3 then 19. oh he's not in this is not
it
rajaba might be panicking because
doing this the other way geometrically
is harder on the eyes it's harder to
trace the W he's got a second he's going
the wrong way everything is choking
completely Timur Java is not doing this
right this is all you have to do is F2
yeah
it's literally made in 19 if the Knight
gets F2 it's made in 19. I get to talk I
get to talk because I did this and he's
made it in without G1 oh
what did because it do he should have
gone out king F1 and he's fine he goes
into the center and he probably would
have drawn this is insane I've never
seen this mate before I've never seen
white check to make themselves at a
grand master level in the night Mission
sorry you get to talk what were you
gonna say there well I did this in about
10 seconds of that increment that's one
of my points of Pride I used to practice
this in the ICC days over and over and
over again and try to get under 15
seconds
but that was shocking Timor was choking
that maybe looking at his clock Danny
yeah and polesa is going to be kicking
himself he could have been that guy who
helped him with rajaba in a knight
versus Bishop position Borussia is that
guy who's not moving on the first move
right now
wow maybe he left and didn't realize
something realm was going to start but
first of all that's amazing second of
all I actually used to do the same thing
uh back when we were so old it wasn't
the ICC days we used this thing called a
chess board done you know stay still
what's that and then we used a clock
called a Kronos clock it was a chrono's
digital clock man Danny I I still have a
Kronos okay anyway so I actually did the
same thing and we would also practice
the knight in Bishop major we would try
to do it under 30 seconds physically
harder to move than with the with the
mouse online okay we were old but I did
the same thing and and that's how I had
that memorized if you if
let's pull up the chair while we talk
about it might as well but if you get
the Knight to F2 in that position boys
and girls I actually have a video if you
want to Google it just how to check the
night Bishop it's on YouTube but if the
knights on F2 and the opposite color
corner it's a Mateen 19 even with best
play you have to memorize that pattern
if you know that pattern everything else
becomes clear
um and rajaba got lucky frankly I mean
he he had many opportunities for that
pattern and instead he didn't find it
but his opponent checkmated himself I
will admit Danny I'm not I was not
familiar with that particular meeting I
didn't even know it was hypothetically
possible to get yourself mated that's on
a square not the corner you want to
drive the king to but I learn new things
every day that's what I love about my
job and Ali reservaruja just dropped
spotted Fabiano caruana 90 seconds in a
10-minute game he's gonna have to catch
up here and I don't understand why
players do that I mean they get out up
from their computers they don't have
forever you got to be on alert and I
don't want to be that guy the Monday
Morning Quarterback but if Ali Reza
loses this game you know this will be
one of the reasons why but for him eight
and a half minutes is still an eternity
and a half
a Greektown population us this is going
to be a fun one the opening isn't
starting super uh it's not super spicy
but we know we've got both farugia and
Favi on cam we've had them so it'll be
fun to be able to see how these guys are
feeling and this is a game that has
massive implications you know we're
already in a spot where okay like
winning winning this game done you
wouldn't punch your ticket for sure that
you're in division one but pretty close
to it because you can get to the spot
you might be able to hold some draws and
remember everybody the top 76 players in
the play-in will move on to divisions
one two and three respectively but only
division one has the opportunity to
compete in The Knockout joining Magnus
Carlson and Wesley so with a chance for
a direct spot to the championship tour
final at the end of the year welcome to
the air things Masters plan that was I
didn't even know I was going to do that
and then I did it
I have nothing I have nothing just I
mean to follow up that act all I'm gonna
say Danny is that as you said 12 uh of
the top finishers moved to division one
they play each other one through six uh
play seven through twelve and then the
six winners secure the six additional
spots in the first major the air things
Masters where they will be joining the
pre-invited players I don't know why we
thought to win by them Magnus Carlson
and Wesley so I mean couldn't we have
chosen more deserving players Danny this
is uh
an egregious blunder uh but man this is
fun this is exciting nobody has a
perfect score which I personally love
that means there's more competition at
the top there isn't someone just pulling
away and then making a bunch of quick
draws and we have a Carlsbad structure
here nice old school on structure look
at the pairings this round man you've
got Lotus is Q versus Vladimir cronic
that's Yonder Palm machine you've got
Sam Sevin versus Nicholas theodoro
you've got Dimitri on draken versus
gusianov you've got prognananda here and
and La Quang Liam getting in the folder
we hadn't even thought about their names
and their hurricane was taken on Dura
Bailey so you can't not focus on
farrugia versus carwana because these
are the two guys tied for first but what
what an adventure we have in store for
us here in round six
we absolutely do and we definitely will
look at nepo and on draken and kramnik
let's briefly unpack this position uh
perhaps and then we can move on because
this is definitely I'll be quieter side
and 94 is very standard fair for black
this idea has existed since the times of
capoblanca who by the way contributed a
great deal to our understanding of this
structure we stand on the shoulders of
giants so what happens after 94 if black
if white takes the Knight black actually
recaptures the bishop not D takes E4
which blunders the pawn to Queen takes
E4 and white defends the bishop if you
take E7 black recaptures with the queen
and he's got enough Defenders on the E4
Knight quickly quickly show the
kilometric for some of our our beginner
players a common mistake that's made
Donya is taking on e4 with the Knight
show that before taking seven that's how
you blunder up no no or before right
with the bishop on E7 a common mistake
made here is you take their first and
you lose a piece go ahead because like
you know you're exactly right this is
important to note because now if you
take E7 well this is more obvious and if
you take E4 you lose the bishop on H4 so
you can't sit on two chairs you either
lose a piece in the center or a piece on
the king side either way you lose a
piece somehow Bobby on a car want to do
that I mean I don't know how we do that
these guys are at Carlsbad Queen's
Gambit declined Carl's Bad structure uh
his oldest time and somehow fobby knew
the trick but seriously this is an
interesting one because note that white
shifts to the king side with Rook 8 E1
often White's plan in these structures
is a minority attack on the queen side
where you're actually advancing your
Pawns in hopes of creating positional
weaknesses not so when A4 and A5 have
been played the queen side is locked up
white plays rookie to E1 they're gonna
move the knight from F3 and actually try
to mobilize the two Rooks by advancing
the F and E pawns as my buddy there with
the coloring book is showing that is a
much juicier plan and no surprise that
Fabiana Karana is adopting the kind of
modern treatment with F3 and E4
michelobic uh is someone who had a
couple of incredible games in this line
Danny it's so fun to review games from
that time because players like Bob
Minnick and capablanca were so ahead of
their time that they would essentially
implement the same plan in every game
and nobody would know what to do against
it it was like Will Chamberlain
approaching the rim who is this seven
footer just dunking on everybody
nowadays all of the plans are well known
the way to fight them is well known but
let's see how Ali Reza faruja now two
minutes down is going to respond to what
I think is going to be Knight D2
followed by F3 well the last Point
speaking of well-known is a shout out
you and I have to give to a mutual coach
we both shared Grandmaster Alex
jermolinski Uncle Yermo as he's known
also very good at these positions very
well known for for the uh the Queen's
Gambit decline structures on both sides
right how much how many how many times
you go over a structure like this with a
okay no nothing no
it might be the only accent I'm better
than you at might be the only one
you got a million Irish accent Atlanta
you're Southern Ash today it's as if you
lived on boat in South Carolina for five
months
I mean anyway but uh you're all done
look dummy let me tell you 1997. when
Daniel raditzki was not even born yet no
I was living I'm older than that okay in
San Francisco at the Mechanics Institute
no okay no we're moving on all right
that's your remote Shadow jungle your
remote qgb qgd Orthodox Carlsbad
minority attack structure expert here
white changes the structure we have an
iqp that means isolated Queen Pawn on D4
and uh
it's it's it is petering out a little
bit but yeah blacks Black's doing well
we'll see farusha should be able to hold
this he's slightly worse White's got the
pawn lever D5 The Rook is awkward but I
vote we go Vladimir kramnik Town
population two because you're on the
promise you do it is Dancing with him in
a fascinating position or white has the
bishop here but a very weak King on E2
and a trap Bishop on G5 and a hanging
Bishop on G3 and a complicated position
as usual in kramnik's games wait you can
take B5 into three it's gonna say you
could dig B5 first oh what they just
agreed to a draw
wow has just had a I don't even know
what to call it just had a tantrum over
an Oslo has don't break anything in your
hotel room because chess.com has to pay
for that don't you break anything in
your hotel room all right Cry of Anguish
all over uh all across the way in the
South here well it's it's an early you
know it's a bold strategy cotton we'll
see if it pays off right the five D's of
dodgeball duck dick duck tip diving
dive Dodge and draw that's what I was
gonna say the five D's is draw there and
that's um
that's actually not a draw we want to
see
it is not and I think we're all in
agreement on that Danny we're not in
agreement on a lot of things anymore but
those quick draws we want to avoid them
when possible at the same time and I
always feel like I play a little devil's
advocate here especially when I'm
commentating with my boy Robert the
player's ultimate Allegiance is to
making the top 12 to fulfilling their
goal in the tournament and sometimes
that does mean hedging their bets and
getting that half point and securing
their place atop the tournament standing
so I want to see that minimized but it's
going to happen occasionally and we can
forgive big lead uh the occasional
what I was gonna say before I got tongue
twisted and had a an unfortunate slip of
the tongue on camera but I'll say that
what I was gonna say is that it's a bold
strategy cotton because this early on
taking these draws they might get
leapfrogged that's what I'm saying right
we obviously know that all the players
are hopeful to be in the top 76 make
their way into divisions three two and
one respectively but this early on
trying to draw your way into division
one that could that could backfire on
both Nepal and promnik it absolutely
could they don't have everything mapped
out you're not guaranteed a win in the
next round and you know Jan had the
white pieces he's gonna be black in the
next round and let's not forget how
quickly things change in these types of
tournaments you think yeah well you've
got it in the bag boom you lose a game
you're somewhere in 20th Place you know
uh behind total unknowns like Peter
civil or endometri on draken I'm sorry
chat Chad is Never Gonna Let Me lift it
up that way no it's not first of all
what I said is just the name of Richard
it's not a cursor it's not anything
awkward chat let let it go it was a
Dodge dip duck dive and draw not I know
what happened we got to move on Donya
I'm gonna I'm gonna lose my mind
I'm going to recuse myself from the
conversation you don't you don't even
know what I said Donya you're too young
for that you're Dandy could you earmuff
it for me real quick
basically had my earmuffs on because I
didn't understand a single word of that
uh I am too young I'm not being
uncomfortable and how many times you're
calling me you know I'm pretty close to
hitting 30 here I've owned a Kronos for
10 years you're doing great yeah okay
it's a bit older you know then you'll
realize but it's true and here comes
Peter Fiddler speaking of uh guys who
used to be candidates not anymore he's
still a great uh great player and
obviously uh would love to punch his
ticket into The Knockout just like
Vladimir kromnik I'm rooting for the old
guys because I'm old
um
there's nothing to fear but White's
position
white is checkmating himself here Queen
E3 check King F1
Queen f
3 actually it's over good yeah or queen
G1 with mate if you covered with rookie
two I I'm assuming you got that pawn
um you know Queen G1 Rook C2 and queen
D4 Peter's got the Checkmate the center
of the board made into C2 Alexander fear
one of the great players obviously from
Brazil for those who don't know fiere
also someone who traditionally does
pretty well in the Pro chess League good
rapid player but he he uh he just went
down in flames fiere was on fire you
flip those letters around and uh not bad
not bad Fiddler takes him down all right
we move on ready
okay and Hikaru land meanwhile trouble
is brewing in Hikaru land Danny he has
struggled this tournament he's managed
to withstand a lot of pressure by his
opponents he swindled the game against
Juma bayaf he held the draw against Nico
but right now he's in trouble again with
white his Center is collapsing yeah
you're a Bailey is just one of those
guys who doesn't care who he's playing
he plays for a win every game I've seen
his games now for many years Super Fun
player to watch and that D4 Pawn Yeah I
was gonna say about you to disappear
I guess ikoro didn't have a lot of great
choices there he was choosing between
poisons and ultimately decided that
losing the d-pawn in order to get
developed and have the bishop here was
his best practical chance not a bad not
a bad classic Hikaru kind of kind of
swindled there
um
but black is better make no mistake
about it and black could even take G3
and have an optical Bishop position that
would be hard to lose
well I'll tell you what durability is
thinking about I think he's deciding
whether or not to flick in the move Rook
ACA check which your logic would tell
you you should and he does but he was
just making sure that you're not
actually sending the king to a square
that it wants to go to anyway I don't
think you are because after King D2
Knight takes D4 and he have a hard time
believing he'll bail out with Knight
takes G3 when there's a juicy morsel
over there for the pick and that Knight
is also going to be threatening B3 with
check and C5 and this is what happens
when you lose the center Pawn all of
your other pawns are like you know WTF
where's our father and Hikaru that's the
sidestep that with King D1 oh this is
nasty
nasty and
it's it he you also have positional
weaknesses the risk of Black's position
is that if you lose D4 or even if black
takes G3 like you said and plays Rook E3
it's like black has the pawn and the
compensation as our buddy Yaz would say
what in the big instead Hikaru doe here
and King to D1 but this is what he does
the Anarchy forces his opponents to make
decisions I've noticed that when he gets
into lost positions he Engineers it so
that he gives the opponent a lot of
tempting options and that's not a good
thing because you necessarily spend a
bunch of time trying to find the right
one and it's the Hikaru effect it's what
it is because you know you have to play
perfectly to win and you get into a
self-fulfilling prophecy where then you
spend too long deciding and ultimately
you end up making a mistake I love the
way Drew or Bailey's handling this I
said he wouldn't take on G3 Danny but
the situation has changed because now
you have access to this E3 Square
yeah but if you get G4 by Hikaru can't
you put the bishop on F3 and just start
to hold it true well perhaps black will
take the beep on first and then try to
come back for the G pawn and somehow
Evacuate The Rook around
early is playing without risk I think he
he's trying to play for two results yeah
and that's not a bad thing
and now which Pawn is he gonna take B3
G3 you could bring the Rook up to E4
again Hikaru milking Black's clock by
making him forcing him to make decisions
yeah
agreed
hey Karu I'm gonna have the time on the
time advantage on the clock even if he
doesn't have one on the board something
he does all the time
speaking of time
will get to us all other time
it's about time
she just drew there again never got off
the ground Danny that was like even all
the way through
not as obvious a draw if you will uh as
the one we saw between Vladimir chronic
and Yonder pomnushy but but similar in
that the players understand what's at
stake getting to the next getting to the
next stage of this many different stages
it's quite the gauntlet if you want to
make it to the end and win the air
things Masters and so they understand
that right now at the playing stage
securing Division division one is their
top priority which doesn't even secure
The Knockout by the way it only secures
match play that Donnie and I are going
to be covering within a couple hours
here so if you just got here where have
you been mom has been calling all day
she's like hey would you pick up some
groceries I'm like Mom I already turned
the corner will you go back and finish
your groceries plus I'm late for the
twitch show anyway we're here we're in
it and uh
and yeah we got a lot of head but I I
will double down on what I said it's a
little early to just think that these
draws are going to secure top 12 for any
of these guys uh Dania so we'll see if
it backfires for for the guys who are
are playing it safe
for sure they got their work cut out for
him they still have three
huge rounds to play Hikaru he's in
trouble he's going to try to hold this
can we take a brief uh look at Nico
Theodore's game I think we we shall
should give him some love and he's
playing
Sam sebian by the way by the way new
2700 incredibly exciting American player
and Nico is in a world of hurt here
speaking of incredibly exciting player
new 2700 that's damn Savion we haven't
covered any of his games so far but we
might be covering a lot more of Sam
before the day is through because he's
about to get a second Queen two queens
are better than one I hear
he had an incredible performance in the
RCC I mean he's just a nightmare
opponent in Rapid he's just got the
fixings he's got a sharp style great
preparation doesn't fear anybody just a
great epitome of of the new crop of
talent across the world this is over I
think Danny because Knight F3 check one
Queen replaces the other oh Queen H1
covering any one square and d8 queen
coming to a theater near you one zero is
the result that was it that was nice and
five out of six that was a nice
instructive thing to show there just
that if Knight F3 check would come white
would have just sacrificed the queen and
then gotten a new one and so there
really was no way for Nicholas Theodore
to keep this one alive everybody Sam
sevian is saying hey hey guys I'm 2700
I'm kind of new to the club but I might
win the event before we're all said and
done so buckle up what else we got here
we're gonna go back to the uh the the
town known as nakamuraville
Smallville
small ability people will know that
reference
don't tell them wait for chat to show
well people know the TV series but do
you know they just I know you know I
know I know you know and I'm saying
don't say anything else because you're
gonna ruin it I know that you know that
I know that you know that I shouldn't
say anything else well Hikaru
might be cursing his luck here in this
position Zora Bailey
still hasn't secured a material
advantage by the way somehow Hikaru has
kept the pawn count even this is just
black magic and I think hegar is fine
again and now he's gonna start playing
for a win I was gonna say and he's
managed to increase his Edge on the
clock along the way uh classic classic
Nakamura
um last second all right well we're
gonna stay right here by the way there
are I'm just looking at the list there
are so many amazing players in this
event who we haven't even had a chance
to look at yet and it's just just wild
we are gonna have a lot of fun on these
playing days I hope I get to do all of
them I'm going to talk to the team be
like hey because they don't they don't
let me do commentary anymore they keep
me they keep me out I'll be like can I
do some can I do some commentary please
hey guys hi guys if you ask nicely well
Drew or Bailey by the way is asking
nicely to end this game and yeah he's
right now here we're going this again 99
of players would take on F7 there and
just bless their fatty cards like he's
got nine seconds let me win this real
quick and let's see the magician at work
as he brings his Rook up to F5 Black's
obviously not worse here but it's so
easy to miss a move like G5 severing in
the connection between the F Pawn and
the E Pawn you can sense the tricks B5 I
can guarantee you is going to be played
at some point yeah such as now
okay okay we're Bailey forcing some
trades here I love the way he's handling
this so far
yeah the uh A5
sorry I think the simplification is
going to lead to a draw no no you're
good you're you're I love I love when
you're excited
um me and me and all the chat I think
the simplification will get us closer to
a draw but it's really just going to be
a question of does durability blunder
under time pressure because this should
be held should be fine but unless that
d-pawn gets away from him or something
else of a catastrophe happens he should
be okay I can get well Hikaru was
thinking about that move A5 sacking a
pawn but then he runs the risk of losing
he doesn't want to do anything wild
because there is still time yeah even if
he draws to win the last three games at
that point he'll have to start taking
the big risks to our Bailey should not
lose this the one important thing Danny
you should keep his Rook on the G file
again to prevent now he can move it and
instead he moves his King up to B4 and
if Hikaru gets too casual here in two
Cavalier he's already lost the pawn
what do you say
he's pushing it too far
Rook B3 would be an instant draw he
still is playing for a win he doesn't
want to allow The Rook trade you can
sense it D4 oh
oh yeah no D3
oh
here goes another Pawn Now is really
getting frustrated
draw Danny and also regardless of
hikara's frustration don't assume that
he's not thinking he has mating chances
against that King on the a file I'm just
saying there's a chance going full
exactly knows who he's playing against
yeah run run do not get Rudolph
checkmated Run Run Rudolph and run it it
runs to C7 Hikaru is probably dreaming
about getting his King to G6 yeah I can
assure you that is what he's trying to
do dirt rally says no can do no serebi
car is going to get back to E4 dude and
he is still very much playing for a Win
Regardless oh wait he was yeah he could
have taken the king of five
no takes in G5 was winning takes it oh
my God
oh my God takes in G5 was winning the
bishop was undermined he's gonna win
this he's gonna win this game Jordan
Bradley's gonna flag you cannot get
yourself to two seconds against Hikari
he will find a way to make it
complicated and he has Bishop F4 defend
H6 well it's hanging still holding oh my
God Jordan Bailey is cutting this this
is ridiculous
knows that he had that win
oh my God that was ridiculous I might
have to show that Danny when we get a
moment yeah that was so beautiful I
thought it was winning because the
bishop was blocking the diagonal you
could just bring the king to G6 and win
H6 but G5 is just straightforward ah
Hikaru is gonna blow a gasket when he
figures this out and he will and right
now he might just have to repeat I threw
a Bailey cut it that close but it seems
like he's found out construction where
he can essentially pre-move yeah you
don't care about this Pawn you care
about the H Pawn which is what prevents
white from creating a passer
yeah
yeah oh my gosh wow can you believe you
had a win here I mean can you just
unbelief that thought is ridiculous in
and of itself
oh my gosh
Jesus
he's he's gonna he's not just gonna take
the draw here he's gonna make sure he
milks this is there any last way to get
a Swindle is what's going through
akaro's head do I have anything left in
the tank here I'll tell you what he
might do he's bringing himself down on
the clock there's an old old man's trick
you tempt black into playing for a win
and then you increase the chance that
your Bailey blunders I don't think it's
gonna work because white is actually
worse here King C3 and D3 is not to be
trifled with you get that pawn to D3 and
black starts playing for a win himself
so time he's taking the drill he's
taking the Drone Bailey gonna play for a
win now oh that's what he did he milked
him down on the clock but Derby doesn't
go for it he did what you said he was
doing
he uh no rather than repeating he got
way down in hopes that durability would
change his mind back up real quick Donya
real quick oh never mind we got other
games to look at that's gonna say if you
want to talk about this I'll pull up the
game after we finish this time scramble
because I saw this was an interesting
scramble lazovic against Prague in the
meantime I'll pull up hikaru's game and
we'll show the win okay great
I just love I love when you're driving I
just take my hands off the wheel and
you're in control
you know hey GM GMS aren't the best
drivers but oh my God I'm just driving
the pawn forward to promotion seven oh
no no you can get a knife
was me but obviously this is winning he
still wins but that's hilarious
Danny oh that was sick
oh you know what else is sick the Hikaru
win which I'm now gonna show yeah no
that was his date game against theodoro
I apologize
yeah
it was the uh
Rook takes B6 Dura Bailey right right
here Rook B6 takes and G5 go ahead
I mean look at this look at this FFG you
lose the bishop and yes the pawn is the
wrong color but the king is too far true
you can trust us on that here you go H6
upon is Unstoppable and it's Unstoppable
because you can try one last strict
Danny look at this King to D6 yeah if
you promote black wins the queen but the
king steps onto the square and then
white promotes that was the win how did
he miss the simple line with eight
seconds on the clock wow you are really
losing his abilities here
obviously the sarcasm is real
oh my gosh I I'm I'm I'm I'm in mind
blown territory
and uh
and I'm having a great time along the
way you know you know when your mind is
blown and you're having a good time it's
it's one of those
they call it zone two these days there's
all this science coming out about
exercise there's Zone one zone two zone
three zone four zone two is like you
know that flow you're hitting the Flow
State that's how I feel that's how I
feel right now well zone five is when
you're hitting a flow State along with
Danny wrench has lenyard Dominguez hit a
flow State this tournament not really
and he's struggling to win this position
up two pawns this actually might be a
draw I'm getting Vibes of Notre back
against Vincent kymer that type of end
game Dominguez is another guy that we
haven't checked into so far Danny and
this just showcases how strong this
tournament is he is not just any old
Grandmaster player Dominguez no when I
was looking at the West when I was
looking at the list of people we hadn't
checked in on yet Vincent kymer and
Lanier Dominguez Perez were right at the
top of that we did quickly have have a
look at a climber game but overall
there's just too many good players in
this event for us to keep track of
everyone for sure Gotta Give shout out
to Black for holding holding on so tight
here
um this is a lost end game but it's
it's one of those ones where White's
pieces are not ideal and so it's really
tricky to unwind well it's simple you
can't play A5 because you drop E5 in
order to play A5 you need to defend the
B5 Pawn you can't do that because the
king is cut off and the king is cut off
because any time it moves to B4 it
receives a side check by The Rook that
sends the King right back I think King
A5 is a draw here right no
yeah rooksy it's so easy to lose this
for black as you can lose purchase
in terms of your defensive setup yeah
now domingue is almost flagged there so
don't lose if you're white
when you're so tricky here tries to get
his King out he's managed but does that
help now it's cut off along the third
ring it's just a check and he's stuck
it's a bluff the King has got to go back
no ability to get out it was just a
bluff oh don't go to E4 and lose your
Rook if you go to F3 Danny yeah but if
you come to eight right now now King A5
is a threat
ah Rook C6 or k6 though might make some
progress if you're white
oh no King A5 Rook C6 take a four Rook
A6 there was King takes B5 it was a draw
a great town now Dominguez doubles back
to the to B2 black has to go King B6
again I'm not sure why this is winning
now a check Rook A6 and he's making
progress now he's going back
where's the win King C2 King A5 is still
a draw if you play King A5 Etc don't
miss it another time
the win is to get the Rook to A6 that
allows you to play A5 it's too late he's
gotten in tip-offs
as you called yeah now don't trade Rooks
obviously Rook H4 Rook H4
Rook H4 you threaten to take with the
Rook that's the key that's going to
force the Rook to A3 this is over uh not
over
oh man that is a trick
S Trading attempt
oh my God it takes A4 is the draw
King takes A4 B6 Rook B Rook G8 Rook to
B8 no Rook G2 wins for black uh you win
The Rook LOL and the kings are all
that's left in this one wow we get we
get the peaceful result it feels like
that was the correct karmic result again
we didn't see the whole thing but uh in
the end uh we have we have the nietzscha
as we like to say
um all right look at this borugia
caruana Den Laz I don't know who that
person is Vladimir
kramnikron look Wang Liam go ahead who
is denlin the topic
well Dan Laz is Dennis lazovic very soon
but I had a joke to share I had a joke
to share this might not land but since
he mentioned nichia all you have to know
to understand this joke is that nichia
is a double meaning it means draw it
also means no one's like the word no
ones so the old chest joke goes two
players are facing off one of them is in
a lost position and he points to a cat
that's running around he asks whose cat
is this the response nichia no one's and
then he says sugilisen agreed and they
shake hands classic classic
classic Tom fully using Russian Russian
language tricks all of us know those
jokes of course video I have many more
but okay we have games there on always
and for Russia in an open Roy savian has
been playing this opening now for a
while he played it in the RCC against
mvl he's played it in the U.S
Championship he's incredibly well
prepared arm to the teeth with the black
pieces in this line
Sam Sabian has more time than than which
he started with as you can see just like
Don just said he's an expert in these in
these variations of the Spanish and uh
farouzia taking a think
and making sure he remembers his theory
big question do you to on percent or not
I always say great Poupon on poisson
don't mind
G5 maybe some attack on each side
didn't show up he said he was coming I'm
a text Maxine be like yo you said you
were playing bruh where are you at
um MBL not here one of the only big
names in the game who didn't show up on
this Friday uh all right
borugia versus Sam sevian is here let's
not forget also going down in this round
you have Fabiano caruana taken on the
Quan Liam the world Bliss Champion
you've got uh Daniel dubov taken under a
Bailey uh
Hikaru Hikaru is is trying to stick in
it hasn't had his best chest today it
feels that he's not quite informed but
will he find it by the end no one wants
that to happen if they're if they're one
of the opponents of Hikaru and kramnik
is taking on gukesh a battle of the
generations oh sorry that is
I'm not saying we have to go to giving
the decision anxiety Danny you just
named six Michelin star restaurants and
now you're expecting me to choose okay
since we haven't looked at Le Quang lamu
yet I've only start there and then we
kind of go around the horn and look at
all the top games but this is the best
part this is where tons of players have
to take a lot of risk like Hikaru yeah
go ahead Danny I'm gonna flip on the
game in the meantime no I was gonna say
music to my ears I also kind of wanted
to check in on La Quang Liam I think of
all the people we've had the pleasure of
covering today Bobby on a carwana has
seemed to be in the finest form for
those just tuning in he's just been he's
just been a monster the games he won he
won in in in fine fashion
this is a game where now on the black
side of a Queen's Gambit decline it was
probably over goes in based on where
that Knight was yeah it was
um what's going on here Donya
yeah Lim is better that I can tell you
or a fact and fact number two he's got
exactly the kind of position he excels
excels in Danny not only is he the coach
of the Premier Webster team he's also I
think either a world Rapid or World
Blitz Champion I'll confirm that but
it's definitely one of the two it was
worthless Champion yeah the guy is a
wizard and he's one of those 2700s you
just forget about and then he just beats
you know Carolina and six other GM's in
an event why is he better well he's got
the ninth centralized on E5 he's got a
very solid Pawn triangle in the center
and he's got action on the king side so
Fabiano caruana without further Ado is
preparing C5 Lim says get the you know
what out of CA
my turn to push the C Pawn
Liam lay pushes C4 he's better but it's
also okay so you prefaced or you set up
the narrative that says yes why White's
better but to give Fabi credit C5 will
probably come and when it does it kind
of undermines the protection of the
Knight on E5 right and that's a key
point a key shot that black always has
in these structures to try to equalize
to get C5 take on D4 and try to simplify
against white space and pressure
yeah which is why Lim rushed the move C4
and you might even part ways with his
Knight and transform his Advantage from
an advantage in the center to one on the
queen side down the C file yeah what is
he calculating here probably he's
thinking which piece to recapture with a
common question Knight takes C4 and then
Queen takes C4 is natural to me Danny
especially because black can't play Rook
C8 which is crucial you can play C5 I
will point out but after dcbc white can
just bring the Rook to D1 and he's got a
small but very stable and nagging edge
here Fabi has to make a couple of very
accurate moves I think to fully equalize
dcbc but uh black is not out of the
Jungle yet thank you AC DC for that
incredibly important classic rock hit
I'll give you a B minus for that one you
know that's pretty good grade in my book
I'm a strict grader I've given my share
of D's
in these puns pretty good though I think
I think I can retire after that one
that was a subtle and appropriate
pop culture reference that added value
to the moment
Welcome to the Jungle AC how could you
not say that that was an A plus bro
listen I come from the Soviet School of
grading where B minus is essentially the
new a plus that is the highest grade
that you can get I've told that story
Danny many times what my coach said when
I got my third Grand Master Norm
his response was two letters long to my
Skype message that was accompanied by 30
exclamation mark okay and then you
logged off
I became a GM okay this is so great all
right move on all right Liam is better
here I love this move Bishop B7 because
it's patiently reminding black that that
c Pawn is going nowhere grab a Snickers
it's weak and I will take it when I want
you say Bishop B6 but don't I have
uh okay Bishop B6 maybe that's actually
I didn't see that come this morning well
Bishop E6 to me is the bailout move and
I feel like white is losing a little bit
of purchase on this position in the
sense that his pieces are sort of
slipping away from the center white
doesn't have that pawn on T4 uh oh this
is a tactical problem Bishop B5
so white might have to go Rook B1 and
Fabi then has dragged The Rook onto an
awkward Square maybe then he wants to
play Queen E6 off for the queen trade or
bringing the queen even to Jesus Oh
Bishop E6
wow Jungle Guns and Roses not AC DC
uh you're talking to the wrong audience
here
oh my God that is the worst I'm the
worst
get out of here oh my God I'm the worst
okay let's pretend that didn't happen
like everything else on the internet
um
like Tom Brady's last season you know
you're retired in the attitude you only
get one emotional retirement response so
the fact that I took off my headphones
and then ranted about how you didn't
appreciate my AC DC reference I will
never again I will never again be upset
about lack of acknowledgment for a pop
culture reference you heard it flip it
and ship it fans you have my word
I will make I will make pop culture
references but I won't get upset anymore
if I'm not being appreciated
all right here we go
um
I love this question for Donya and Danny
how much has Bobby improved in faster
time controls I I would argue two things
on that and I know Robert would back us
up Donya one Bobby's
Bobby's weakness his reputation of not
being good at fast time controls I would
argue was always a little overrated
because not many people beat Magnus
Carlson in Rapid tiebreakers I don't
know if you knew that right it's not the
easiest thing to do that said he wasn't
certainly on the level of your hikarus
of your magnuses uh your yonda palm
machine or even Maxine bashayla grub
like he hasn't necessarily considered
himself a great rapid and Blitz player
and we know that he did go to work on it
and I think it showed I mean he was one
of the top performers in last year's
rapid Chess Championship I think he
likes this time control uh specifically
he's told me that the 10 plus two format
he just feels comfortable and at home
here but your thoughts Donya I gave my
answer to it
I completely agree I think it was always
overrated as well you know sometimes
reputations in the chest world can be
hard to shake and most of the time
they're unfounded or they're based on
one tournament performance like you know
draw Anish Geary uh and all and all that
jazz and a lot of people might not
remember that to reference ICC again
Fabiano caruana his nickname was
adaptation and he was one of the highest
rated players in the five-minute pool so
no he has never been the fastest bullet
player the best Blitz player but we
always compare these players to other
super GMS and Magnus Carlson is the
standard that we hold them to and yes
he's not as good he's not as reliable in
time scrambles but Fabi has done a great
deal to improve his actual results he
was always good to begin with Danny but
now he has stabilized in time pressure
he has won some time scrambles against
some of the blitz best Blitz and bullet
players in the world we saw that
regularly in the RCC and he is in the
SEC right he beat it he surprised a lot
of people by taking down Arjun irigaisi
right and
amazing fashion that was an amazing
match
yep so for those who did it in the
bullet yeah I was just gonna say for
those who didn't follow the match uh
Fabiano was actually trailing and came
back in the bullet portion to beat Arjun
irregacy of course someone who is an
absolute star in Monster rising star
from India so so yeah and I think you
know there's our explanation of it and I
think in Rapid in particular we're not
claiming fabi's one of the best Bowl
players in the world just pointing out
that he he can do it and has but I would
say in Rapid in particular Donya it's a
Time control that actually he really
kind of likes you know and and this
format is showing and he's obviously
playing well today so we'll see
he's playing well he's got the
initiative now he's sacked upon but
brought his Rook to D2 and he's hitting
well that pawn used to be on A2 now it's
on A4 but White's pieces are in a bit of
a bind here yeah and White's King is
feeling a little bit uncomfortable black
does have this uh move Bishop C4 that he
could play at any point to drive the
Rook out of F1 instead Fabi Gets behind
the pawn so it's a sharp position yep I
would predict that this game bails out
somehow maybe white should play Queen B6
and just you know accept that he's going
to be defending in an end game for a
while but I think like Quang will pull
himself together here and pull out half
a point but we'll see we got a lot of
other fascinating games
I'll put you on the spot Danny where to
next well I'm a little biased because
I'm looking at the other leaders of the
event including all these and Sam sebian
it's a spicy Spanish you know how I feel
about some spicy span or some good
paella oh my gosh I could go for that
right now what in the world would that
do making me miss Madrid
um man the some of the best
food anyway here we go we got that okay
so I'm literally blacking out focus
Danny on the the games and not the food
chromic and gukesh was the Battle of
generations that we talked about in the
beginning let's check in on that one
real quick
boy am I happy we finally got Madrid of
that discussion
and I like trying to get Madrid of the
dark Squad Bishop Bishop H4 G5
Bishop G3 Queen takes G3 can't do that
no can do boy
okay well
we're gonna stick right here farusha and
Sam seven we'll check in on Chrome in a
minute H6
yeah I love your idea of Queen G3
hitting F2 by the way whether ever
happens or not I just want to
acknowledge you and your feelings that I
like that idea
thank you Danny I'm I'm all warm and in
the heart place so I think white should
drop back to E3 and that's not the most
Pleasant move to make yeah you know
you're not winning any brilliancy prizes
and he plays it but a Hallmark of these
top players is that they know when to
dial it back and take a step back and
say yeah I'm not better anymore but I'm
gonna stay solid we're gonna get some
trades down the e-file black can take
again and put the other Rook on E8 on
the other hand
when it's on f8 it's pressuring the
bishop on F5 but I would play rookie 8
here he does and just kind of chill
maybe 95
trade some more pieces Black's pretty
comfortable here I think yeah he's also
up a little bit on time that's not you
know an advantage that you write home
and tell Mom and Dad about but it is a
good sign for for Sam Simeon because
borugia one of the fastest players in
the world you don't want to be
significantly down on the clock against
him so a good sign for sevion
Here Comes 95 just like you said it also
frees up the C Pawn point out that idea
because now black can play both C6 to
reinforce D5 and at some point maybe
even C5 and you've got a majority with
the four on three
and I would be remiss if I didn't point
out something I always point out there's
only one open file you have to see who
controls it in this case it is black
with a Vengeance he's got both of his
heavy heavy pieces on the e-file
farrugia is creating a dark Square
blockade on the queen side I like that
move Knight to B3 aiming for C5 also
getting his teeth into the D4 Square the
position is equal to Annie I think it's
kind of dynamic equality where both
sides have their chances yeah but the
clock continues to dwindle we could get
a bailout and a draw or things could
devolve into pandemonium here in the
next couple moves if especially if
Flacco is 94 which I think he very well
might
I was going to say is is black ever
looking to play like Queen E2 in some of
these positions just simplify because he
owns the only open file and gets The
Rook on the second rank is that an idea
for for semian I think that's a great
move I think that's probably one of his
time not the top candidate move that
he's contemplating right now my guess
would be he's deciding between 94 Queen
E2 there is Bishop E2 which is tempting
but it's it's kind of a paper tiger the
queen can drop back to C2 and then that
Bishop is really awkward and it can be
targeted with rookie one so I don't
think he's doing that I kind of am
leaning toward Queen E2 okay
made me feel all good I was just making
this yeah I'm hoping for some in the
compliment but for some education man I
was like hey will you educate me on on
what's going on here with that second
Rank and you just instead you serve me
up a compliment education sandwich you
complimented me you gave me some
education then you complimented me again
man I am all blushing and torn up
I'm just trying to play some chest man
Queen F4 Savion is trying to stick a
rook on E2 his intentions are violent
Daniel he's not just bailing out he's
playing for a win here yep
still a possibility but not as likely
because D5 is going to fall with check
but White's position is just unstable
and Danny it's all because he doesn't
control the e-file what you wouldn't
give right now to play the move rookie
one and just stabilize those squares he
can't do it
how does farrugia respond to this move
yep I've had nothing to say but yep I'm
just I'm yupping you right now I'm not
trying to yup you but I'm yupping you
because everything you're saying is so
is so right on and yeah I always talk
about it also I would be remiss to not
do the bad analogy I always do and say
open files are like Commodities supply
and demand the less there are the more
valuable there are they are and usually
you can see a game that is otherwise
looking equal otherwise very symmetrical
B1 purely because one player owns the
only open file
that's actually pretty insightful point
and in this case that owner I love how
you were surprised you were like that's
I've never heard of it
Danny wrench you know he's got some wise
things to say once in a while
well G4 was played inside G4 was
aggressive but almost out of necessity
right it's like an aggressive move that
you're playing because it's really hard
for farusha to find other ways to deal
with this
yeah it's kind of an aggressive
defensive move because most people play
cg4 they think he's trying to attack
that could not be further from the truth
he's just making space for his pieces on
the king side he brings his King up and
right now his top priority I think is to
trade Queens if you can get the Queens
off the board he takes some of the heat
off of Black's pressure then you have to
reckon with rookie 8 to E2 but that's a
problem I think white uh wouldn't mind
having right now
good point and uh something I want to
jump to right now we had a good question
from Chad Legend
091201 wants to know whether we think
alireza is suffering from not playing
enough online chess and some of these
moments I mean he's not suffering that
much we should at least call out he's
currently leading the event so there's
no way that he's uh suffering that much
but I think what we'll what we'll tell
everyone is there are things you do when
you're in shape regardless of your
knowledge when you're in shape right
your cardio's there you do things
intuitively to use the right kind of
sports analogy you do things you have
more stamina when it matters so I think
it's a little too early to tell but if
it does catch up with alireza it might
be because he hasn't played serious
online chess we know he's played some
bullet here and there uh in quite a
while but don't you what do you think
yeah you know I think the influence of
that can be kind of overstated as we're
seeing even in this tournament some like
Vladimir kramnik he doesn't play online
at all and he is acquitting himself
incredibly well farouja has played
online in his entire life he still plays
a lot of bullet so I really think that
his form is perfectly sufficient for
this tournament and his time control he
played a tournament like the candidates
right now you would probably feel the
rust a little bit more well someone who
is surmounting a lot of the rust that we
expected is Vladimir criminal can we
take a dip into his game really quickly
I was just gonna say though
unfortunately you made you made the note
of chronic as a as a comparable to say
that you know uh it's it's an example
that you don't have to play a lot of
online yes but to go back to my analogy
I said that usually it's too early to
tell until you see who's got the cardio
when it matters because the thing about
yeah exercising and playing a lot is you
have more stamina you keep your focus
down the stretch right now I'm looking
at a game where Vladimir kromnik might
be about to go down and maybe is
catching up with him a little bit
against the young cash from India he
sacrificed in exchange earlier it did
not work out to put it mildly now he's
in exchange and a pawn down and Rook C2
I think deals the hammer blow to Black's
can to White's King because the other
Rook is coming down in the second Rank
and if you play G4 to create some
reeving room it's a classic construction
Rook D3 is Checkmate I think Vladimir he
might go Bishop D6 here and hold on for
a couple more moves but not more than
that he's also falling on the clock as
well this is over this is this is
completely one-sided
yo good good point good stuff B7 is fine
here I mean cash can do basically
whatever he wants he just needs a couple
more moves to break down the last
remnants of White's defensive
construction here grab Nick is going to
keep trying though he's not just going
down as he should he's also down on the
clock though unfortunately while he
tries to play tickle here and maybe
trick the young young opponent into uh
into repeating the same position a few
times but um I don't think ukesh will
fall for that
so many interesting games here Danny
it's one of those things right for Rouge
is in a Time scramble Carolina might be
about to win in the end game
oh my gosh nepo's in the time scramble
uh help me out here you want me to
choose I shall choose let's go to the
nipple game we haven't checked on that
in a minute okay young the pawn machine
he's he's much better actually he's
better and up on the clock so I think
yawn might be someone who just continues
to keep pace and jumps to five and a
half after this one
John is just the Ultimate Nightmare
opponent he plays so quickly puts so
much pressure now material here is equal
and lazovic is a multiple Time title
Tuesday winner so 17 seconds for him is
a lot the problem is to me more on the
board I actually think Jan might grab
this Pawn on B2 and try to use the a
pawn to win the game but it's not going
to be easy Danny because in some
situations why can sack the knife for
that pawn and then come around and
eliminate these weak pawns on the king
side so this Yan's work here is far from
done in fact objectively we see that the
position might be close to equal yeah
I think the main thing is you got to
worry about time if your dentist yeah
right I mean you're under five seconds
four seconds
move he does play King E2
sidestepping the Discover check
might be two Knight C5 don't do that
King T5 Knight C3 Forks Galore here and
Black's not the only one having another
one Guardian can I run to F5
oh and go toward the king's side
little hole there on G4
for the king I don't know bang let's say
you're bang right you could win this in
two moves because you're also going
after these Pawns yup I I think that
John obviously taking a moment that's
how you manage your time well if you're
watching chat when you have an advantage
on the clock use your clock as a weapon
shout out to John Bartholomew in
critical moments don't keep rushing
take a moment execute yeah actually
gives up the a pawn oh King's E4 that
was a huge mistake by white allowing the
king to get active oh and there's
nothing is going to say that's over
that's how quickly he wins these games
you just
trick after trick and that is a winning
workout game just because Black's king
is too active and that c Pawn
wait okay it's not totally over he has
to be careful but with three seconds
there's no way lots of it you're not
holding this it is a loss for can you
and you're down on the clock so let's
all right I mean we can we can see the
final moments Perugia maybe isn't a Time
scramble
so many games oh my gosh man I think
virus is losing I think we should go to
farusha because this will be his first
loss of the tournament if he loses this
game they're a ramble watch this and
whoa
Sam sevian showing what he does the
young American Grand Master because it
wasn't a fluke that I was in Toronto at
the cgc finals here we go oh yeah but as
I say it he's losing it a little bit but
I still think black Knight's favorite E5
though it's always better to have the
knight in time scrambles that is like a
universal rule there's more Forks more
tricks he's got more pawns by one but
for Russia has two passers and he might
bring his King out of the way Danny and
try to go Rook to G6 here and this is a
three result game believe it or not that
F Pawn runs real fast
yeah here we go great points
great move rookie three chasing the
bishop around and now D3 no he wants a
fork on that three oh he's funner the
pawn
light Knight's coming to F3 at some
point with check don't forget that watch
out for here it goes D2
oh he's coming right after it oh what a
tricky move Knight G5 King F2 hits the
rook and you might not be able to get to
that Bishop
but you have rookie two and Knight takes
Bishop oh my gosh that does win he wins
a piece of Peace oh he didn't see it
that was a terrible move now he's worse
Bishop G6 and F5 for Russia might now
win this or we might see a repetition
holy canola gosh
this is insane king after you go for it
getting F2 wins for white he did oh my
God he's there too he was winning a
piece oh my land's there this is pure
nerves and he finally says enough is
enough let's make that draw
I don't disagree it was a fair result
poetically uh but both sides had wins
and not just like two or three moves
like one move one move combos to win
there and and neither of them seem to be
keeping their nerves and again these are
chess Gods I'm I'm not saying I would do
any better but it does seem like they
both lost their nerves a little bit
there because normally we see them
execute I would say at a high level even
with that much pressure no they
certainly did I mean they know it's on
the line and those positions are just so
tricky there's minor pieces in close
proximity Forks everywhere you're just
trying not to lose on time speaking of
not losing on time couple more games
still going here in rounds we actually
have one more game still going and it's
one more game's still going and it is
jaspam that is Martinez versus Robson
the caterpillar whom is spicy
after this game we are going to send it
to our last break before we know who
wins the uh the the play-in segment of
the air things Masters so
stick right here we got to see what
happens in this game looks like spicy
caterpillar has a chance
I think we know who's winning this game
Ray is zigzagging his way and a rook
trade is good for white because he's got
both pawns protected by the bishop
jasmus two seconds here still trying to
hold
the advantage of having a g-pawn instead
of an H Pawn oh this is a nightmares
defense in a Time scramble Ray needs to
find an opportunity to go Rook F6 and
force the king away and then start
pushing the Jeep on eventually
yeah I'm surprised he's waited so long
at some point you can play Rook F6
you could have moved the light Square
Bishop uh to B5 once the king isn't
attacking the G Pawn but he doesn't go
for that plan
no he does not
now he can give a check on H5 but he's
delaying it he doesn't want to blunder
that pawn
yeah oh you might have wanted a pawn
where's that Bishop going it has to
choose a diagonal and then you lose a
pawn
what
that was an instant draw if he took the
bishop
20 seconds one second
you made that move with 1.2 seconds oh
Ray's gotten his Bishop on the best
Square now G5 is coming and the king is
going to see the other Pawn through to
promotion I think
F7 it's over no this is winning he's got
it no it's over and you got the bridge
set up but the Rook protecting the king
from checks that means there is no A7
Perpetual coming
sick win
G7 and it's Rover Ray Robson keeps
himself in the hunt even if it is an
outside chance no no resignation from he
wants to make Ray made him and uh I
think we know how this one is going to
end in just a few seconds
Ray's doing what the pros do he doesn't
even need to do it here he's got enough
time but he keeps his pieces mostly on
the light squares which is what you do
in a Time scramble to make sure that you
don't walk into a skewer always possible
there we go right he just attacked The
Rook
but Rey is going to finish this one off
easily it is it is it is silly but it's
an even more important trick for viewers
to remember when you have increment
because in that in that moment you're
not you're not also really racing
against the clock a couple of fast moves
with all of your pieces on the light
squares are enough for you to regain
time
and then get the job done as Ray just
did so that's actually a really
important thing to remember Donya good
call out on that right get your pieces
on light squares so that uh
so that you can gain time on the clock
well on that note I think it's time for
us to take our uh our last break and
speaking of something we do before we're
back on the clock let me remind
everybody that uh if you're a title
player
and you want to compete in the 2023
Champions chess tour you actually can do
that don't miss your chance to qualify
for the next plan we host qualifier
events every single Monday excluding the
days when other CCT events are underway
so it's your chance to join the action
all you have to be is a title player
compete this Monday February 13th or
sorry the following Monday February 13th
not February 6th all the details can be
found at the Champions chess tour site
go to go dot go.chess.com
Champions chess tour for the direct link
or the command use the command
qualifiers in chat or the direct link
all right Donya you and I got to take
our last break here
before we know who wins the plan today
don't go anywhere it's the air things
Masters playing as we kick off the 2023
Champions chess tour when we return
[Music]
welcome in to our new video lecture
series here with the one and only the
14th World chess champion vishwanathon
Anan if you have to explain that you're
world champion and it's take taking
longer than two words there's something
wrong with your title and that's how I
felt there's something wrong but I
believe in when we're talking the 60s
and 70s even the 80s and 90s
you could see that
the match format produced something
unique and I remember there was a funny
moment at the press conference where I
was trying to tone it down
not get very excited and also I had not
had time to collect myself in fact I
already wanted to calm down and think of
the next game because I knew this is a
wounded animal there I knew that I had
to play a game against the man who is
desperate for the match to be over so
that he could clinch his title he wanted
a draw at any price I mean you can make
a joke that he had spent a week out of
the swimming pool already so he must
have been exhausted and waiting to
finish so for all of us there was this
feeling of
um we got to grab this chance with both
hands because it's not going to come by
away
[Music]
foreign
thank you
we are live we are back the 2023
Champions chess tour kicked off today
with the air things Masters plan we are
getting down to the stretch here with
just a couple rounds left before we move
on to match play so Dania let's remind
everybody quickly what's at stake in the
Swiss how does this format work 76 of
these top Grand Masters are going to be
moving on to match play respectively in
three divisions with the top division
being for the top 12 finishers that are
currently competing in the playing that
you and I have been covering the next 20
in division two the next 44. obviously
they're all competing to join the Air
things Masters knockout which will start
next week after a weekend break on
February 6. so Donya on that note we
want to talk about the person who's now
leading who kind of came from behind it
is actually in clear first with us that
ish of India Dania you didn't have a
great uh speech Yes Championship that we
held in December he didn't have a great
time to steal but he has shown up and
he's playing great right now here to
kick off the CCT and I think gukesh
might be a victim of what I talked about
a little bit earlier which is the sort
of recency bias that often pervades the
chess Community where you look at the
last two tournament performances and his
Olympiad performance kind of is already
in the shadows I mean the guy had seven
out of seven I think against all GMS he
beat Bobby with black cash is still very
much having an amazing and amazing 2022
this year is just getting started so I
don't think ukesha's confidence is
shaken in the least but Danny this
tournament I can't believe is in clear
first he lost an early game I think
that's why he flew under the radar so he
did do a Swiss Gambit except it's a
Swiss Gambit where you have to beat
Vladimir kramnik in the previous round
of black which of course he did and now
he faces an on-form Sam sebian which is
a pretty terrifying Prospect and Sam he
gets a double black that's a tough
pairing but I think he Embraces the
challenge
agree totally Sam Sam Embraces the
challenge if you're if you're just
tuning in what is John you're referring
to Sam just Drew Ali Reza farouza with
black a game where he was better
throughout most of the battle so Savion
is playing some Fantastics yesterday
Dunder before we talk about the X's and
O's on the board in this battle I also
want to just highlight the standings to
our left look at that list of names A
Who's Who of some of the best chess
players in the game and uh again I'm
gonna call attention to the fact that
there were a couple players who took
early draws yonda Palm Desi and Vladimir
cronnick and then cronic lost the next
round right all the reservation 500 car
one I had an early draw but it's not
guaranteed that they're going to be in
the top 12 yet so a lot is at stake here
in these final two rounds
oh absolutely everything is yet to be
decided I mean the top 12 can change
completely and you've got some players
who like ukesh have kind of been under
the radar I mean look at gusainov Dennis
lazovic who did lose to yawn upon Nishi
but still is very much relevant you
don't necessarily need you know eight
out of nine a score of seven might
actually get you in if you've got good
tie breaks
and uh right now gukesh and sevyan they
top the tournament standings kukesh has
a chance to solidify his place with a
well-timed win here against M7 and I
think he's off to a pretty good start in
this game Danny
yeah so let's talk about this particular
this particular one in action it was a
London system don't fall out of your
chair when I say that because it kind of
just became a traditional sort of
reverse qgd kind of structure but
um your thoughts on on why you like
Lucas's position here I love this move
95 unleashing the discovered attack of
the queen on D1 to hit the Knight talk a
little bit about what you see white
doing over the next few moves oh White's
just more active and you know what I
don't like about Black's position is
that he's cramped on the queen side that
pawn on A5 is really controlling a lot
of key squares it's not letting the
queen move out to B6 it's making it hard
for black to create Pawn play on The
Queen side and of course the Knight on
E5 if I can find a way to support it or
even if white grabs that bishop and
maybe follows up with eight I was gonna
say A6 and Bishop B5 White's just having
more fun in this position not saying
that he's much better or anything like
that but Sam needs to proceed very
cautiously the next couple of moves
yeah and if the light score Bishop Falls
after Knight takes D7 as you've
highlighted not just Bishop B5 white has
the bishop pair which is a long-term
advantage two Bishops are better than
one
hey the bishop pair brought to you by
Doublemint gum oh my gosh that just
worked out
um if only
um but all right it's uh it's up now for
Sam Sevin to think about how he wants to
deal with this driving that a pawn down
so aggressively what a thorn right in
black shoe that kind that you just you
thought you checked your socks you get
them on now you're already mid-run
you're running hard and you're like what
is going on here something's poking me
oh it's a Pawn on A6 and it's poking my
big toe very sensitive yeah that pawn is
just a destructive force on the queen
side you might be wondering what savian
is thinking about here B6 is often
automatic but he is not a fan of the
resulting position and the weakness of
the C6 square and white could pile on by
opening up the queen side later on with
the move C4 that's a pretty terrifying
Prospect given how weak Black's Knight
is going to be on C6 unsupported as it
is by a bond so Savion is trying to find
a way to avoid that there's a there's
moves like Queen C7 here even taking on
A6 could be a way to stall white from
playing Bishop B5 the problem is The
Rook could take the Pawn's place and
that could be even worse
yep
yeah let's show it we'll show the
options here so if uh okay if black
takes E5 let's say because you can't
okay either one okay if you take E5 just
want to show you can use B7 okay sorry
so yeah take E5 white takes back and
then takes B7 and then takes A7 and then
out of the question yeah right so you
got to deal with A6 first that was the
point I wanted to show now that we
established E5 can't be dealt with you
gotta either play B6 or B takes A6 first
kind of
yeah and if you take this is what I
hinted at Earl nope that is not where
the Rook is going to land The Rook
appears on a six and then the bishop on
B5 and the Knight on A5 and this is
where you regret not having a Pawn on B6
too at least keep the Knight confined
but the what we're expecting and I am
expecting the move B6 with through
clenched teeth yes but still this is the
position Sam is trying to evaluate and
trying to assess how bad this is but
this possibility Danny of Rook C1 and C4
it's such an easy plan and you don't
want to allow positions where your
opponent has all the low-hanging fruit
uh in a rapid game
tough stuff no I love it and that's what
I I'm glad we showed on the board
because at the end of this line again
even if white isn't winning something
right away with the bishop B5 it's that
the position is going to become open
White's gonna get C4 when you have the
bishop pair it's much harder for your
opponent to keep a position closed it's
much easier to slowly pry open diagonals
and files so that's why we often say the
earlier you get a bishop your advantage
in a game often the better for you
because now you know your plan you know
you can start to pry open diagonals and
I think that Sam is using his time for a
reason this is actually a very tough
moment where the rest of the game might
be set in motion from whatever he
decides to do right here but he's got to
make a decision soon he's down to five
minutes and he does take on A6 radical
measures desperate situations Desperate
Measures and I'm almost certain that
gukesh is going to eliminate that juicy
Bishop on D7 the bishop itself doesn't
look like a good piece Danny it's more
about the squares that it's controlling
on the queen side giving white the
Monopoly over B5 and C6 gives white the
enduring Queen side advantage
maybe Knight takes C6 and Rook takes A6
because it comes with Tempo is calling
gukesh's name as well but I would take
that bishop and you know cash in my
chips here
I liked I liked it the first time you
said it so I'm not going to disagree
with you now take on D7 take A6 you've
got the bishop pair he he agrees gukesh
doesn't need a lot of time to go for it
he's just big fans of our commentary
he's like I I like these guys I'm gonna
go with what they said you know what I'm
in
um safe safe decision always works out
well of course we know speaking of
people that are still in it Donya like
we can't even see all the big names who
sit on five of seven on the left if
you're just tuning in there are so many
top Grand Masters in the hunt right now
for that coveted top 12 spot so that
they get to have a chance to be in the
division one section as next year's mate
next week's Main Event not next year's
next week's Main Event the other things
Masters kicks kicks off so Hikaru
Nakamura round Ox are in a battle you
can't even see hikaru's name there on
the left even though he actually does
sit at five of seven like everybody else
so let's check in on that real quick and
see what the five time U.S Champion is
up to here with the black pieces
well his opponent is the formidable
round accident which should be a
familiar name to everybody not quite uh
a star that shines as bright as gukesh
and aragaisy but still an incredibly
talented exciting young player from
India he's a super strong Blitz player
and he's got the white pieces here
trying to fend off the cars initiative
uh in what started out as a re Lopez but
I almost thought this was a king's
Indian but that Bishop he encountered on
G7 now Danny positionally White's got an
advantage on both sides of the board
this night is nicely centralized the
other night can jump into C6 but
hikaru's pieces are very active here so
it's actually a tremendously complex
position eval bar gives a tiny little
pull for black but I can see this going
either way in the next couple moves I
completely agree but I also uh even
though I'm the one who queued us up for
this of course we all wanted to check on
with ikaro but I think the game between
I think the game between Yonder bomb
machine and Fabiano caruana I'm sorry to
throw it but that is an imbalance worth
jumping to we have a queen on the board
for one player and no Queen for the
other it's it's the battle As Old As
Time who will be better the centralized
queen and the potential mating net
against the dark swears of the G7 Pawn
or the two Rooks in the past Apon what
is going on here
I think only one side has all the chips
here and that's yeah and it's a lot of
it is because of the placement of the
bishop it's not the queen per se it's
the way that it combines and cooperates
with the bishop to first of all attack
G7 second of the bishop itself is
incredibly stable yon might very well
lose the C2 Pawn but he's definitely and
he just did but he's not gonna lose the
C3 Pawn Fabby on the other hand right is
going to lose A5 which I would take if
I'm in the on shoes and as usual Danny
he's up four minutes he's got somehow
seven and a half minutes that might be
the death sentence for Fabi he takes the
other Pawn does yeah it says I'll get
back to the A5 Pawn when I'm ready I was
gonna say that's a sign that Yellen
definitely knows he's playing for a win
not just because of the centralized
bishop and the potential threats against
G7 like you said but the time advantage
on the clock he's like look I don't want
to take A5 and have this Peter out let's
get a race I'll let you keep your iPhone
I'll keep my C Pawn I'm gonna use my
queen to attack G7 and irritate the
bleep out of you yeah the more I look at
it first I took that quick peek I'm like
oh two Rooks for a queen could be
anyone's game but this is a really good
example of how and why the queen can
dominate Pieces by attacking things on
both sides of the board when you have a
weakness next to your king especially
but do not play Queen C7 here and
blunder Rook takes D4 John's not gonna
do that and Yana is just terrifying to
play when he's in this kind of form now
it's not all bad for Bobby and Bobby's
Rooks are active
most likely Fabi is going to lose the A5
pawn and when he does he has to arrange
his Rooks in a way that will first of
all keep G7 defended and B try keep to
keep the C3 Pawn at Bay it's an
incredibly tall order Danny he's got no
counter play because the bishop protects
the gatekeeper to the white King on H2
which is on the safest Square on the
board tough tough job for Fabiano but
he's obviously not going down without a
fight
as you're describing what he has to do
to hold this I'm sitting here shaking my
head it just seems like Too Tall of a
task that that Bishop on D4 you'd almost
love to give up one of the Rooks Donya
for the bishop and the pawn the problem
is even if you do that the queen has
three pawns and you're probably still
losing so like there's no real way to
simplify the pressure and that Queen is
just gonna poke and produce she'll go to
A7 and how are you dealing with this
stuff it's
I don't like it yeah I do like some
things right I don't like this thing
right here I like some I don't like this
thing one two three times I told you I
don't like this thing right here I would
reciprocate but that is one of my you
know shamefully one of my weak spots
um as as an impersonator now Fabi might
have just hastened his demise of the
movie before I actually like that
decision practically he's allowing point
a seven Danny and I think he's preparing
to give up the exchange and pin all of
his hopes on that past Pawn in A4 it
should not work I think John's got
enough time to refute this but we know
that Jan can sometimes get sloppy in
these situations and I I think this is
what Bobby's hoping for at this point
can get sloppy sometimes he doesn't
always make his bed
I mean that too
evidence on camera if you if you tried
to tell Mom that you already made your
bed you just got caught on camera buddy
because not good man it's not a made bed
blankets and damn we could see his
toilet there's so this is wrong on many
many levels and what he just did there
might have been very wrong I think I
called it into existence Danny I just
think he's made a huge misjudgment
okay he he allowed the sack on D4 but
more importantly he's allowed to counter
play Bobby's training Bishop E4 and I
think Jan forgot that the G2 Pawn is now
vulnerable this actually might already
be
a dead draw that's crazy and yeah comes
to E4 I think he thought he had D5 which
is a discovered attack on The Rook on F2
but then what black just plays Rook D2
he hits the d-pawn bishop E4 is a threat
and it's and you're right
wow and wow if I may rewind really
briefly to the moment when Bobby had
played A4 I think Jan should have taken
this pawn and then brought his Queen up
to A7 and this might be what he missed
this necessitates an exchange sack and
obviously with a three on two as you had
pointed out earlier this is a technical
win for five people we're past that now
John and he is by the way I was gonna
say he hasn't given up on a chance to
win by activating his King he's got
these Chances with the Deep Pawn still
he has to find a way to push that pawn
Fabi has to find a way to set up a
fortress on the D5 Square not easy to do
though is when The Rook comes to G5
there's H4 I think that's where yon uh
is really pinning his hopes but Bobby
could even give the bishop up for the
pawn potentially and there are some Rook
fortresses you could set up I think
he'll make it happen
shout out to Bobby though for kind of
spotting that trick right that's what
good players do when they're losing he
kind of he kind of baited yawn into that
right a little bit of a trap there
recognizing his chances to hold with the
rook and Bishop versus the queen we've
talked a lot about Rooks and Bishops
today a lot of long distance
relationship references you didn't see
coming
D5 here he goes Rook D2
no maybe yes
by the way so many games so much at
stake in this round We're not gonna be
able to cover all of them just pointing
out that uh I think Dimitri on draken
already got a win uh Fair chess on
YouTube maybe not I'm just trying to
track the standings here so much at
Stakes yeah he's six of eight
oh my gosh that is a huge win sevian is
still playing and still suffering at the
hands of gukesh where we can go at any
moment
okay but we can also stay here
you've got Hikaru trying to come back
against brownie
you've got Ali resin farrugia in this
round still still going against Liam lay
looks like Hikaru will not be able to
win I think that game is likely to end
in a draw yeah which is bad news for
Hikaru he is flirting with not making it
to division one
we can go there briefly let's do it
let's flash let's Flash hikaru's game
versus Roundup sodwani yep I agree it
looks
looks like he could still lose this you
have to be very careful this is actually
a very sharp position he's just played
Rook B8 and he's trying to keep winning
chances alive this is what he does A6
would be a horrible blunder
well would it actually a six Rook B1
White's Bishop controls the promotion
square but I wouldn't dip my feet in
that toxic swamp
if I'm sidwani I try to find a way to
keep the pawn at Bay maybe Rook to A2
here would be more wise
yeah well if you end up trading the C2
Pawn for the A5 Pawn depending on how
that goes down and where the pieces are
at the end it's even that isn't over I
mean white has this advantage that all
of Black's pawns are stuck on dark
squares highlight those for me baby
they're targets for the white for the
white Bishop you know what I'm talking
about right now look at that that it's a
white king Done Yet the white king gets
in from F3 G4 H5 or F5 and it's just
it's a very tough position for Hikaru
you have to be careful you do and I
think they might be repeating moves if
white in fact plays Rook A1 at that
point Hikaru is pretty hamstrung he has
to repeat with Rook p8 will raunak play
something sharper A6 here would be a
blunder not because of promotion because
white would win the bishop because if
Bishop two B6 deflecting White's Bishop
by force don't do that I think groundnut
should repeat moves here I I don't see a
need for him to be Brazen maybe bishop
C1 is is a is a more prudent winning
attempt that Hikaru would definitely
play if you were white that would be a
gutsy gutsy move by the Indian
Grandmaster
yeah Hikaru I think knows that if
Roundup plays oh he goes for it he does
it
love to see it
ikaru is uh frustrated not sure what
he's calculated there but uh very
emotive player as we as we know and love
but he's uh he's in a tough spot because
if he pushes this too hard he could lose
and that would definitely crush his
chances of making division one there's
probably still some awkward outside
chances of making it if you draw at six
and a half I don't know if that'll be
enough out of nine but uh but it's
already getting down to the wire here
fantastic move by hikar so hard to see
strikes on the other side now he's not
attacking with the punts he's making
space for his Bishop trying to smoke
White's Bishop out of C1 that might have
actually been the only way for black to
stay alive
that's actually and oh
huge what does white do on that Ace we
should take Bishop Q5 Rook A1 I think
but we might get a liquidation there in
a drawn Rook end game potentially well
if you play King E2 Bishop G5 you're too
slow you can always play Rook A1 I guess
if you're around like you can protect
with the Rook so oh yep
Rook A1 is forced I think don't take the
bishop because then you can't stop the
pawn and promote your Pawn in time
and he plays forced
it doesn't feel to me like white is
risking here Danny but it's a Hikaru
game we know anything can happen
no I think you're right I think it's
getting closer to a driving hikara will
have to settle on Rook A8 and we will
ultimately see a trade yeah he goes for
a trade of the a for C pawn and that is
what you have in store
Bishop takes G5 black it even no but I
can't take on A6 because the bishop
still controls the promotion Square
if I had to bet I'm not a betting man
but I think this one's going to end
peacefully probably to the Chagrin of
both players because the draw
might not be sufficient for either
but it's tough all around for some of
the biggest names let's let's let this
one Peter out to a draw Liam lay might
actually be taking down all the resign
let's go there
he's up two minutes to 30 seconds on the
clock and better to go with it Liam lay
is pushing an advantage on the queen
side here with that pass V Pawn
I will interject briefly and say that
gukash is still very much in control
against amsavian that's our other big
game but let's quickly unpack this end
game how significant are White's winning
chances it looks completely winning
Danny but it's not that Knight on B2 is
actually very well placed it's pretty
unassailable it's supporting the pawn
and the situation on the other side of
the board is pretty symmetrical perhaps
Lim could try creating a second pass
Pawn but that's kind of risky in its own
right here he goes pushing his ships
into the center of the table
Liam placed 95 what how do you meet A3
though are you are you just popping the
pony back to guard A2 like what was the
point how do you or pop the tower back
to C3 okay Rook C3 now the Knight on D5
guarding B6 C7 stopping it from behind I
think verusia should push and then drop
his own pony back to C4 I think that
might liquidate both passers and then
black and breathe a little bit more
peacefully there that might be the only
way to draw actually A2 Rook A7 Knight
C4 we trade a two for B yeah he finds it
A2 for B6 and we're gonna get peace and
Rook B2 there there's a rocket Knight D7
only move defending the Riff and
BlackRock was on B7 here Rook B2 would
win the game that's always the
difference and how narrow it is between
a win and a draw at this level
we almost completed each other's exact
same sentence there but yeah Rook B2
would win was on B7 but okay gonna be
another draw here
um
let's watch the end of the cash game but
please continue okay no no I was I was
trying to check uh by the way Fabiano
did hold that draw against John Napoli
amazing so so he doesn't give an inch
going to the gukesh game versus Sam
sevian we have really winning the young
man who started this event with a loss
was it was it round one that he lost or
around anyway
has won six of seven games I forget
whether it's six in a row or not he
might be about to make it seven of eight
and damaraju gukesh is like uh the
legend lives on the Olympiad called they
want their record performance back
gukesh is uh oh he will be the yeah look
at it oh crushing it through two two
pass Pawns he is cooking with some fish
oil here B6 and 92 check it looks scary
but white can take and drop his Rook
back then Sam will go D4 there's still
some off chances here I think he should
try it but he's one tempo shy if I've
got my calculation on and he is B7 and
white promotes first he's gonna go D2
but Queen takes h8 comes with check
which that's it Rook A6
ain't nobody got time for that
ain't nobody got time for that gookesh
seven of eight you can pretty much clip
and ship it he is the first one who has
punched his ticket into into division
one I'm not saying others probably
haven't with tie Breakers but I went to
the school for kids who don't do math
good and I'm not going to do that but if
you cash he will be dancing in match
play for division one for sure
he will indeed what an incredible
performance I mean he just gets so hot
when he's on form and he did that in the
Olympiad he's doing it again here and
here's a refutation Danny of the idea
that you can't play regularly online and
succeed in a tournament like this he's
doing it that's true and yeah he got
crushed by Magnus in the SEC but Magnus
is Magnus and he will meet him again in
the anxious Masters pretty soon Vladimir
kramnik he's not out of contention he's
got to win this four on three against
dubov and White's Pawn structure is
ideal I don't oh I don't think it's
happening now for sure
but remember just because you just
because gukesh is making the plan
doesn't mean he's going up against
Magnus or Wesley just yet right we have
12 players playing in match play right
after this so don't go anywhere everyone
we still got a lot of Chess ahead
don't worry I'm jumping the gun he's the
first into division one but he still
needs to make his way into the top six
he needs to win a match
um in division one he will get to choose
his opponent most likely but we will get
to that
and it looks like
the game between roundock and Hikaru
ended in
excuse me
Daniel dubov
and Vladimir kronik also still throw him
down in this round
if we want to check out that one yep
I've got it pulled up here kramnik has a
four on three the Bishops have been
traded off obviously this is a draw from
a theoretical standpoint but how many
times have we seen players lose control
in time pressure G5 here is a very
dangerous attempt Vladimir kramnik knows
all the tricks Danny and he's known them
since the 1970s the guy has played well
I always joke with these end games in
his life he's sorry he's been around the
block that's what you're trying to say
all right be kind yeah Vladimir chromic
has been around the back there yeah uh
he's uh you know um whoa he goes for
mate with King H3 and the King puts his
running shoes on but you might have to
actually not like his running shoes back
off I was gonna say it wasn't even the
best way to do it now he loses E4 with
check and it was like oh I was just
kidding I was just kidding literal okay
nature okay very nice what we have here
what we have here is round nine around
the corner
um
okay do not forget Daniel the tournament
may be over but we don't know who's won
until the last person has finished the
last game
tournament may be ending at the party is
only beginning stick around not just for
the last round but of course for match
play to determine the six players who
are making their way
to the aim chest Masters joining Wesley
and Magnus Fabi and gukesh I was going
to say this is it's fine with a draw
it's Fabby though Danny I don't think
Fabi is because I don't think that six
and a half is guaranteed you're really
throwing up the tie breaks here right I
mean as as we look at the standings
there's
there's so many people with the
potential to end on six and a half right
now the list of five and a half out of
eight players is so long you can't even
see the end of it on on this people
people whose names we have not mentioned
all day Ralph
blue Baum around Oxford Ronnie Masonic I
mean freaking Pablo pencaranov
everybody's on five and a half and their
tie breaks might not be that bad so
most likely your tie breaks are going to
be better if you've been at a higher
place in the tournament throughout but
that's not guaranteed and Fabi should at
least try in this game
100 a few people with six and a half
will likely get in
um but many people in five and a half
know very well what they're up against
and that this is must win territory for
them uh one of those one of those people
of course being Hikaru Nakamura who in
this round is going up against an
against a world Blitz champion in Lamb
Lane
Mukesh is establishing himself I think
as one of the top regosan experts in the
modern day he plays this opening almost
exclusively he played it against Magnus
Carlson in Tara and he held the world
champion with you know room to spare
um so gukesh just not afraid to play the
same opening he knows it backwards and
forwards I think he's got a pretty nice
position once again probably gonna push
C5 and get some action going on the
queen side and he does
yeah Favi would love to get a win here
and just throw everything into mass
chaos look at this we've already have
two had two draws Danny sorry to catch
off farooza nepo on draken and Eric icy
hello Arjun erogici on six and a half
out of nine all of them
so five spots essentially have already
been reserved at least wow
well they're reserved right now I mean
but there's so many people who could win
and get to six and a half what happens
to the tie breaks if that should occur
right I mean
it's obviously a a safe bet to a degree
from a from a score perspective six and
a half is going to get in for some
people but not everybody and and you're
really throwing it up to the tie break
you know me I get nervous in that mode
someone is going to be heartbroken on
the outside looking in at the end of
this for sure no question about it
Hikaru one of the big group at five and
a half he's in the Mustang territory but
he usually has good tie breaks as we're
used to him being at the top of the
Cross table not so this time he's he had
that early loss uh to Shang Yu who ended
up falling off a little bit that's going
to hurt hikaru's tie breaks because it
is I think the sum of the points that
your opponents score so right now the
job Danny for the players with five and
a half is to win they're not thinking
about the tie breaks they will cross
that bridge if they get there first they
need to get there
what a bleep show this is going to be
and I love every minute of it me too I I
don't know whether to focus on this game
here where carwana could could just turn
the tables on the standings or if we
should pop over to some of the players
who are probably in must win territory I
feel like we should probably do that
um I mean this is this is a game that's
going to be spicy I think Bobby's
showing like hey I'm not just going to
take a draw and and throw my hat into
the six and a half out of nine ring
where none of us know what's going to
happen with tie breaks so Bobby's gonna
push we'll keep our eye on it but where
else can we go the only other player who
can guarantee uh a a spot in the top 12
if he wins is like Wong Lim so let's
maybe briefly check into his game I
don't actually know who he's playing
let's find out I'm gonna click into his
game
oh who is this yeah that's what I was
saying it was icaro takaro uh versus uh
it's a good one brutal pairing for
Hikaru on five and a half in the last
round just brutal
yeah this is not a fun one to be right
if if uh if
Liam lay wins then he gets seven and
he's for sure in like you said but he's
playing Black against Hikaru so would
you rather who do you want to be here
right you're black you know you're going
up against a guy with the white pieces
who has to win he has no choice you
could get a draw in theory and roll the
dice on tie breaks if you're lamb late
but that's not that's not an opponent
that either of these guys won most
likely I think like Wong would get in
he's been Atop The crosstable but as
you're saying it's far from guaranteed
and we've seen many cases particularly
on the RCC where a player takes a draw
they're positive they're gonna get good
tie breaks you just can't know that for
certain things turn in the final round
and you just can't depend on your
opponents achieving a certain result
right then it's out of your control so
like Wong is just playing chess and I
think he'll try to seize his
opportunities if he gets them I actually
like Black's position here the structure
is pretty symmetrical Hikaru is trying
to spice things up and add some Sriracha
to the position by getting his Knight to
D6 and like Huang I think is about to
say over my dead body but how is he
going to stop that maneuver Danny
why is it sriracha and not Cholula or
Tapatio like why are you gonna do that
like why are we discriminating against
different types of everyone's favorite
way to spice up a position I'm not a
truly I I don't Tapatio is good with
certain things I think Sriracha is the
most universal hot sauce to me I can put
it on absolutely anything I think
Cholula would have a pretty a pretty big
argument to say against that okay
um
wow this just got this is a great
population too okay well Sriracha is
also I mean I'm a big I make I make some
some Mad Hot Wings Sriracha honey
Madness it's a it's a sauce you're like
oh hot wings with Sriracha yes one of my
specialties next time you come over I'm
cooking them up for you so I'm not
against Sriracha I just felt like that
was a big leap to make that's all I'm
saying
get the skillet ready I'm taking you up
on that I love me some hot wings and
Hikaru loves him some hot D6 Square he's
gearing up to go Knight C4 he wants to
do it the right moment
and he wants that Bishop there right why
is getting the Knight to D6 dangerous
because you get the bishop pair the
board is pretty open so the bishop pair
is rather desirable here
if you got to be careful right because
black also has the D5 Square depending
on how quickly you pop a pony into C4
black can respond by maybe putting a
knight on D5 but white white has one of
those microscopic poles why can be
patient you can play Bishop of one put
the a rook on C1 take your time before
you play Knight C4 and I don't see as
many improving moves for black here
Dania show me tell me tell me what I
mean you're right I know you know I mean
it's clear because of the time that like
long is spending
I'm thinking about how to reshuffle if
you play Knight D5 and as he goes Bishop
E7 which I was going to propose Bishop
E7 or Bishop f8 clearing the parking
spot for his Knight but that is also
hard to achieve because the B6 Pawn is
going to hang but there are some tactics
in the air there Danny if I can show
this really quickly this might be what
new car is calculating Knight C4 Knight
C5 might be possible Queen B6 Rook C6
Queen starts feeling short on moves
Queen A5 Knight B3 but I think white can
get away with Queen B4 and you say ah
discovered check anywhere the Knight
moves you drop the bishop so I think
Hikaru will calculate this he'll take
his time but I don't see him rejecting
Knight C4 I think he's gonna go straight
for the complications here that is the
best way of guaranteeing winning chances
let's go back I love that board what a
fantastic line I love that nice C4
Knight C5 you take B6 laughing in the
face of danger he is the Simba of this
Lion King movie they say he is his own
Simba well Hikaru he hasn't done too
much laughing this tournament he's had a
pretty rough go of it and the standards
we hold him to are so high I mean five
and a half out of eight is the score a
lot of players would kill for this
tournament Danny but that early loss it
really set him back he's still in
contention which is crazy because he was
losing to dream about if he could have
been totally out of the tournament so
he's kept himself in but wasn't able to
win that game in the last round with
black and now even with a win might not
be making it into the final 12 but oh
boy will those in division two feel
sorry if they have to face an angry
Hikaru Nakamura for sure and it would be
the one thing normally we'd be focused
on division one solely but if you've got
an angry Hikaru making his way through
there there may be some we have to check
in on by the way uh speaking of things
we need to check in on Fabiano caruana
uh is is pushing against gukesh like
this is not
he's not just gonna just gonna say that
I'm like I said he's not rolling the
dice on the six and a half tiebreakers I
think it's a very smart move
um and I've been critical of of people
earlier today and then and in previous
events when we've done rapid chess
championships which had a similar kind
of Swiss day and then a match knockout
day
um I don't think it's good to uh to
leave yourself as a victim to the
universal tie break system and I like
what fobby's doing
yeah for Russia and right now I should
remind everybody this was a point of
confusion for some in the RCC you should
take the tie breaks you see on the left
side with a grain of salt because they
will update after the final round they
will change after the final and you
might say well all right can they really
change that much yes they can we have
seen some crazy reshuffling the top tie
break could become the lowest Ty break
so early as a ferocia isn't sitting and
chilling you know sipping his
Frappuccino and saying you know I'm in
division one he is watching nervously
for the final Tournament standings okay
so H4 the last move by Fabi he is trying
to drive that pawn down use it as a
battering ram and crack open lacks
incredibly vulnerable kingside pawns
construction I love every bit of what
fabiuano is doing here Ariana
yeah exactly
um all right F5 played by gookesh feels
like that's
well it kind of works out here it's
definitely a move you don't take lightly
because uh pawns don't move backwards
don't you Pro tip and that's a big
commitment to your entire kingside
structure
I have something crazier to tell you I'd
like to thank our amazing team working
hard to provide all the facts School
cash actually did not lose in early game
I think everybody and their brother was
under that impression he actually he
threw two games against Yan and Reza not
the worst people to draw against but he
was just a little bit below the top guys
Danny for most of the tournament and so
we didn't have our eyes on him until the
last round but ukasha's not lost a game
yet shades of his Olympiad performance
honestly but right now he's in big
danger Bobby has a big decision to make
though he can take the Knight with his
Bishop tempting but you give up the
light squares or you can keep the
tension of Bishop F3 and really try to
sneak in H5
okay fun fact good good to be corrected
by the team thank you for that if you're
gonna draw two guys young the Palm
machine only Reza farugia are probably
two of the best guys to draw so there
you go gukesh really has had the best
Tournament of all he is the uh the bell
of the ball so far and uh will he finish
that way or will Fabiano you know make
that pumpkin make that pumpkin go Splat
at midnight huh how's that for a
reference completed full circle
make the pumpkin go Splat at midnight at
least tell me is it a movie or is it a
song
you're kidding oh have I oh God what did
I just do oh God is that one of those
limp Limp Biscuit moments again where
Chad is just gonna explode it's like
when you stub your toe and you know the
pain is coming but there's that one
delicious second where you don't feel
the pain yet that's what happens when I
look at this hasn't exploded yet
you don't know what a a pumpkin like at
midnight is referring to
is it a horror movie like Halloween
because I'm a horror fan that would be
particularly embarrassing
now you got to tell me the chat's
probably gonna scream it so
we're gonna wait we're gonna wait for
we're gonna let Chad handle this one
because I got some chess to focus on
what have I done so Fabiano bring in the
pressure hitting G6 maybe H5 comes I
like that move Rook B1 he's playing both
sides of the board here poking on the B5
Pawn poking on G6 I know you're waiting
for Chad to say like Dania are you
kidding me I'm kid I'm keeping my eyes
nervously on chat
you know the turbulence is about to
begin we also should probably check into
hikaru's game at some point but just to
complete the picture here Danny
Fabby is in control of this game he's
calling the shots but will he be able to
actually deliver
yeah we're gonna we're gonna find out
but Hikaru is on his way to delivering
something you talk about a three result
position over there against uh Liam lay
but um it's one that Hikaru looks like
he's uncontrollable but with everything
what is going on he's down the exchange
the queen is saying and it's black to
move
but 97 check is coming and A8 is saying
and see it at 75 isn't before saying
black you're the the last movie played
was Queen takes Knight on D2 oh my God
the last sequence 95 Bishop before what
he plays Bishop before because the
Knight on D5 was pinned to the maid on
G2 but the queen takes D2 and lamlay
forgot that the bishop had to guard E7
he just blundered it actually in
hindsight it was just a blunder it was a
blunder and here's the thing let me
spell out what's likely to happen if you
take the Knight that's out of the
question because Hikaru wins more
material I think like Huang has to bite
the bullet here take the queen I'm gonna
just show yeah the likeli line take the
queen it's not actually that hard to
follow the rest of the line black has to
take the Knight back and actually
there's worse things waiting for black
on the other side of the end game Danny
he's down upon a B white could bring the
rook in white has this move to trade off
the Bishops I think Hikaru is going to
finish this one off and he at least is
gonna give himself a chance this is
incredible tactical eye by Hikaru who
has withstood his subpar form and again
has given himself a Fighting Chance
based on the tie breaks to make his win
on top 12. Blown Away plus especially
because of how we got here well we have
the big board up let's show it again
that Bishop B4 was played to guard the
Knight on D2 uh you back up Cinderella
run here yep yeah on a real Bippity
Boppity Boo um since you know your
references Queen takes D2 exposed the
bishop on B4 for being overloaded just
like it's an easy blender to make
because who sees that coming uh we can
see on the live board the exact line
Donya pointed out a few moments ago and
uh Hikaru is going to be playing for a
win in this end game he is and I think
he's going to deliver
beautiful tactics go to waste sorry I
didn't hear I was looking for my lost
slipper
thank you
I'm telling you I know the story of
Cinderella I just didn't get that
particular reference within the story
dude you got the when the clock strikes
12 at midnight right and then that I
know
the pumpkin
that I don't know right I'm just rusty
on my fairy tales okay all right I I did
enough commentating with Danny wrench
we'll set the record straight don't
worry it'll right the ship all right oh
look at this Rook D1 it's even worse
than we thought it look is coming to d8
to win the bishop oh the game might be
over Danny it just oh look at this
bishop A5 44. Bishop A5 A5 Bishop C7
Bishop Texas
Bishop F1 in the end this is like igar's
pieces are always on the perfect squares
like Wong has to play Rook C1 or Rook C2
and A6 hangs no I think Hikaru could win
a piece here if you well let's okay I
might not have been the best move
that's still pretty good let's back up
and show what would have happened on
Bishop A5 real quick Donya yeah
third Mouse up of the day before now
I'll just point out Danny anytime you
take and in the end Rook C1 is not made
because white covers Bishop B6 A5 Bishop
C7 takes C7
and it's only a matter
of time and as you said it's never made
for white in the end because the which
the bishop goes back to F1 so
there you go well back to that was the
reason
La Quang Liam had to play Rook C2 Hikaru
played Bishop E5 but
Black's position is hanging by a thread
but Hikaru better put it away because
you got to get a win there's no like oh
this slipped and I gotta draw that you
feel good about this is a win or
literally go home or in this case the
division two if you're Nakamura so
yeah he has to be perfect here
he takes that second Pawn he is now up
two pawns both of them on the queen side
connected passers and what stands
between him and the win here is just the
activity of Black's pieces if he can
force a rook trade or Force One of the
Bishops out of their spots he'll win on
the spot but it's actually not that easy
to do and that is why like Huang put his
Bishop on e4 to prevent the move Bishop
D3 again hanging by a thread yes we've
seen Hikaru pull these types of games
out but he usually doesn't let them slip
if he's on The Winning Side
agreed agreed it's not something he does
every day I'm looking over at that car
want to go cash game
um and that's also getting spicy I don't
know where to go I think we're we can
sit right here obviously we know nothing
has to win
we do we do let's watch a couple more
moves and then go go to the carwana game
let's let's see Hikaru kind of wheel his
way out of a slightly awkward spot here
with the bottom before hanging Danny and
if you played B5 The Bishop's connection
with F1 drops and black can actually go
Bishop to C2 so work left to be done
here for Mr Nakamura maybe it's time to
make some Lofts but then you give up one
of your Pawns
yeah you're probably winning maybe maybe
not I mean giving up that pawn is no fun
and as you pointed out your Bishop on A6
is super key to defending that back rank
you can't cut off your own scope with B5
due to what you said show that line real
quick just to B5 Bishop C2 you take D2
and uh Bippity Boppity Boo oh put it
together what do you got won't let me
jump over the bike
put it together and whatever you got
a Checkmate on the back rank too oh baby
okay let's go back all right so this is
this is not an option for white and
otherwise how oh he plays Bishop F1 he
does decide to give up the pawn he's
gonna put the Rook behind the eight Pawn
with okay one more he's gonna Force the
trade with Rook D4 and go into the
bishop end game
and if you had opposite colored Bishops
here it would be a dead draw with same
colored Bishops you can essentially
ensure the continued progress of the
pawn because any time that pawn is
stopped by the bishop Danny its
counterpart can move to that same
diagonal these positions are usually
pretty straightforward wins but yeah
he's just got a little bit of technique
left to show he car is going to win this
one I really don't have any doubt bring
the king in Easy clap I think for for
Nakamura that pawn is also not
accessible to the black king and it can
move to A6 when he wants it to no rush
bringing the king up first is what I
would do king E3 Bishop C4 Etc then play
A6 when you're ready
well if that's what Daniel noradiski
would do
and that's what I would say you should
do
a lot of sriracha on the karwana cash
game by the way I think you Cara's got
this in the bag Danny I think we can
safely move on
you think so I don't know
at this point the bishop can also come
to the diagonal with Bishop D3 Bishop E4
and even if you trade Bishops and the
king gets the a pawn you just win the
king of Pawn ending so yeah I think
Hikaru is going to get it of course I'll
say this it's like when you wait for the
elevator and then take the stairs but if
something happens we promise to fly
right over to this game Who cashes in a
major major hole on the clock though
let's go there let's do it the car was
playing the Right Moves there he's got
this in the bag Fabiano caruana is close
to finishing go cash off but he's
holding on 15 seconds in a sharp
position Danny oh this is stressful
yeah and the black king has also been
blown open we missed how it actually
came to fruition but ultimately where we
left it is what happened Fabi did drive
that pawn to H5 pry open the G pawn and
now he's trying to get surgical up
against that King on the H file but
where's The Knockout blow this game is
much more important for Fabi than it is
for kukesh kukesh essentially has I mean
Fabi will catch catch up to him if he
wins who catches tie break still might
be better so he's guaranteed either top
or second place in division one if Bobby
draws he might not make it at all so the
stakes are huge where's the win Rook B7
Danny there's always this move Rook C7
and dukesh he needs to keep this Pawn
alive because that is what keeps him
alive in this position
I start to look at ideas this is crazy I
know but things where you punch D5 is
white D5 no I was thinking of that too
yeah because if the queen takes it you
get the F6 square right and if the pawn
takes it you open up the six rank for
business and I don't see the follow-up
tactic that's the problem but Bobby is
taking his time for a reason here
everyone there's this could be a
critical moment and like Don you said
you can't let the fish off the hook
another great move by gukesh what
inventive defense there is the queen
occupies the corner and keeps the key
dark squares protected the queen trade
might be insufficient to win we sunk
fabi's Praises Danny in time scrambles
his Improvement in bullet we're about to
see whether Fabi 2.0 can make an
appearance he might have already
frittered away his objective advantage
on the board but he has to keep the
Queens on the board who cash might be
playing for a win here whoa It's that
last move I mean this is getting crazy
gukesh is ready to move on every
response car wanna has he's playing
instantly but he may end up blowing it
in the process we need
Queen E4 H7 was threatened mate queen of
five okay but now now The Rook ending is
uh
is awkwardly yes awkward as fobby it's
drawn objectively but I actually think
white does have a slight practical Edge
has to try to get rid of White's past
pawns yeah there goes one
can he get to eight two
oh Rook G7 check there would have set
the king back by the way he doesn't play
it
this also works in what Rook G7 now you
also have D5
but King H6 in response to Rook C1
forces that Rook off the seventh rank
dude is there like a rook C1 Rook H1
made here by the way it doesn't work but
I just gotta point it out no that's what
I'm saying yeah Rook C1 King H6 I think
was the only move well Fabi just got
unlucky there with the tactics but let's
keep yeah watching
you have King B3 and then Rook C3
threatening made on H3
has one by the way so
we made a good call here can Fabi
squeeze a win out of this I don't think
so
well if he wins he probably ends up
taking first on tie breaks tying Rakesh
with the score
of seven out of nine
but all right your cash is simplifying
it out I think that was a very nice move
F3 actually I don't know no I mean in a
Time scramble that could I mean probably
objectively it's correct he keeps his
King active I guess he is because if I
just can make no progress and Bobby
shouldn't lose right he shouldn't get
wild here because six and a half gives
him a chance and we know he's got good
tie breaks yep
game is not over go cash is going to win
F3 you were right F4 was an excellent
call Cash was in a fantastic form Abby
not giving up chances he's gonna move
two seconds
one second
okay don't go King C2 and get mated oh
my gosh would that have been The Rook T3
Rook D3 it's gonna be a draw
a for f
still not over King takes up wait a rook
B5 okay I thought there was a I thought
there was a rook B3
no this is a draw Fabio will get behind
the pawn but go cash will sack his Rook
for them well not yet why is he what is
he doing too early too early get a loose
or is he no no
that was in the move
what was the move
not yet I don't know what the move was
let's take a look
um
it was Rook F5 you forced King G4
because then the king isn't ideal then
when you go to f8 and on F3 King B2 this
is the human move I think oh you're you
buy it yeah how is this yeah you buy a
temple
I did not find that I just quickly broke
the cardinal sin I didn't even try I
just turned on the engine your Rook F5
Rook F5 for that's a fascinatingly
instructive point you force the king to
G4 show it don't you yeah five because
without it black pushes the pawn
straight away yeah and then you go band
down and now you gain a Tempo F3 King
Beach this is where this is where you
gain that Tempo because the King has to
burn another move yep and then that
gives E2 in time just enough time Bobby
just kind of assumed that was a drawn if
he doesn't make it Danny he will be
kicking himself for a while although he
will have a chance to make it to the
next tournament but man oh man was that
a potentially big moment
it looks like no one we might have our
my word is someone getting in at six
Liam lay is in 12th Place with six out
of nine no there are others who can
still pass wow we've got a game going on
with Sam sevy and we got to go check out
who still has the chance
um to get with six and a half oh no he
just lost oh you lost it Daniel do
rocked off
dubov takes the 12th spot robs Liam lay
no no he was already done yet and we
should wait for the tie breaks I think
to update because they might reshuffle
the final standing so there is one game
going Danny I'm gonna flip it on just
because it's the last game and that's
what stands between us and the final
Tournament standings it's a rook and
Bishop versus Rook they're not letting
us go just yet
the uh the mate the okay let's just
place bets draw or win draw or win I I
vote white wins white fund's a way to
win this I think it's a draw I think
black's got just enough time here even
though it is a win I think objectively
with the king in the back rank
it's Ori Kobo Israeli Grand Master
trying to defend this with black
not sure who DJ howby is
well I'm just like
oh that fascinated by how that finished
there what an instructor Brooke ending
we saw there even though Fabi missed the
the way to win that was still
really interesting to see in real time
and
I'm also I think I'm most Blown Away by
the fact that hikara managed to come
back and make the make the division one
that was
it didn't seem destined to be his day
that Fabby moment was crazy though that
reminds me of some videos you see of
premature celebrations and sports right
where one side celebrates and the other
side hits a full court shot gukesh
taking that pawn it was totally
unnecessary he could have let you're
gonna let that pawn reach A7 before
taking it but he yeah he already thought
it was in the bag and cash probably
doesn't realize how much he could have
impacted not his own chances he would
have still made it he would have been
okay it's Fabby who got a golden
opportunity to punch his ticket Casey
six by the way
no but now he makes it complicated again
King C6 was better first yeah one shot
comes and black is still alive there
should be me Rook C1 Bishop C5 it's
winning
yeah that's it
yeah
I would try Rook H1 here
but just to catch the mouse slip
okay okay I believe lightweight is mate
hello
all right there we go and now we have
the final standings
and Fabi makes it thankfully for him
Hikaru has made it
he's the one lucky guy who got six and
had amazing tie breaks oh my gosh
unbelievable I love to see it I started
doing the math and and saw that someone
six out of nine was gonna make it but I
thought it would be Liam lay La Quang
Liam
nope
but no my gosh Vladimir Crum make the
14th World chess champion is still
dancing boys and girls and he will be he
will be a nightmare for someone to play
in the next round to pick him that was
unbelievable Danny what a finish and
this is why we love the last round
yeah what a wild what a wild situation
we've got we've got three divisions that
we'll be going down in match play again
we will be focused on the top division
of 12 players obviously because we
really want to find out which of those
six will move on join Wesley so and
Magnus Carlson in next week's and next
week's main event for the air things
Masters but let's not forget that
if we look at the standings right now I
can't even remember the name so many of
those players have so much to play for
not just 10 grand for first in division
two and five grand in division three
respectively but of course an automatic
bid if you win division yes you end up
getting a better second event here in
the Champions chess store than a lot of
other players because you're
automatically in the KO stage so there
is so much so much ahead here I uh
I think we're getting pretty close to
knowing how they finish but we'll give
the team just a second we don't want to
go for a break until we know who has
punched their ticket into all three
divisions oh it's kramnik is kramnik out
it looks like the standings have been
updated oh no is he out there and it
might be in 13th he might have been
surpassed by Lim
I'm looking at I'm looking at our screen
I apologize if I spoke too soon I
assumed those were the final standings I
guess they're not
hey they're not updated yet
I was just so excited Danny I was so
excited I thought it was Liam Lee
originally too hey it's okay it's our
job to just keep going who knows I we're
not even gonna say it's not cram Nick
yet what I do want to clarify for
everyone the reason we're going to be
announcing the players and each division
that they've qualified for and not the
pairings before our break then we will
come back for match play is because one
of the really fun twists of this event
is that the top six actually get to
choose their opponents in the order of
which they finish so gookesh gets to
choose his opponent for those who finish
seven through twelfth now why is that
interesting well you know when you get
chosen Dania that someone picked you and
said hey I'm gonna beat you yeah that is
it officially we have the standings
Vladimir krumnik is in with the better
tie breaks over the Quang Liam oh yes oh
no oh yes
look at it look at it we've got go cash
Yonder Palm Mishi Ali Reza farusha I'm
not gonna read it word for word you see
the 12 players who have made it but most
importantly Dania the top six on the
left get to choose who they want to play
in the right yes my guess is no one is
going to choose to play Hikaru just
going to say it two things Danny first
of all just to make the broader point
and you can correct me for those people
who might be feeling a little antsy
about the format what division one
determines are the six players who join
Magnus and Wesley in the first major the
aim Chess Masters so we're gonna have
six individual matches composed of two
games and the six winners of those two
game matches are the six additional
players in the first major in division
two the winner it gets seated directly
into the next major but you gotta win
the tournament there's only one spot to
claim and for division three there are
tons of prizes and the winner of
division three gets automatically seeded
into division two in the next play in
Danny so the winner of division three
has a long road but everybody's got
something to fight for other than Rises
and that's what I love about this there
is no true consolation here everybody's
fighting ultimately for a spot in the
major some roads are longer than others
completely agree well said and obviously
I want to dive in at some point to the
storyline of the top six players and who
might they choose 7-12 but before we do
before we do we should take a look at
division two because now we officially
have the standings there uh which starts
there with gadir busierenov right there
at the top noterbeck yakuboa right there
again I'm not going to read the whole
list but you've got grishek again it's
it's also dead right there I was gonna
say it's a pretty scary List look at
number 27 prognananda NBD right Dura
Bailey finishing 31st division two has
so much to play for and of course as
Donya already said the winner of
division two automatically takes one of
the four spots that will be automatic
bids in the next major event again we
know the formats new you're going to
learn it you're gonna love it I promise
you because it's freaking awesome it's
freaking lit how did we find a combo
that has all the top players playing and
still rewards Grand Masters and by down
to the several hundreds we figured it
out and I think it's going to be quite
the year Donya and guess what I think we
have division three as well and I would
tell people I think we do as well we're
gonna confirm that people who are a
little bit confused about the format
that's okay you know we're gonna keep
talking about it and keep confirming it
so I would just ask that people be
patient with themselves I think it's in
a genius format that really strikes that
balance and yes it's going to be
complicated because we're trying to give
tons of players a chance but again just
listen carefully we're gonna keep
reaffirming the key parts of the format
what you need to know for today is that
we are going to be determining the six
players who get into the aim Chess
Masters and the one player who wins
division two who gets into the next
major so those are the things that we're
going to be really hitting on we are
confirming the players in division three
Danny it's so great that 76 players get
a Fighting Chance while we're waiting
for division three if we could bring
back division one I'd love to take a
look because to me one of the most fun
storylines were about to dive into as we
head to the break and come back and we
will find out who the players chose to
play but you are damaraji gukesh Dania
did you know that you're you're gukesh
who are you picking the first pick who
are you picking of those guys Malkovich
sequel being dumb Raju Kesh oh gosh
this is the problem righty car Nakamura
is number eight that is like facing the
Golden State Warriors probably going to
be the eighth seed in round one of the
playoffs
you know what I know this sounds crazy
but of 7 through 12 I feel like Vladimir
kramnik might be Lucas's choice and it's
one of those it's not like getting two
chosen last Danny in you know Middle
School sports game it's just because
everybody's a beast you're choosing
perhaps the Lesser evil
Excuse me yes and he also beat kramnik
in the Swiss plan for those who just
joined so maybe he he decides to go back
to that well but all right we can
continue to speculate instead we're
going to go over and take a look at who
finished in the 33rd Place all the way
down to 76. it starts with Bortnick a
very well-known household name
especially when it comes to Bullet but
then you start circling names that just
pop out of honoronian in 39th place
right Robson in 46th uh the the FFL the
famous bleeping Legend in 59th place I
don't even know Chomsky was in the
tournament and you've got Christian it
was gorilla over there Mr Irrelevant
Christian carrilla at 76th
wow svidler in 70th I mean just an un
this is division three talk about The
Walking Dead I mean these players are
going to be at each other's throats for
that coveted ticket to division two and
more spots in division two Danny will be
taken up by those who lose in division
one so the six losers are not out
entirely they get big prizes and they
get an automatic ticket to division two
in the next plan so they've guaranteed
themselves a pretty cushy spot who can
actually make it into the first major
that's the big question
oh you said it you said it well we've uh
we've got so much ahead so many names
there a bit of Gujarati in 50 first
place but I mean we could just continue
to go down the list but we are going to
mainly be focused of course as we said
on the players who finish in the top 12
because those Patrol players are
battling for six spots who will join
Magnus Carlson and Wesley so as The
Knockout begins on February 6th we're
gonna find out but not until we take a
very very quick break because we're all
exhausted the players are exhausted get
up now grab a snack or sit right there
and watch whatever awesome content we're
bringing you with a break because the
air things play and Masters has moved to
match play when we return
chess kit is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
kids it feels just like playing the
chest is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
fifty thousand chest puzzles and a whole
library of entertaining videos that
teach strategies tactics openings and
end games specifically for kids
chess kit is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
what's up everybody Danny here with
chess.com officially bringing on air
things as a sponsor for the 2023
Champions chess store the air things
Masters is coming your way and I'm here
to unbox and add some air things Tech to
my studio here I've got the air things
view Plus in front of me right now the
most advanced air quality check improve
overall health sleep and comfort I mean
who doesn't want all of those things to
be improved I I believe I do but okay
this is where I normally start just like
breaking things when I unbox things at
home because I
with any of my unboxing we better get it
in one take because I'm just gonna rip
it I'm officially I'm like a kid on
Christmas what's inside here we go so
we're opening the air things
everything's box pretty cool stuff and
uh inside the air things tackled which
we really are going to set up here at
chess.com Studios uh we have
we have uh the air things Tech that's
going to read for us our air quality and
uh and keep us keep us going
um we've got some Chargers obviously you
need that you need Chargers to make your
stuff work it's pretty simple and well
we've even got some sticky things which
they they know that you might struggle
hanging things on a wall and so they
give it to you so you can just do right
and then you do that thing where you
stick around the wall I love people who
are thinking ahead on that because I can
never find a stud right I mean you know
you got to be a stud to find a stud and
I am not a stud we we all know that okay
well there we go we've got an empty box
after that very well packaged very neat
not an unnecessary waste of cardboard I
will appreciate that for the environment
and give them a shout out so pretty
simple stuff we open it oh we're gonna
we're gonna download the app we'll do
that in a second first thing I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna do what it says which is
Rip open the tag and it says to pull up
the air things app which I'm going to do
in a second and we're going to test the
air the air hand waiver quality in just
a moment it's already blinking it's
going to come on it's it's act that's
fascinating oh my gosh that literally
happened in real time it says breathe
better live better I'm fascinated and
frightened all at the same time I can
add a device and I'm gonna plug it in
getting started with my view plus
placement we recommend that you place
your view Plus in an area where you
spend the majority of your time well
that's right here in the studio okay
continuing
calibration know that it may take up to
seven days to fully calibrate makes
sense I I'm tldring this yep uh the
radon the radar will fluctuate
throughout the day week month okay makes
sense I'm not judging you you don't even
need to explain all this to me I'd like
to be educated though the Hub is on
anytime you want to know the air quality
you just wave your hand in front of it
it's like a magical air Genie watch this
doing it what I flash a lot and then it
absolutely tells me the air quality in
the room yeah I've got pretty good 1272
I'm gonna learn how to read this if you
don't think that air quality is
important you know that human beings
will spend 90 percent of their life
inside I read that fact from Air things
and first of all I was frightened
because what are we doing why are we not
outside more that's a different
conversation to have but ninety percent
of our life seems like a lot of time to
care about the air quality in our rooms
also how much time do chess players
spend inside if the average human spends
90 percent of their time inside how much
time are we spending as chess players I
don't have a fact check on that but I'm
going to look into it and I'm going to
assume that air things make sense as a
sponsor for our chess event because we
want to know that we're breathing high
quality air especially because fun fact
the ideal carbon dioxide levels will
increase your cognitive function by more
than a hundred percent 101 percent in
cognitive ability Improvement that's
fascinating stat also a 288 percent
increase in strategic thinking with
right with the right air qualities 299
increase in information usage abilities
first of all I don't even know what that
means because I probably don't have good
enough air quality to consume that
information and regurgitate it for you
but I'm going to say it again a 299
increase in information usage abilities
when you have the right air qualities
the right carbon dioxide levels in your
room well actually looks like all this
talking I'm doing this is a fun fact is
increasing the carbon dioxide in the
room we went from 1270 due to 13 1965
that's because I talked so fast that I'm
decreasing the amount of oxygen in the
room and increasing the amount of carbon
dioxide that's a special ability that I
have I don't know what special abilities
you have but that's the special ability
I have anyway so shout out to air things
shout out to chess players spending way
too much time inside and shout out to
knowledge of good air quality hope
you're enjoying the show on chess.com
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things
we are back the day continues to roll on
International Master Danny Ranch Grand
Master Daniel noraditsky we have moved
past the Swiss portion of the air things
Masters playing stage into match play
Donya I know you're tired but you're not
that tired we're pretty excited about
what we have in store
hey I didn't even need coffee today
Danny and that I mean something really
big has to happen to replace my daily
dosage of caffeine and something big has
happened something big is about to
happen something big even bigger is
gonna happen as we enter the matchstage
Annie I could not be more excited for
the next stage of this epic event you
and I could sit here and unpack what we
just saw over the last several hours the
amazing comebacks the wild finishes but
there's nothing else really to talk
about at this point besides what's at
stake in the match play portion so let's
dive in and remind everybody of what's
ahead 54 players are about to secure
their spots in the air things Masters
three divisions coming up six spots will
advance to division one they of course
will join Magnus Carlson and Wesley so
16 spots will advance the division two
of the air things Masters 32 spots
advancing to division 3 and 10 players
will be eliminated and have to rejoin
the play in in the following event
reminder
235 thousand dollars are at stake if you
make it to the February 6th through 10th
schedule where The Knockout begins so
you really want to make it Donya
you most certainly do a couple of
clarifications Danny as we look at this
very informative slide those six spots
that's what the fuss is about those six
players are the ones who will be joining
Magnus Carlson and Wesley so who already
have their tickets by invites so that
will make a total of eight players in
the top group those who lose Danny in
division one the six losers they drop
down they still qualify for division two
same process those who lose in division
two make it to division three so and
only 10 players those who actually lose
in division three only they are pushed
out of the aim chest of the air things
Masters
well said and and so again it is as we
said a new format you're learning but
it's pretty simple if you win you win
prizes and you move up if you lose you
still have a great chance unless you
lose in the bottom of division and don't
forget what's at stake if you win the
whole thing come February 10th is a
direct spot into the championship which
has five hundred thousand dollars in
prizes so quick reminder that's what
we're playing for here and who is still
left playing for it who are the 12
players who've made their way through
the gauntlet
not really recognizing any names here
Dan you're putting me in a pretty tough
spot I don't have anybody to talk about
I will Pat myself on the back
and you know why why guess who guess who
gukesh who came in first has chosen for
his opponent indeed the world champion
Vladimir kramnik will he regret his
choice We Are Gonna See I can't wait for
that game of course he called Nakamura
lower right he made it through Danny
with a clutch win in the last round and
he will be facing Daniel dubov with the
black pieces one of the most difficult
pairings in any tournament we've got
some juicy games to play foreign
it's crazy because obviously gukesh did
choose to play Vladimir kronwick the
14th World chess champion again if
you're just tuning in gukesh beat
chromic with the black pieces in the
Swiss play and so so Donya did predict
it and it kind of makes sense from that
perspective but also objectively you
could argue that Ralph momentov and
roundock sodwani were both you know I'm
using this very very lightly weaker
opponents Dr Evil quotation fingers just
in terms of rating and experience and so
through cash really going after his
thought that he plays faster chess he's
a younger player he's more accustomed to
the online format than chromic I I guess
um that's what he's saying is actually
going to be simuling
and Vladimir kremnik
oh I missed there was there was
something on screen I missed something
no I think I think we'll cash a Cash's
name is listed is listed twice but oh I
wasn't even noticing okay I'm focused
he's playing a simole that's what you do
that's the hidden twist I already know
who's missing there that name is gonna
be Alexi serrana but I already know who
was missing because I I saw the list and
knew that that was who it was so cash
said hey Alexi I'm gonna put you into
the finals let me simul these two
incredibly players playing kramnik is
not enough of a challenge let me take
Fabi with the black as well that is in
fact Alexi serrana who will be black
against Fabiano we're getting that
updated we're getting that updated right
now but while while we get the graphic
for division one fixed here everybody of
course let's highlight that the players
who made it into division two are no
slouches themselves
um as we said uh 16 of them will remain
and play in division two of course uh
the ones who drop will be in division
three but
um back to what I was saying because I
want to talk about the storyline if if
possible that gukesh chose kromnik Donya
and again Ralph momentov Roundup said
one technically lower rated players but
not people that gukesh wanted to throw
down against and I I think it's an
interesting choice I I know you called
it but I'm not totally sure I agree with
it you'll note that yonda pompeshi and
Ali reservaruja they both immediately
chose Ralph mametov and and sadwani
right so the two players that were
technically lower rated than than
Vladimir kromrick so interesting I was
opening my mouth to say that I mean you
can basically go several ways you can
choose the lowest rated player but if
you're familiar at all with how Alexi
serrana has played in the RCC then you
know that he's not necessarily the
wisest Choice Ralph momentov is one of
the trickiest grand Masters out there he
has defeated just about everybody in
Rapid play and In classical chess so
you're essentially choosing you know
between six incredibly difficult
opponents ukesh already defeated kramnik
Vladimir comparatively Danny is the
rustiest of the players so again I don't
think it's disrespect back from wukesh I
think he's in a tough spot and he's
making the wisest decision given his
options yeah okay well all right so
we're going to come back to division one
of course in a second we previewed for
you the players in division two let's
also remind everybody that there's a
who's whose list of uh of a ton of very
very good chess players
um also competing in divisions for you
we we noted a few of the notable names
Donya before we went to break I'm going
to ask you to do the uh the fun thing
tell me who finishes on top of division
three at the end of today you got a big
list there I feel like the clock the
Final Jeopardy
if I had to choose one name and I do
have to choose one name I am going to
choose
give me 10 seconds to equate myself for
the full list
you know who I'm gonna choose
I'm gonna go with Ray Robson number 46.
I feel like Rey is just one of those
players who can step it up in any moment
he doesn't play a lot but
I mean he's just a beast I think he's
going to bring out his best opening prep
that's my prediction Danny
okay imagine if I'm right
you better be that better you better
earn me a bonus you're choosing one of a
lot of players so if you're right we
will throw you a bonus that's that's a
pretty that's a pretty bold pick I mean
it's just hard with the odds but I'm
gonna do the same thing and try to pick
and uh
you know
I'm gonna pick taymor rajaba
look at that are you now yeah
he played in this plan qualifier just
announcing team we're a job off got some
super GMS thrown in their Lovato ronian
we got legendary oh God again
we we're we're also we're also
overlooking some of the younger the
younger guns there you've got
Christopher you obviously a super
talented not not quite Ray Robson level
in terms of puzzle prowess but for those
who don't know Christopher you also one
of the absolute monsters I use that term
uh just completely intentionally an
absolute monster when it comes to uh
puzzles so oh that's uh
that's one to watch out for for sure by
the way who was leading anyway I mean we
could go on and on about this but let's
bring it back to what we started with
the chess board in its initial position
and of course Danny wrench on the bottom
of your screen that's all you need for a
happy life chessboard and Rich I'm not
sure about that other guy
we're gonna be getting going here in
just a second the game the games will
begin that's what it means when you see
a chessboard on screen and also here we
go this matches is starting yonda Palm
Desi Ralph momentov E4 on the board for
the Challenger to the World Chess
Championship title fasten your speed
belts ladies and gentlemen Ralph mom
Madoff is going to meet Yana pumnushy at
the top I love seeing I was gonna say he
is one of the only accelerated Dragon
proponents Danny at the top level and he
also plays the regular Dragon this is a
ridiculously bold choice and I'm gonna
make a bold prediction nepo likes the
line where he takes C6 and goes Bishop
H6 I've seen him play that let's see if
he essays that rare line here or if he
goes for the main e takes D5
well D5 is on the board for those who
don't know we'll go back to that game
here in just a second Donya if you can
the uh yes I can prime next game has
begun as well we'll go there in due
course yeah D5 is the main idea for
black in the dragon when you face the
nine castles long variation of the
Yugoslav attack for those who don't
speak this Theory Bishop to C4 is the
option for white that prevents D5 okay
he takes D5 on the board we're seeing
the main line where we'll go from here
Bishop to D4 okay indeed now interesting
theoretical update after E5 Bishop C5
the kind of Derek Gore forced move
what's Bishop B6 he plays it rookie
eight was Anish giri's recommendation in
his Dragon chess level course that made
waves I played rookie eight in the US
Championship didn't get a great position
Ralph going Old Reliable Danny black is
considered to be worse by modern Theory
but obviously we're talking about the
Sicilian Dragon here things can go
either way and I think Ralph is making a
bet that Jan is just rusty on his theory
this is not an OP opening which occurs
at the highest level anymore ever so
Ralph may be thinking that Jan is a
little bit Rusty in some of the weeds
and it doesn't appear at the highest
levels anymore ever I just want to leave
nothing nothing to the imagination there
it's because with all other things being
equal this line is basically a force win
for white I'm just going to say it and
that's someone who used to play the
dragon religiously is black like this is
not a fun time for black if white is
deeply prepared and ready to bring it
and that's why Don just making the point
that momentum is playing a line that is
while interesting in Blitz and a
practical shot objectively if white is
prepared and remembers their Theory this
is just a bad line for black that's the
truth and I really oh Bishop C4 though
uh Danny might be confusing the moves I
I think I called it 94. that's why and
there you go I was gonna say why is
Ralph thinking he stumbled into this
what now he's thinking no it's because
Jan mixed up the board or 94 is the move
here and how do I know he mixed up the
move order he's starting to think and
Danny after Queen C3 I think there's a
check on G5 and this might have
frittered away the sort of theoretical
Advantage the white is supposed to have
E4 could also come with a discovered
attack uh-oh and you might have fitted
away your chances to use Fritter again
because you've now used it three times
on the show so let's move forward have I
farted away my commentary spot and
further uh I'm just kidding no but my
point is you weren't wrong that the
gamble kind of paid off momentum plays a
line a dubious line in the dragon Beyond
a pawn machine stumbles a little bit in
terms of his theory now we're in a
position where black is already on a
slightly better footing than you would
normally get should white have
remembered to play the 94 move order so
um this is fun there are a lot of games
going we we can go wherever wherever the
the journey wants to take us if we want
to check in on the matchup we were
talking a lot about which was of course
damaraju gukesh versus Vladimir kramnik
um and we should check on that I think
we have cameras for both those guys so
we can head over there let's go ahead
and do it another look at that purple
chair Danny and I'm just gonna say one
of those things
uh that people say about athletes
anytime Vladimir cranberry plays that's
just a moment to savor I mean this is
just such a great moment because you
just don't know how many more times
we're gonna see Vladimir kramnik make an
appearance essentially still very close
to the prime of his abilities as he has
demonstrated in this tournament every
time he plays he does a great job
especially when there's a two-second
increment
it's true and again the fact is he got
in he was number 12 by the way if you're
just tuning in he got in by the by just
by the skin of his teeth but now that
he's here I know gukesh picked him but
ah I don't know I feel like the 14th
World chess champion it might take that
personal you know I don't know that he's
gonna go full Go full MJ here and and uh
and drop the cigar and grab the whiskey
but I think that I think that he might
take it personal there's a great Russian
expression in this situation Danny
uh which is cram nickels show him where
the lobsters spend their summer
literally which essentially means I'll
show you where it's at you picked me all
right you picked me all right I'm gonna
show you what happens when you pick me
and right now I think kramnik is off to
a great start it's a hedgehog structure
he has eliminated Weitzman Academy
Bishop never a good thing for white
black is chilling here
I like Black's position and again if if
you were in that spot Donya regardless
of the uh you know the hype and the um
the the reference to the Last Dance okay
by the way sorry not their summer I
missed okay we're the lobsters but but
let me ask you like how would you take
it if you were picked I mean obviously
you you remove your your uh your
emotions if you can
um and be objective but if you were
picked to throw down and someone someone
said like hey I think I can take this
guy how did you how do you take that
I mean you take it as motivation and you
just lean on what you have accomplished
in the past right I think kramnik is
under no Illusions like he knows that
he's probably going to be gukesh's
choice so I don't think he's taking it
personally to the point where he's just
I'm never talking to this guy again I
hope ukesh doesn't succeed in fact
kramnik was one of two players the other
being Boris gelfon who traveled to India
and conducted a high level training
session with the top Indian Junior so he
is very well familiar with gukesh and so
I actually think he's embracing the
challenge he maybe even appreciates the
chance uh to show gukesh uh where the
lobsters spend their winter and gukesh
trying to show cram Nick what happens
when you put a knight on e4 prematurely
look at the tension there between the
knights who is better and why this might
be a total fizzle out and a draw I mean
anything is possible here
yeah well if it's a draw you got to feel
good if you're chronic because you have
the black pieces then you get a second
chance this white let's remind everybody
it's a two-game match format right so
unless we have a tie and we move on to
to Armageddon we'll talk about what that
process is it's two games to decide the
winner and ultimately who punches their
ticket to compete in The Knockout next
week
and the thing about two game matches
Danny that I love is that you
essentially create Intrigue right off
the bat because if one side wins I think
we need more situations in chess where
one player absolutely has to win that
situation occurs in the World's Cup
which is also a two-game format and it
produces some of the most entertaining
chess you will ever see because players
who don't usually find themselves in
that situation are suddenly thrust into
a spot where they gotta change their
openings they got to change their play
Styles and we are going to see a healthy
dose of that as Vladimir kramnik makes a
very committal decision pushing his Pawn
up to the center knocking off the bishop
but weakening some of the light squares
here yeah that's that's a big commitment
and maybe he thinks all the nights are
coming off one of the points is that if
oh I just grabbed my mouse like I was
going to highlight something instructive
you're in control my point was let's say
Nights on YouTube were traded and the
Knights on G4 are traded now you're in a
position where the D5 and F5 squares
can't really be targeted anymore by a
pony right so suddenly it's it's a
little bit harder for white to really
expose those advantages regardless of
how they look
I'm not the biggest fan of E5 because
while I agree with you what I want to
show here really quickly is after Knight
takes C2 Rook takes C2 takes takes first
of all crucial detail Bishop G5 would
win the game were it not for the movie
three and yes you can occupy it with a
pony what you can do is attack D6 with
the Rooks and the bishop and you could
put a rook on D5 it's the next best
thing you want a knight on The Outpost
Rook on The Outpost ain't too shabby
either I feel like kramnik might be
slipping just a little bit but obviously
way too early to say still a lot of
fight left H4 would be a grave error
because of Knight to H3 check and then
you can get mated on H1 not deserable or
lose or lose the F2 pull and that would
be funny yeah white has to play the move
King to H2 here
or not I wasn't even that the queen
could slide across adding some Cholula
to the position if you will yeah
slicing it up
and uh there you go the queen comes to
F5 and guards
h3o speaking of Tapatio farrugia has a
Tapatio going on in his game if with
your permission we can jump to his
affair uh against zidwani
I'm all about it as soon as we can we
will make the plan but right now we've
uh
we'll flip we'll flip it over here we go
what's going on for arugia is arusha's
looking fantastic what happened here
yeah sorry to pull everybody away and
the cremated game is very rich but
ferusa is completely winning game one in
17 moves it was a very bad opening for
round Knack who played a weird Dutch I
mean he was stumbling around while
farusha was developing his pieces and
that King is on its last legs but
farusha is also getting a rook to E7 so
whichever way you slice it here this
looks totally lost for black but
roundock he's a tricky guy Arusha needs
a little bit of precision here to finish
him off in game one oh oh yeah I love
that move
what 96 he's gonna go Knight F4 anyway
trade and get the G file I love it this
just I was gonna highlight the bishop
pairs the problem the dark squares are
the problem 92 was a great way to
execute but the truth is Black's
problems weren't gonna fix themselves
and
and now you're just really tough I mean
you could you could probably also meet
96 with with just Bishop to C3 and black
still has struggles we see roundock
speaking of struggling he is head in
hand Focus farouza given a little bit of
a bob there
um but Knight F4 check is going to be
devastating whether it forces the trade
and opening of the G file or not
yeah this is very impressive play in the
early going buy all your reservation who
I've been saying for a while now is one
of the top end game players in the world
has already established himself as a
technician I think Magnus Carlson has
the top spot but of the young players
alireza farouza's endgame prowess is
very underrated and I think will be the
subject of a lot of Praise as he builds
his trust career if of course he ever
you know plays an OTV tournament but he
is making a case right now that he is
not just not Rusty that he is ready to
fire away and fire away he will at
Black's King the Evo bar going up even
further
yeah and where's the crusher we're
announcing we're announcing some sort of
knockout here for the computer I just
okay
H6
Bishop E3 there is the move G5
intercepting the bishop she's gotta be
careful
and for ruja you can sense the wheels
turning he gives that check he takes
that Rook okay just gets The Rook D1
play it simple rookie seven coming in I
think black is just overwhelmed Black's
Rook is not playing white is playing
this literally up a rook and a bishop
Rook E7 just wins a piece like Drew
Yorktown can't defend both draw in nepo
momentov by the way Jan just had to bail
out after that opening mishap yeah
played Bishop to C4 instead of 94 on
move 12 of a well-known line in the
Yugoslav attack uh nine castles Long
Dragon so he just kind of you know the
the Gambit paid off for momentum we
talked about there we'll talk about it
later because right now Arusha is
picking between I thought he was going
to take F6 and played rookie eight but
then maybe there was Knight D6 right so
he's just gonna keep the clamps why part
ways with the bishop pair this is
horrible
this is terrible indeed I think we can
entrust the rest of the winning process
to alireza we've got a bunch of other
games hicaro we've got andraken uh
against their geissy Fabiana carwana is
a crazy position can we go there uh
unless and then Hikaru has a pretty
stable equal end game so that might bail
out we'll check into him but I want to
show you
y'all this position Bobby has the white
pieces Alexi serrana is threatening
Checkmate on G2
yo help me out here Danny happened here
I I uh this is a big Pawn chain and
somebody knows how to use it he's got a
uh he's got a Pawn on D6 but a Pawn on
on C4 to meet it Frets on G2 White's
better oh my God according to the
computer but I feel super scared if I'm
if I'm playing white I'm terrified Rook
takes D6 looks like it wins a pawn
because you can't recapture what you can
do is play Rook to E2
hitting the queen putting the Rook on a
defended square and then I think you can
recapture The Rook this has to be
carefully considered though by Serana
and he's not usually down on the clock
if he's down on the clock it's a pretty
bad sign he adheres to the John
napomnishi school where he will play
very quickly even in complex positions
this position though complex is a huge
understatement yep
although I like that you highlighted the
D6 tactic because even if it doesn't
work right now that back rank is a
problem for Fabiano so he's using his
time partly because he probably knows
that there may be something sensitive
and tender right now and he doesn't want
to let it slip although that he doesn't
know the computer says no White's fine
Persia has one by the way as expected
just a couple moves in and G6 here might
be the way for black to douse the Flames
of White's King side attack you create a
little Luft yeah blunt the influence of
the bishop there's no doubt in my mind
that white is better objectively but the
things can turn around instantly here in
one move one little mistake
yeah geez Louise geez Louise geez Louise
you get nervous when one move could lose
a chess game is that why you're nervous
all the time
I am nervous I mean I'm nervous on
behalf of the players my heart is
beating I can't even imagine what
they're feeling
in this two-game affair if Fabi loses
this with white I mean beating Alexi
with black on demand
I know of a couple easier things
and Rook takes D6 here Danny as I always
like to say just because the move
doesn't work in one position it doesn't
mean it doesn't work in another you have
to keep reevaluating the same tactic
over and over again I still think the
White's got rookie too
my goodness three minutes for Alexi that
might be a problem is there also Rook F1
I guess I think both moves
get the Rook off of the square and then
you can take D6 right
oh yeah that's even simpler you're
absolutely because it keeps the Rooks
connected
yep
so Rook takes D6 is impossible is Bobby
gonna play for H4 and H5 is that just
like that's a little too much right like
come on Dan like calm down
I think you're right that he's gonna
play with his pawns I think F5 is
probably the likeliest trying to smash
through on G6 you could attack a bishop
there
Alexi though E4 reminding Fabi that two
can play at that game he's got some
Pawns of his own but this might be a
little bit too slow
B4
yeah the problem is you're gonna get C3
but then what and then what yeah white
white has H4 coming H5 coming maybe F5
as you said
Rook F1 probably worth throwing in at
some point probably now just get the
Queen off of your back get a little
breathing room for your king I like your
idea I think F5 might be even stronger
paradoxically with the Rook on F1
because you can imagine Danny after the
F takes G6 happens that Rook is aiming
at F7 the Tactical potential here
against Black's King is unreal but if
Fabio doesn't unlock it properly it
could easily backfire
yeah well said and
well the problem is if you ever play a
five E five Falls two though so if
you're not delivering the goods on G6
with some sort of crashing through you
also want to keep your whole Pawn chain
together F4 E5 D6 is is by Design right
and it also is holding Black's pieces
back so again that's why as we say it
like the players are the players are
using their time for a reason because
this is this is very tricky and what a
what a weird swing of a game when you
have one side with with a massive
majority versus the other on two
opposite sides of the board weird
position it's a ridiculous position this
might be a fascinating time scramble I'm
keeping a side eye on Vladimir kramnik's
game he seems to be in a little bit of
trouble I'm not sure if it's a little or
a lot we could check that out in duboff
Nakamura we have an end game where
Daniel dubuff talk about delivering the
goods he's got Hikaru Nakamura under
some serious pressure between those two
games Danny do we stay on this one do we
go there we got a good problem we got
too many interesting games hey as I've
been saying my hands aren't on the wheel
I'm just I'm just a passenger baby you
take me where you want okay a quick look
at Hikaru nakamura's end game and then
back to the kramnik game hopefully for
the end of that Daniel dubov has just
declined a draw offer of taking a page
out of hikaru's book okay and I think
for a very good reason he can stick a
second night on C6
oh geez
it's also got a roughly equal situation
on the clock okay right as I say that
he's now entering under three minutes
but when we first joined it was close
enough to say like all right first thing
you check against zacaro is am I way
down on time he's not way down on time
he has a better position he's got a
couple of nights on strong squares but
objectively as well black has no
position or weaknesses yet right it's
all activity that favors white nothing
concrete unless he converts so these
positions are also dangerous against a
guy like Hikaru if you try too hard as
we always say then you get under time
pressure you know before you know it the
script is flipped not the good kind
um
bad kind I did commit the serious
transgression of Consulting our silicon
fiend but okay the best move apparently
was Knight a to B7 that talk about any
human how do you not put your knight on
C6 not just because the knights are
arranged in kind of cool fashion because
they're controlling all the scores
Knight ab7 though prevents black snipe
from jumping out to its most active
Square on C5 which I think is what
Hikaru should do to exploit Knight C6 it
was an inaccuracy objectively but you
take everything with a grain of salt I
mean black is hanging by a thread in
this end game tons of forks tons of
threats
and I think Knight C5 might actually be
the only way or black to keep the sort
of defensive flame burning here and he
plays it you don't have to tell him
twice yeah of course he sees it well if
B4 the Knight will pop to A4 with Tempo
on the bishop I'm assuming uh if you
give black another move is he playing
something like King f8 just like I don't
know inching your way toward defensive
defensive efforts in the center these
positions are always so funny down here
because like everything is completely
symmetrical besides the pieces and where
they are and and the initiative can get
away from you super quickly but also you
can get a snap of the finger and
everybody's traded and we just overall
because because no one had any
positional weaknesses and you could even
get a turnaround here white could
overpress overextend I mean those nights
as cool as they look they're not very
well defended so you can think of an id5
could have happened there in duboff
decides to manage his risk eliminates F6
and Knight takes F7 is an easy tactic
there that's in the air so Hikaru nips
that in the bud and he's still worse
Danny but I think he's holding on pretty
nicely thus far Vladimir kramnik though
he is not holding on very nicely I think
he might be losing his game let's go
check out that game because I think it's
probably the biggest
probably the biggest storyline heading
into our match play portion if you just
tuned in why is that the case well
damaraji gukesh finished number one
after several hours of an epic Swiss
event and one of the people he beat
along the way everyone was the world
champion Vladimir kramnik and we
speculated whether he would choose to go
back to that well he says yeah it's not
dried up yet because remember one of the
cool things about our format Donya one
through six get to pick their opponents
so gukesh just to remind the fans chose
to play Chronic and right now it seems
to be paying off it is but gukesh he was
on the queen side uh of the queen versus
rook and peace Affair in the first round
against Borussia he failed to win that
one in fact he almost lost it so he
might be experiencing some Deja Vu but
this is a much easier position to play
the reason Danny that it's winning for
white isn't just the material it's the
weaknesses in Black's Camp E6 and G6 and
the king is exposed there's Forks
kramnik his defensive strategy here is
to keep his pieces on protected squares
that's why he's gone Bishop C5 this game
is far from over but kremna cannot
afford another mistake he's got to be
perfect here if he wants a chance at
salvaging a draw yeah this was a fun
move because Bishop takes E3 can be met
by Queen takes E6 and on Bishop D4 Queen
D6 check I saw it Donya hey there I know
I did you saw that excellent
there you go Mama's lemonade was always
the best Mama's lemonade extra sugar
miss you mama all right here we go Queen
A2 hits E6 Knight C2 maybe gonna follow
to kick the brook off of that square and
then okay no problem gets The Rook off
of the square voluntarily but now maybe
Knight okay you've been Knight C4 I was
saying it's 19 one night C3 the maneuver
tomato tomato yep
Rook is exposed though Danny Queen C2
comes to Minds now you could easily
blunder here with white too I mean
there's Forks everywhere who cash trying
to arrange his pawns to maximally
restrict Black's Knight I'll just point
out Danny that the pawn isn't really
going anywhere you do not want to play
B5 and leave the bishop exposed to a
fork that's the best way to lose
instilling
oh yep
here he goes
he's just gonna win the pawn straight up
from Nick gives a bit of a smile there I
don't think it's a happy smile it's like
ah all right and remember everybody this
is not uh we're not in store here for
hours of knockout play that starts on
February 6th this is already very high
stakes it's one and a half points to
punch your ticket for the main event and
and the and the uh the chest that kicks
off on February 6th so losing this game
is a big big blow for Vladimir chronix
chances Hikaru has drawn that position
against two but I think we should go to
fabi's game because this one is totally
over he will resign any second there's
nothing left to see here let's go
straight to Fabiano caruana who is it a
fascinating time scramble I like to see
Serrano with five seconds on his last
legs I think he might be losing this one
very shortly
yeah five seconds to hold a position
when your king is under Fiverr a Fiverr
I was I was combining Under Fire and a
flavor and that's what came out it's not
everyone's favorite flavor that's what I
was gonna say having a king Under Fire
with five seconds is not everyone's
favorite flavor say that five times fast
and uh
that's that's not my favorite flavor
five all right here we go
um the second sorry the seventh rank is
exposed Here Comes E7 and queen E6 check
H6 and queen he calculated the whole
thing before he went for it that's how
fobby does work Queen F5 you can pick up
the Rook on E2 but then the queen will
step aside and make way for the pawn and
fabi's gotta admit oh rookie unless
there's a perpetual
I don't think there is incredibly a
funny idea by the way green fh5 and then
take the rook and then take the Rook
okay he doesn't do it no but this is
winning dead King G3 I would go King G3
probably because the queen on E8 is
going to essentially create an umbrella
for the white king to run toward the
center there must be a way to escape the
checks here I'm I guarantee it
come on hey that was a five head five
head move right there
come on
what's that from I guaran no I was just
thinking I guarantee it that's from
Men's the old Men's Warehouse commercial
anyways oh yeah you're gonna like I
totally heard what you said I guarantee
it there you go nice well Fabiano
takes a lead in his match versus Alexi
serrana if you're just joining Ali Reza
farusia did the same against round ox
adwani
here we have Dimitri on draken and Arjun
irigaisi
and on draken he struggled in the first
round of the cgc against Wesley and he's
about to lose this one to an angry Danny
let me tell you our generic guy sees on
a mission right now he had a nightmare
event inside of Steel he wants to prove
to everybody that he's 27 30 for a
reason this one's over Queen H5 was made
Queen G3 is made in one Queen H4 his
mate is 24 with my favorite fine fine we
were choosing we were choosing potato
potato
I would have chosen Queen H4 but okay
let's quickly go to the only other game
in progress which I believe wait is that
it
I think that might be it that's it
that's it okay only one draw Danny this
is impressive Hikaru Duba the only
peaceful result the rest was your blood
spilled everywhere
iragaisi takes down on draken with black
carwana takes down Serrano with white as
you can see before you Nakamura and
dubov Drew their game but I think we
have the full list of results
respectively to maybe to maybe throw
your way uh reminder we also saw good
cash or we didn't actually see the Annie
book ukesh did indeed take down chronic
there was one other draw you forgot
nepalm Machine versus momentum yeah yeah
that was a quick one actually and nepo
must be kicking himself because Rafa met
up with white is just a force of nature
so yawn failing to deliver that opening
Salvo he mixes up the move order and
he's got to get his act together in game
two with black that's gonna be a
fascinating game
and if that game ends in a draw then the
Silver Lining is that we'll get an
Armageddon so it's a win-win for the
commentators but the players got to be
feeling the nerves
well I mean if we look at those trailing
who has the best chance to come back you
know the Quran MC lost but he was black
so now he gets white uh on Dragon's in a
tough spot because he just lost with
white that's not everyone's favorite
thing to do
ranoxodwani also gets white but I have a
feeling that Perugia might just be too
much too much today uh for the the other
young rising star from India there are
three of them on the screen the other
other rising star from India uh in Round
Rock subwani so
um
well I think the Nakamura dubov game is
also an interesting one we'll be focused
on right away because Hikaru getting
white having held with black that's
going to be that's gonna be a tricky one
it is an actually a big Miss for Dubai
you know that game could have gone to
Bob's way he had a big Advantage at some
point in the end game but Hikaru one of
the Premier Defenders especially in
Blitz and Rapid it almost seemed like he
held it easily even though it was far
from Easy Alexi serrana Danny another
guy to watch who's so dangerous with
white he's got tons of preparation so he
ain't going gentle into that good night
either and neither of course is former
world champion Vladimir kramnik yep here
he goes back to his old vintage you know
opening repertoire for white according
to Vladimir kramnik not written by
Vladimir kramnik contrary to popular
belief written by Alexander Hall leafman
beat a world champion uh if you if you
remember the old days when we had the
fide World knockout giving a world
championship title
shout out to you halifman a great great
book series and here we see chronic
repertoire in action
yeah he's going for a little before
action early in the game even before
developing
is before developing his Knight on G1
just gonna pause here for a dramatic
effect
sometimes you just let it breathe
sometimes you say it's the best way to
tell a joke Danny yeah and then you look
at the camera look at the camera smile
look at the baby look at the baby
back to the chest easy easy okay bye go
cash he's not waiting he's the one guy
who said I'm not waiting for you to play
B4 I am counter-striking in the center
with D5 this is the type of onbalanced
position you want to have if you're
Vladimir but Danny the danger is that if
you get to Cavalier with your kingside
development or lack thereof and you
allow D5 you don't have the Machinery to
stop the progression of black center
pawns I would go Knight F3 here with
kramnik and stop playing with fire and
Castle ASAP get out of that center
before black blasted open
100 agreed plus if you play Knight F3 on
D5 there's ideas after e d e d that you
can even change the structure with D4 in
some position so you have a lot of
options if you play Knight F3 and get
castle rather than you know of course E3
is also a move H4 don't be chronic dude
he's gone full Alpha zero lad was never
the same after he spent too much time
there with that Deep Mind crew look at
this H Pawn running up the board maybe
he thinks this is no castling chest but
I love every bit of it gukesh says I'm
not impressed he just stops the
progression of the pawn with H6 and H5
is now going to be met probably with G5
though you can also grab that pawn but I
don't think I think gukash is preparing
G5 we're about to find out maybe he
doesn't know what he wants to do here H5
you got you gotta love this you know why
because it's not like chronic is looking
for a boring game look at the scoreboard
he has to win this game or it's over a
draw is uh is is all good cash needs
right so he's literally playing for two
results
oh four
let's go this is how we play when we
have to win
Danny I hate to be the Debbie Downer
here uh but I I don't believe in this I
think ukesh is gonna play D5 and dude I
I feel like White's just two on sound in
the center whoa every move is surprising
the words in the words of Clint Eastwood
believes got nothing to do with it okay
deserves got nothing to do with it I'm
not saying this is good for white I'm
saying let's go H5 and F4 is epic that's
how you play when you're down or not
he's just going all in man I love it
true and you know I'm the first person
to approve of this kind of play you know
this is what I've made my living on
but when Vladimir kramnik plays it you
know it's a little bit scarier than when
some obscure commentator plays this kind
of again I'm surprised he plays GF Danny
this is incredibly creative play he
opens up the G file so what he wants
here Knight F3 Rook G1 and let's not
forget the black and black spawn
structure also damage so he could
potentially play positionally as well on
the queen side here no I let me set the
record straight I love this I'm just a
little bit worried for his own King
safety he's gonna play he's gonna play
Knight F3 he's gonna put the Rook on G1
he'll play E3 he'll play King E2 or King
F2 he'll get the other pieces to the
king side I don't even know oh wait no
he's going with E4
this is it the night this feels like a
game that mittens would play as white
can I just say that that's how this
feels this feels like a game that you're
like what is going on here and then
suddenly the neural net machine learning
engine known as known as mittens goes
and White's winning
I feel like I joked about this earlier
but maybe Krab Nick has a side bet with
someone that he can win a game without
castling he's playing an old Castle's
chess you know gukesh can do anything he
wants but Queen D4 uh gukesh might want
a Checkmate on F2 and then Rook d8 hits
the pawn on D3 and one of the big
problems here for Vladimir is that he
can't go Rook H3 to cover that pawn
because someone
is caught with his pants down on the
king side maybe Queen F3 and King E2 is
what the doctor ordered but then there's
some crazy tactics with the Knight F2
this is gonna get incredible very very
shortly I wish I could just play King D2
to be honest I can't for a number of
reasons you don't need to list out but
if I could put my king on C2 I'm just
gonna finish the thought and and deal
with the fork I'd be happy
um but uh not easy to do you're right
probably Queen F3
but yeah this this this I'm just gonna
make the moves here and I thought this
worked for a second but then I realized
there's no mate on D1 the night cover is
that Anna covers The Rook
um yeah yeah so yeah
sex on E5 maybe B5 throws some more oil
onto the fire I feel like this position
might actually arise and this is where
I'm really really afraid that cram Nick
could just get checkmated with all these
monsters sitting around the center and
the King side yeah
well if it wasn't no Castle's chest bed
then at least he'll win his side bet
um whether even if he does go home it
was pretty epic to see him throw it down
today but all right there's some other
games that have also gotten started
Donya we can uh we can go anywhere but
you're in charge
Hikaru has already drawn he drew the
opening getting straight into the
Armageddon he offered a draw with white
and we saw him do this in the RCC this
is this is his Mo in a lot of these two
game matches he believes in his ability
to pull out the Armageddon and his
record does and has often proved him
right but what a risky call geez yeah
when you get the white pieces normally
you push a little bit but Hikari was
that confident and likes himself some
winner take all chest that's what
Armageddon is it's winner take all we
like to use that phrase in sports but in
chess there's always been a caveat
nothing is really ever winner take all
because you can draw not so fast when it
comes to Armageddon the most exciting
event in sports of course right behind
sudden death dodgeball
absolutely I'm going to go to my meta of
nepo because the other two games they're
both in a nimzo Indian but they have
just started so we're gonna let uh
serrana caruana and uh eragisi Andre can
develop a little bit we'll go there in a
while here we have an opposite colored
Bishop middle game so it's not a draw
just yet as long as the Queens are on
the board Danny and nepo kind of
deciding do I want to implicitly offer a
draw or do I want to keep chances alive
but potentially give white pressure on
the F7 Pawn that actually looks a little
bit unpleasant for black
yeah I mean at this point because nepo
got to this position facing potential
and we're getting different than Hikaru
where he drew a game with white
not not in a fashion he wanted he
probably he'd probably be happy to draw
this position as black and he is a
little worse here Knight E5 is coming as
you said F7 is tender
we're not sure what exactly nepo's
thinking we'll find out soon but uh
I have a bad feeling about this Danny on
John's behalf because that Knight is
coming into E5 and you've got Rook C1
you've got this weird maneuver Bishop F1
C4 mehmedov hit one of his strongest
suits is his ability to play with the
initiative he is so good at continuing
to create problems and
right now he's got exactly what he wants
a relatively risk-free position with
more active pieces and clear tactical
chances
well Meadow's got a risky position I'm
looking at the risk of that fan spinning
super fast above John de palmishi's head
he's moving the air around but speaking
of air by the way we got an air quality
check by the way did you know that I
have a an air thing set up here in the
office Donya I did not I find out new
things every day what my air quality is
it's right there on screen doesn't look
all that good I think I can see the word
poor there
wait it says poor damn girl I wonder I'm
feeling so tired
maybe that's why I'm lacking cognitive
thinking maybe that's why I lack
strategic thinking maybe that's why I'm
not playing chess very good is because
the air quality in this studio isn't
improving the brain waves of this guy
can we get it
a full-scale investigation to get
togethers of this will be brought to
Justice
I'm actually I'm actually not kidding it
does get a little stuffy in here when
you've been in the room for six hours
but shout out to air things thanks for
bringing us that air quality measurement
you might literally be improving the
quality of my life if we start taking
these uh these stats to heart and
improving the airflow in here
yeah this is a
This Ain't Good Danny this has to be
gone to the bottom of ASAP well maybe we
should go yeah yeah I was gonna say the
only thing worse than this is uh that we
haven't checked in all the games yet so
let's dive over and you take us to the
next uh the next beautiful chess board
to look at all right well the next
beautiful chessboard to look at and
we've got two games competing for my
attention obviously kramnik gukesh is
continuing to go Haywire we'll go there
soon but we have uh Arjun aragaisi
against a must win Dimitri on draken and
let me tell you Danny this is going
completely the other way Dimitri has
really dropped the ball in this mini oh
he's losing a pawn here no I this might
just end very quickly
it's it's you know we knew he was in
trouble because he lost with white in in
the first game but it looks like he also
might be feeling a little disheartened
because this one is just getting away
from him fast that was feasty by Arjun
by the way F takes E4 was a lot stronger
yeah get a big get a big Pawn Center
shake what your mama gave you I always
say if I may really quickly F takes C4
might have just ended the match not
trying to be dramatic but I if I'm
calculating correctly E5 might be
winning H5 is coming baby or this or
queen H5 tonight in the pawn this would
have ended it yeah okay
bye
I mean he takes to the bishop and
obviously what appeals to him is Knight
takes C4 you can take H7
and I'll show this as well Queen D3 pick
up C4 and from a practical match
perspective this is perfect opposite
colored Bishops with an extra Pawn Arjun
is not going to lose this in a million
years
word
yep we're not looking good for Dima at
all
sure well we got missionic against
caruana serrana against caruana that
even Rhymes and we've got kramnick's
game which has subsided a little bit in
the sense that the Queens are off the
board but kukesh is sitting pretty shall
we check into Bobby's game and then go
back to kramnik Let's Do It Let's Do It
Fabi first then kromnik and uh we'll see
we'll see if the 14th World chess
champion can pull a miracle or if he is
headed home and back to the drawing
board remember carwana up a full game
now with the black pieces
um
okay E6 are you looking spicy the pawn
is pinned The Rook on A8 is undefended
white has Queen B3 coming and then Rook
to D1
no you know it's one of those positions
that looks very impressive because your
eyes are drawn to that pawn chain but on
chains don't win games good moves when
games Knight B5 to D6 might be one of
those good moves so black has the
equivalent outpost on D3 and karuana is
just salivating at the prospect of of
sticking a knife there the opposite
colored Bishops uh aren't doing any
favors for Alexi either black has
potentially C6 a nice little parking
spot for the bishop I like Fabby here I
think Alexa needs to whip up some
tactical action pretty quickly and
Knight B5 is the only way I see to do
that
well especially because black is playing
for two results right a draw and and
Fabi is is dancing on Monday as the main
event kicks off so
um
so yeah I don't like the more the more
we talk about talk about the position
and remind ourselves of that fact heart
to see how Alexi Serrano is jumping up
real winning chances here
yeah no he's he's taking his time he has
been struggling with the clock
uncharacteristically in these two games
and probably on a carwana I mean we've
talked about his rapid Improvement Danny
and that's one of the narratives really
of his online play the past year and you
can't say it enough I mean he is just
this is Fabiano caruana 2.0 who matches
his opponent's speed on the clock who
plays his best preparation but Alexi he
ain't ready to give up just yet Knight
B5 on the board and he's gonna continue
trying to whip up some chances but I
think we should go to the board of
Vladimir kramnik because that game might
be reaching his climax okay
ukesh and chromic I see you chat you're
asking for us to check out the farrugia
game we'll feature baby birds just just
sit there mama's gonna feed you and
we're gonna be there soon I don't know
why I said it like that but we're just
not gonna lose I think so that game has
been in an end game for a long time but
we'll get there after this one let's
just evaluate the position and evaluate
Vladimir's winning chances which I don't
believe are very high great they're not
great you're right
they're actually close to zero
I mean yeah
I mean that seemed a little harsh but
okay
um
no but the reason I say that is largely
because first of all
my I'm not math good as you say but I
think black is up a pawn white can win
it back that's not the problem the
problem is this monster sitting on D5
which kramnik is trying to smoke out so
he still
you know he's still creating threats but
no significantly worse you're right and
and if you ever take D5 black will
likely just take with the c Pawn open up
that light Square bishop and uh that's
no fun you highlight rookie eight I was
gonna say
you have to do something to guard the
bishop on E7 but Bishop to E8 is really
what black wants to play right as soon
as you can so are you going to play
Bishop d8 so you can play no but then C5
hangs so you're right yeah you probably
have to play rookie yay and he just did
farrugia has drawn his game and I was
keeping an eye on it throughout Danny it
wasn't really that interesting Queen
trade early said one he never even came
close it was just symmetrical the whole
way through and around I could just
admitted defeat alireza farusha is the
first of the six players to punch their
ticket into division one of the air
things Majors Magnus Carlson here I come
says Mr faruja that's a big moment a big
moment Ali Reza farouza is the first
person to punch his ticket for The
Knockout stage of the air things Masters
which as we've been saying all day will
start on Monday after everyone gets a
bit of a weekend rest February 6th kicks
things off and the crew from Oslo our
studio there will have the coverage
including Grandmaster Robert Hess
Grandmaster David Howell International
Master yavanka houska Kaya snore and uh
I think Tanya is in studio I don't know
if tonya's there I apologize
um if I think she is but I don't
remember
because I'm tired
and your air quality your air qualities
my air quality is bad your cause God
that makes me feel like I can say
anything and I can't get canceled
because my air quality is bad
no you're absolutely right I is you
should just run wild
here are some things I've been looking
to get off my chest
reading in chess I'd like to say the
following just kidding lawyers don't
worry guys I'm not going to say the
things you don't want me to say LOL uh
please don't clip that
um okay
my air quality was good if my air
quality was good
um any Hooters here we go Rook to G2
played from Nick trying to keep the
fight Alive
by the way we should go to nepo's game
when we have a chance I don't mean to
okay you know call the I'll call the
shot sorry Danny it's just that I'm
looking at the board and I feel like my
Madoff is actually pretty close to
winning here
yeah no Jan really let that first one
get away from him shout out to momentum
because we were skeptical like hey this
is such a gamble you're really hoping
that Jan doesn't remember his theory
well guess what John made one mistake
momentum was able to simplify the whole
game and now with the white pieces you
might be about to send the world
championship Challenger home
well the world championship Challenger
will have to you know make his home in
division two if he loses this game with
the first one being drawnie has just
taken the night he is down upon oh my
goodness he is being pushed to the edge
of the board the eval bar creeps up I
think the move H4 really cements and
shows the extent of White's Advantage
stopping Knight G5 oh my gosh this is
dead lost but the metaph has a little
bit of work to do and we know we know
how tricky nepo can be when his back is
against the wall
indeed indeed indeed
neither fake queen D6 might be also in
the cards but that has to be carefully
calculated because you might lose that
pawn
if if you're not careful
I think it might work though
Queen D6 uh he goes for it we're gonna
find out John gives the head nod which
is not the happy head nod yawn no it's
like the uh if this works I'm screwed
Jan that's like uh he can do that if he
can do that you know I finally get some
respect you know that was my Rodney
Dangerfield
um I don't even know if you're allowed
to do that speaking of things that can
get you canceled don't impersonate that
guy
um any Hooters where are we going
that is how your career ended no I think
this is over I think this it's plus
seven and that's because the queen trade
actually loses for black and the reason
it's lost for black Danny is because the
bishop controls the E6 Square so the
king can't approach the pawn that way
otherwise you're gonna have to lose the
F7 pawn and the knight in these types of
end games is just horrible because it
can't multitask it's tied down yeah to
the pawns this is total desperation for
Yan he tries to keep the Queens on the
board and he has to
but I think Ralph should be able to
finish this off with a couple more
accurate moves
for sure and also you look at the time
and that's that's telling right yonda
palm machine is usually up on the clock
when he's winning he's down on the clock
and losing
barely holding on right now moment of
trying to show the technique
the technique he brings to the table
Bishop to D5 really clamping down where
almost any move black makes makes his
position worse he's not sweating the
technique he is playing pretty fast here
the one thing you've got to be very
careful about if you're white is pushing
your pawns prematurely because that's
the one way I've seen these games get
swindled the queen suddenly comes out
and before you know it the queen is
harassing the white king so you're never
really out of the woods in terms of
King's safety because the queen is so
quick to activate I think Jan is praying
for something like that and so Madoff is
just sort of taking his time but
eventually he's gonna have to make a
decision on how he wants to win the game
maybe take the pawn on B4 and trade it
for E5 maybe try to expose Black's King
but whatever you do it'll give black
some chances Jan hasn't lost his Hope
just yet
yeah came to G1 and uh
Jan is gonna try to find a make try to
find a way to make a move that both
passes kind of passes the ball back and
doesn't make his position worse it's not
easy to figure out how to do that
nope
by the way Arjun aragaisy is about to
punch his ticket
through to division one he has a
completely unusable position we can
catch the end of that one Danny uh we
could also go to Serana carwana I just
love saying that let's take our wanna
car wanna start carwana or geisey and
Drake Kawana I want a lot of sarwana
carwana I want a lot of sarwana carwana
let's do it I want to honest I say that
10 times in a row sir Juana caruana
Lions inside
yeah exactly you know I was listening to
the chess.com show those guys are so
entertaining it was done yet and I think
it was Danny that day and they were
doing impersonations of me it was funny
and you know Jen they said I wonder what
Yasser would sound like if he said
sarwana carwana ten times
hillberg
here we go 1876 and King Louis XVI is
actually playing in that tournament
before they unseated him
and uh Robespierre came in and had a
problem with that anyways we're up to A5
speaking of heads getting chopped off
I think Dimitri on drakens run here is
about Rover
yep
he gave that he gave that kind of look
right there like all right this is
frustrating
what to do now
remember he has to win it's win or go
home at this time
these are two game matches with
Armageddon tie breaks awaiting we
already know that one match is headed
there that is of course Hikaru Nakamura
versus Daniel dubov and uh
interesting things to unpack there about
how Caro approached that strategy he's
done it before will he do it again
improve what he's capable of in
Armageddon
um but will any other matches join them
is the question
Volks Vladimir kramnik certainly won't
join them I think he's dead lost against
kukesh who does have 10 seconds on his
clock this is over by the way Danny I
mean it's in the back for Arjun and I'm
not jinxing I mean it literally on Drake
and it should be losing here objectively
but I think arjun's just gonna Shuffle
until he had draken might just offer a
draw here that is how hopeless this is
we could go to my meta back to my
medical
tons of games reaching a key point
all right let's go to Vladimir real
quick I think he might be breathing his
last breaths here in division one but
he's still trying he's still trying he's
trying his little heart out man mama
always said he'd never give up and he's
all the way
he Stacks The Rook Bishop C5 it's still
a game but look at this Knight F6 check
he wants to win H6 and then go to the
eighth rank hold blooded assassin Rook
takes F6 and Bishop C5 takes G1 kramnik
runs out of moves it's over
yeah gukesh is finding these moves by
the way with less than 10 seconds he's
all over it oh this is what I knew was
going to happen go all in and then it's
it
unfortunately for the 14th World chess
champion he will not be playing in the
main event starting February 6 but it
that doesn't mean he didn't show up in
force today make his way through a
gauntlet of a Swiss and I have a feeling
that big Vlad will be back uh in future
play-ins for the uh 2023 Champions chess
tour I just I got a feeling
you most certainly will and there is
resignation who cash has sent him
packing Jana pomnishi has just been sent
packing we clicked at it at the right
moment it's over the Apon promotes what
a win for Ralph moment of this is huge
yep and that's the first person to win
who was chosen right Jana pommeshi chose
to play Ralph momentum because he
finished in the upper half and momentum
says hey you know what maybe rethink
those choices in the future because uh
at this point Ralph is Ralph is showing
that he is he is ready to play next week
he most certainly is and he has
experience facing Magnus Carlson In
classical chess I remember he played in
uh Sham kir in a super tournament and he
acquitted himself incredibly well so he
is no pushover in those top tournaments
he's actually a very unpleasant opponent
he's got a creative opening repertoire
and Alexi Serrano well his run might be
coming to an end here at the hands of
Fabi this is essentially unwinnable for
white much like ondraken's position
so we might only have one Armageddon
but that's all we need to keep ourselves
it's Nakamura versus dubov and uh
Zippity Zippity doob Zippity day my oh
my well we have Armageddon thank you
thank you thank you um all right here we
go
carwana sarwana I want a lot of it's not
a position that's giving white a lot of
chances as we said Fabiano not only in a
great position to draw given that he's
already up a game he's probably winning
this position if this if this momentum
continues so yeah
no other games with chances there again
huge shout out to Ralph it's one of the
cool things about the format is you'll
get these matchups we're not going to
see every day you get my Med of a
creative player aggressive player
throwing down next week against some of
the world's best can't wait to see what
that has along with so many others no
this is fantastic and this game it's not
over just yet on draken has officially
conceded the draw and of course
conceding the two-game match Alexi
serrana is still trying Fabiano has one
minute on the clock that is baby Alexi's
only chance if he can mix things up
somehow get to Black's King but there's
no mating construction Danny this is not
made the king always has G7 and White's
Bishop is really the problem here if it
was on H6 here we'd be singing a
different tune
it's not though it's on E1 and it's
basically a spectator
at the same time time pressure does
funny things to the mind right and it
does nervous we see it ticking away he
it may be easy for us to see that the
king is safe but I think he's nervous
about that he sees Rook A8 check coming
yeah followed by the Rooks coming to the
file I think he's nervous about a
potential mating net
short on time and of course the other
big thing that does things to your mind
is bad air quality let's hope Fabby
doesn't have that if only he had an air
tank device to check that Rook to F3 on
the board I think he's holding on here
Danny very important Rook C6 and B7
black can send both of his Rooks to the
eighth Rank and protect B8
carbon dioxide levels in my room are
rising with every passing time
moment I'm just checking I think it's
the toxicity of your co-commentator
usually that causes that those toxic
gases are being emitted it's incredibly
accurate the 1203 is exactly what it
says on my device I got to give them a
shout out to that
that doesn't make me happy that my air
quality is poor we're going to deal with
this later I'm actually fascinated by
this whole topic because I've learned
that humans will spend 90 percent of
their lifetime inside and I'm like wait
what so anyway we got to get on top of
Dan's air quality here I might pass out
mid-show one day if we don't okay back
to the position oh my God he takes C6
well he has to he's wait this is the
last guy yeah what do you mean is he
winning he's got B7
oh my God wait I've woken up no and he's
also got Danny Rook A8 to C8 he can win
the pawn on C6 and get connected passers
Bobby might be losing control but this
is crazy as I'm saying you're like Danny
had to you know you're you're yelling at
me for getting excited I think Serrano
might be sending no no no getting here
I'm on board now I for some reason I
just fell asleep on how close this Pawn
is to promotion I apologize Fabiana
carwana might be choking this game H4
could set up a meeting man everywhere
but he's got two seconds to figure this
out
eight seconds for fobby though oh oh
here comes Rook A8 no he's one first oh
move
Rook A6 there I think was winning now
it's too late
well he plays it anyway but he's gonna
lose B7 oh that might have been his
winning chances right there and the king
is getting out oh
Forks him
an on-demand win from a dead lost
position gosh
about lost it when that happened
that was not fun for Mr carwana and
Alexi serrana is sending a second match
into Armageddon
serrana carwana we're going to be saying
that a couple more times I jinxed him
that was unusable he had it all under
control there was one idea to anyone and
that was the exchange sacrifice and it
worked to freaking Perfection he found
it and
Bobby got under time pressure but I was
I had the sense when we were saying it
you saw the time ticking as we said time
pressure does does things to the mind
it's easy for us to say and
unfortunately for Favi he now has to win
his match a second time in Armageddon
but okay let's remind everybody of all
the results that we now have in the
books we've been through the Swiss we've
now seen the match play stage behind us
we have Armageddon in store but from
Nick is sent home by gukesh not
napomnishi sent home by mametov sodwani
goes home courtesy of Ali Reza farouza
Dimitri on draken is no longer here
Arjun irigaisi Fabiana carwana Alexi
Serrano Daniel dubov and Hikaru Nakamura
will be competing in Armageddon Donya
what a world what a time to be alive
I mean we have gotten every type of
format we've gotten the Swiss we've
gotten knockout we've gotten match we've
got an Armageddon and Hikaru Nakamura
has his work cut out for him his
strategy was to take that quick draw
with white Danny I can't wait to see if
that strategy will pay off as it did so
often in the RCC and can Alexi Serrano
complete this unbelievable comeback in
which he wins on demand but now has to
win again in the Armageddon only one way
to find out
we're gonna find out as soon as we
return from the break and if hikaro
Nakamura who's still streaming was
looking for Content I guess Armageddon
is what he had in store what is Bobby
going to do to rebound we don't know
don't go anywhere it's the final moments
from the air things Masters play in
stage when we return
[Music]
he's gonna win the tournament
this is gonna be a turnaround
[Music]
oh
three seconds
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
overtime chess is what it's called Donya
it's what the fans pay for it's what
they love we have Armageddon ladies and
gentlemen alongside Grand Master Daniel
naroditski International Master Danny
wrench we made it through the Swiss
playing we had match play let's check
out the results Donya and uh okay we're
going to be diving in to the two
Armageddon matchups of course but before
we do that as we look at the results who
are you most impressed with who punched
their ticket to The Knockout starting on
February 6th well I'm not hesitating at
all Ralph mum at all I mean Jana
pomdishi is the world championship
Challenger he has an unimpeachable track
record in these types of Rapid events he
always seems to come through clutch I
mean RCC anywhere you look Jan delivers
and Ralph momentum holds him down with
black and then crushes him one-sided
game with the white pieces I can't wait
to see Ralph uh at playing at the top he
really deserves all of these invites
he's one of the Most Fascinating players
But Eric I see defeating on draken
farugia smooth win against edwani and of
course gukesh sending the former world
champion packing everybody had
impressive performances but these two
are against Danny it's like we had a
great dinner seven hour dinner and now
we've got the tiramisu some world famous
tiramisu coming your way the world
famous tiramisu being served up by
Fabiano caruana versus Alexi Serrano
Daniel Dubai versus Hikaru Nakamura
those Armageddon matchups are going to
go down
simultaneously Donya and I are going to
have our hand on the volume mixer as you
as a good DJ does flipping the script
back and forth doing what we can to stay
in touch with both but right now
let's do what we can to tell everybody
how the Armageddon rules work here in
the Champions chess tour the tiebreaker
is played obviously if the score is tied
after two games in a match the players
bid for their for their time as
traditional Armageddon bids go but the
cool thing about this format is that the
lowest bid
gets to pick their color
normally the lowest bid just
automatically takes black with that
color Donya but in our format the lowest
bid will get to choose whether they want
black or whether they want white
designed to really show that the lower
bid can be a strategy depending on the
style you're playing maybe you want
white and more time in those situations
but your thoughts Donya on the
Armageddon format yeah the the side
selecting color is is a nice little
twist I would say that the actual
occurrence would happen if both sides
bid very large like 950 versus 940 and
then even though technically you'd have
less time uh you could still choose
white it won't happen in most cases but
I like that I'm a big fan of Armageddon
in general not just because it
guarantees a result but because it
really brings out the player's Styles I
mean the fact that black has draw odds
and less time it's a very elegant
balance between a big advantage on the
one hand and a big disadvantage on the
other I think it's one of the fairest
forms Danny of guaranteeing a result
well we do actually have the results in
of how the players been and I'll just
I'll just read them here thanks to our
production team who's crushing it behind
the scenes let us know so Fabiano
caruana bid seven minutes and 50 seconds
Alexi serona bid eight minutes and 20
seconds that means Fabiana wins the bid
because he bid lower and he chose the
black pieces so he will play Black with
seven minutes and 50 seconds
go ahead no no yeah just under attack
Serana has 10 minutes he doesn't have 8
20. so white always starts with 10
minutes 10 minutes exactly yes I'm sorry
I didn't mean to confuse yes so bobby
gets seven minutes and 50 seconds with
the black pieces
Alexi serrana gets 10 minutes with the
white pieces Daniel dubov bid six
minutes and 30 seconds Hikaru Nakamura
bid 7 minutes and 59 seconds which means
the Neil wins and he chose the black
pieces as well
um maybe I'm actually rolling with that
do they get the higher time I actually
that's actually interesting question I
didn't I didn't realize that does uh
does Fabiano get eight minutes and 20
seconds because that was sirona's bid
against 10 minutes or does he does he
take the time he bet
so the winning bid selects color and
plays with his time bid so no I'm pretty
sure they get the time that they but
unfortunately for jubov I really really
don't think that's a wise bet against
Hikaru 630 there is no increment Danny I
can't stress this enough there is no
increment in Armageddon which means that
flagging is very much on the table
and he's got that three and a half extra
minutes Danielle better pull off some
magic or he's gonna get flagged agreed
agreed speaking read so much I can't
even say we're in the same town we're
like in the same city we're in a green
Town population Universe I I think that
that's a really interesting take for
denil to choose uh to choose the black
pieces there was so much less time so I
don't know that smells like fishy's bid
vishy's famous bit it was like four
minutes anyways we got a game going
yep and it's a uh reverse sort of
pan-off structure here with black having
that Queen side extended majority you
put the Rook on B8 as Bobby does he's
gonna play B5 A5 B4 crash through on the
queen side as Black's plan but white
will try to undermine the D5 pawn it can
be tender with moves like E4 and use the
king side
and when you're on the white side of an
Armageddon game you don't want to become
obsessed with your time Advantage you
have to remember that the position on
the board actually does matter so you
all you have to strike this very
delicate balance it's nice to keep that
time Advantage you have to keep flagging
in mind Danny you can't get a rook vs
Rook position with two seconds on the
clock you are gonna get flagged so Fabby
he's the one who has to be obsessed for
the time being with his clock situation
as long as he's down on the clock he is
definitely not down on the board I love
what he's doing on the queen side there
B4 is coming and he's better he's faster
than white and he can just ignore Alexi
in the center I think and just play B4 I
think he should I love it nothing like
ignoring my opponent's plans been doing
that for years B4 love it you have a
two-on-one majority even after the a the
A and B pawns are traded and in this
panel structure if you just took
everything else off the board black is
almost winning in the end game because
you're so close to creating a pass Pawn
so the dynamic is interesting white will
play F4 and F5 and maybe even F6 and go
all in for these attacks on the king
side meanwhile black will win an end
game if all the pieces are traded
absolutely that's well explained I think
Fabi has things under control let's
switch to the other game because we've
got a lot of action already in just 10
moves 12 moves and wow and end game
which is not necessarily bad for Hikaru
right just because the Queens are off
the board doesn't mean you're closer to
a draw I do like what Daniel is doing so
far he's got a pretty simple position
and he can continue pushing on the queen
side almost echoing Fabiano caruana's
plan in a completely different opening
this was a Sicilian
yeah and let's not forget we haven't had
a lot of chance to talk about it Hikaru
Drew their first game in match play with
black and had white and we thought is he
gonna push but Hikaru instead
immediately chose to let the game Peter
out he basically forced to draw his
white
okay and take
the question is because whether Hikaru
really believes in his skills in
Armageddon that much and it looks like
he does and if he takes B5 Knight takes
E4 Bishop to C6 is looking pretty good
to me so dubo's idea I think is Rook B8
this must be what Hikaru is calculating
right now the eval bar was not a fan of
this move but at least it's forced the
card to think and dubov is cutting into
his time Advantage I feel Danny the
bishop B5 has to work somehow I'm not
seeing the move after Rook B8 but I feel
that it exists maybe just A4 secure the
bishop and then go after Black's
crippled queenside Pawn structure I I
think Hikaru likes and Knight A3 Knight
C4 could be real juicy here after
castling to protect F5 I don't like what
Danielle has just done at all
I agree with everything that just came
out of your mouth
every single word took seven hours you
know but it happened eventually girl
took seven hours but the bond is real
you spend this much time with someone on
camera you might as well learn to like
them you know that's that's what I'm
that's what I'm hoping people will start
feeling about me after all these years
it hasn't been working
um but uh it was love at first seriously
the joke set Jokes Aside very well said
Donya and I love this movie A4 I love
the plan of putting the Knight on C4
highlighting that the A5 poem was weak
super well set and again Hikaru now up
almost four minutes on the clock with a
small Edge this is why to complete the
the storyline I was highlighting this is
why Hikaru forces Armageddon he loves
winner take all chess he loves this
format regardless of the color he gets
he feels confident in his ability to get
the dub when it matters and I'm gonna be
a little unfiltered here I'm a huge
Daniel Dubai fan I mean his chest and
how can you not be you know when when
you watch these games and some of the
ideas he displays so this is not a
personal uh remark but I really feel
like that was a terrible bid by duboff
six and a half minutes I mean you can't
stress enough how good Hikaru is in no
increment situations I feel like maybe
eight minutes and yes I'm playing
armchair General here would have been a
wiser bid because the problem is you
know you can equalize on the Lord but
Hikaru is always going to create
problems and he's going to use those
extra three minutes to find moves that
just force you to think I just don't see
Daniel getting out of this but he's 2700
for a reason this game is still going
our other game is starting to heat up as
well
yeah let's let's flip back over there
not because this won't be awesome uh to
follow they're all awesome to follow
we're down at the stretch you're an
eight-hour show we'll be done Greg
shahadi hopping in chat hanging out with
us what's up Greg the commish himself of
the protest League um okay I like this
plan from Serana this is what you got to
do although the clocks are now
completely even and in fact Bobby who
started out with a two and a half minute
time disadvantage is actually up a
little bit
he is but I feel like his wheels are
kind of spinning in the mud on the queen
side he played that move B3 but he's
gonna find it very very difficult to
push the companion over to C3 maybe
start with Bishop before Alexi is
building up the pieces on the king side
storm clouds are starting to gather
around blacks King can Alexi Danny get
the queen into the attack or can Fabby
strike at the queen side with C3 first
it's gonna be a scintillating finale in
this game yeah and for those saying Fabi
looks distressed maybe you missed the
memo but he is distressed because he was
up one to nothing and had no business
losing to get us an arm again so he
needs to shake off those memories he
needs to focus on the moment that is now
because he's not happy that he's here
that's the other psychological advantage
we have to talk about probably favoring
serrana just a little bit
oh absolutely and that was a ridiculous
finale I mean what haven't we seen in
these must-win situations Alexi he
brings his Queen to D1 for a reason he
didn't eeny meenie miney mow it that
Queen where it wants to be is G4 that's
where the party is at that's where the
bars are but to do that he's gonna have
to move his side out of the way and that
means allowing black to play C3 and
probably taking a different course
usually some tactics and getting his
Knight into the defense
I stared at the position for five
seconds before realizing that the Knight
was hanging but the bishop was hanging I
feel like I'm like what I went full
Bippity Boppity Boo with Donya right
um Knight to D6 just put the bishop on
B1 if you're serrana you've got Rook A6
coming in some positions you still have
done he has Knight G3 Queen G4 Knight H5
oh my gosh as I say it I'm getting
nervous for Fabi Knight G3 Queen G4 oh
here he goes battering ram bang bang get
that pawn out of the way he wants F5 F6
by hook or by crook can Fabiano keep the
ramparts alive on the queen side maybe
Queen to D7 to try to keep that F Pawn
alive but Danny Knight G3 could come at
the most inconvenient moment for Fabi
and if this F Pawn starts running amok
last king could end up paying the price
Ed's will roll one way or the other here
and either way you're happy with your
with your play if you're Serrano why
everybody because white has to win you
need three results yes faviano wins on a
draw because he has the black pieces in
Armageddon so this is exactly what
sirona ordered its Wi-Fi is is getting
nervous here you see that email bar
creeping you see the stress starting to
show you could have some problems on the
queen side as well don't sleep on Rook
A6 which could hit those loose knights
in fact he's played it in this position
and carwana's defenses Danny are
stressed even further you know what the
problem is if you move your knight back
to d8 Rook takes D6 and then Knight F5
picks up a second minor piece and
potentially the game these are serious
problems for Fabi who was once again
behind pretty significantly now on the
clock he needs a turnaround he needs
something like Alexi did in the previous
game yeah that was
that was that was brutal that last game
that to get us here and right now I
don't know that Bobby's gonna have it I
mean it's this is so tough everyone's
tired this is this is how we separate
those who will still be dancing in the
main event with so much on the line
because it's it's designed to be a
gauntlet this is designed to be tough
and this crazy developments in the other
game by the way Danny I'm sorry to cut
you off he missed it though 98 Rook D6
95.
I even think he takes D no he takes D6
to Simply The Winds of the spot Rook
takes E3 and that Knight F5 just picks
up the full Rook I think Alexa can just
take with the pawn and essentially end
the game right there
oh my gosh Serana with come back carwana
doesn't wanna any of this oh my God we
got craziness On The Other Board as well
man hey I'm a passenger you're driving
me right
and I will not deny on the serrana game
we'll bring you back there as soon as we
get more clarity but look at this
position Daniel dubuff has engineered
counter play against whites King Hikaru
almost getting mated there yeah
oh here comes another strike bang bang
bang taking the Sriracha to the queen
side now
it's it's Cholula what it matters most
because everyone knows that never sorry
okay we're focused on the chess we've
got but look at look at Hikaru it was
mate on the board it looked crazy in the
end what's going on White's position is
totally fine and he's still up two
minutes so dubov is running out of
tricks
he is and Hikaru is just gonna play this
until the crows come home to Rusty he's
gonna play this for 8 000 moves if
that's what it takes to whittle Black's
clock down to zero and he is whittling
his clock down to zero Danny I'm keeping
one eye and seventy percent of 75 of my
other eye on duboff's clock the board
doesn't even matter Carl will play Rook
and two and rook and two this is why the
bid struck me as potentially unwise
zubop's play here has been fantastic the
position is equal objectively
agreed agreed with you and and the the
idea that you have to play anytime
Scramble with no increment against
Hikaru means I want to have more time
than my opponent and uh
he doesn't have more time than Hikaru so
that's a problem and there's still juice
to be squeezed here if you're playing
white I would take white in a real game
Knight C4 is a problem only one side has
a pass Pawn as of yet and look at these
10 15 seconds that dubov is spending in
every position just to maintain equality
this is where Hikaru is spilling blood
this is where he's setting himself up
for the flag Fest to come even if dubov
manages to preserve equality
jeez and other game going crazy too
oh my God I think we should go back
yeah the the I'm sorry I was I'm in that
mode too I'm watching the fobby game I'm
oh what is going on here oh Lexi missed
e takes D6 that would have ended it on
the spot he has a loud Fabi to keep his
miners but now his Pawn has reached F6
Danny we said that if the pawn reaches
F6 the game's gonna be over 99 of cases
is this the 100th case where Fabi can
keep himself afloat I don't think so
Bishop F5 looks deadly here F7 check as
possible I know that's what I'm looking
at is F7 check in some sort of Discovery
oh with the queen and the King
it just doesn't look fun doesn't look
fun Fabi also down on the clock
no increment coming to save the day here
but Alexi he knows what's on the line
he's got to be feeling the nerves
delivering the hammer below Danny we all
know how incredibly hard that can be
against these super gems they never die
they never give up until they lose a
queen or they lose a king and that's
what Alexi is going to have to do win
fabi's queen or win fabi's King one or
the other
yep it's uh
last game of the year Dan don't want
anything back now you know
you gotta win the queen win the king
here he goes he's trying okay Knight F5
Queen
I think Queen H5 and black is still
alive I I think Alexi might have messed
up the mood or I wonder what he sees
here Queen to H3
could give a check on F3 Danny and take
the Queens off the board that would be
huge
yeah and if you don't get mate as white
and the Queens disappear this B Pawn on
B3 is still very very passed
and uh close to queening so you have to
you have to not mess this up if you're
surrounding you got it you got to get
something against the black king don't
let it slip away
two minutes now for both sides same
situation on the other board your car's
time Advantage is dwindling duboff has
activated turbo mode he has turned those
afterburners on and he has serious
chances to hold that end game against
Hikaru that's gonna come down to the
wire this is coming down to the wire oh
my goodness this is all you can eat Rook
takes place before the pawn is pinned
Bobby immediately played Rook A8 he
shakes his head he doesn't like it
I like it he's got the best position
he's had in the last 10 15 moves for
sure he's got serious counter play down
the a file don't sleep on that B3 Pawn
sex is Queen but his Queen is his scream
is trapped it wasn't I don't know where
to go
oh
but is it always said that he had no
choice take the Knight and go B2 and pin
your hopes on that pass Pawn try to get
Rook A1 and I said if Alexi wins the
queen it's over it's not I I don't know
I think it is I the Knight on E6 is
falling with check if you take F5 Bishop
F5 I think the king gets mated even if
black gets a second Queen I think Bobby
knows he's toast that was why that was
why he shook his head on Rook A8 it was
yeah I think it's over afraid you're
right I'm afraid you're right maybe he
had a way to sack the queen in a better
way I didn't see it it was very hard to
defend I think Alexi is gonna take this
home I agree yep yep yep yep yep this
should be hb2 93 and it's uh
it's gonna be a Lexi serrana oh my God
division one amazing yeah you have to go
back to the Nakamura dubov game Flag
City population Hikaru Nakamura in the
other game it's all down to the clock
Alexis Serrano has this in the back
Danny now safely look at this it's a
rook of Knight in three versus Rook at
night in three Dubai is not worse here
flag him and now the time situation is
even
the time situation is even and Hikaru
could lose this if he's not careful
right I mean
unlikely but the
if the a pawn Falls Donya black black
has an extra Pawn over there
the thing is even if it falls icaro is
Gonna Keep chances alive as long as he's
got mating material as long as he has a
single Pawn on the board he's got
flagging chances I don't see dubov
defending this I just don't see it I've
seen a car with too many of these
remember all dubov needs is a draw right
all he needs is a draw so do Bob has to
play fast enough to Peter out the game
he has to force it you can't allow some
sort of Rook vs Rook scenario you need
to force icaro to make a draw or give up
a rook so use that past E Pawn don't
just trade Knights and bail out because
Hikaru will flag you he's doing a
fantastic job he's Daniel dubov I am
very impressed with the way he's playing
right now E4 and he should have enough
counter players 55 check oh Rook D5 and
then he takes
35.65 rotation five it's still no he's
gonna find it now
oh
he's still winning Hikaru he cars should
still be winning this King age 5v3 it's
close
no he had 96 I think black at 96 and
Knight F4
okay he takes E3 what is going oh Knight
G4 Rook takes C4 no 64 is a draw
I think King F4 G7
and then there must be a move Rook takes
G4 Knight C7 there's tactics Theory I
don't have enough time obviously 16
seconds
apparently the move is Rook takes G4
it's the only move he's not gonna make
it he's not gonna make it
he's gonna get eight seconds that's it
even if I was gonna flag him even if he
finds unbelievable dude one it's over
there's no increment king of five and
the United States
and Hikaru wins oh my gosh
what just happened
what is going on here
Fabiano caruana
gets sent home in dramatic comeback
fashion by Alexi serrana
and and Hikaru Nakamura is proven right
regardless of the uh the skepticism and
the questions should he have made more
of an effort with white he says no uh
armageddon's my jam this is what I do
he always finds a way to pull through
and that final tactic Danny was absolute
genius Knight G4 it posts practical
problems that dubov did not have time to
solve had his bid then 30 seconds higher
I think we'd be singing Daniel duboff's
phrases right now and he'd be thinking
about what to play against Magnus
Carlson as it stands Hikaru Nakamura
what a day for him today unbelievable
as you see everyone if you just tuned in
the players who won these matchups
secured their spots there were six of
them available to join Magnus Carlson
and Wesley so in the main event starting
on February 6 with a lot of prize money
and ultimately one seat that goes
directly to the finals in December with
five hundred thousand dollars so who
were those six
I was reading them and it's gone and
here they are the division one winners
they brought them up Productions all
over it our Junior a guy see Ralph
Hikaru Nakamura win the division along
with gukesh and Ali Raza farusa they all
joined Magnus Carlson and Wesley so
those eight players will be throwing
down starting February 6th in the main
event for the air things Masters Donya
this has been an absolutely unbelievable
day this isn't hasn't just been a
qualifier it hasn't just been one of
those throwaway events because what we
really want to watch is uh the air
things Masters which we do want to watch
this was an epic tournament in its own
right as a standalone event I think this
was absolutely epic this competes with
anything in terms of entertainment value
and I see no better way to inaugurate
what will hopefully be a tradition an
incredible annual event than with a
seven hour slug Fest that we saw today
each of those players so deserving of
that spot this is how we will be kicking
off every event in the Champions chess
tour if you liked what you saw today
Russell Crowe screaming in the Gladiator
Arena are you not entertained this is
how every one of these events will be
kicked off uh the the players who lost
their match play-ins will still be
competing they will be in division two
yonda palmrashi Dimitri on Drake and
Fabiano caruana Daniel dubov products
I'm wanting and Vladimir chronic the
14th World chess champion joined the
other division two winners that you see
to your right
and uh well on that note let's go to the
division three breakdown because those
division two winners sent these division
two losers to compete in division three
hate using that word because no one
loses here but let's be honest it's a
competitive game and you win or you lose
Hussein off grishek Liam lay kymer
zhangyu
will join the division the division
three winners oh my gosh I'm tired Dania
I'm I'm tongue twisted take it away I am
as well Danny I'm with you there partner
this was a long long show this was an
amazing show Alexander Boardman got to
shout him out he's a good friend of mine
he is a recognizable name to everybody
and he showed today hey I'm not just a
bullet specialist I'm a strong
Grandmaster and I think people need to
recognize this some of these players
that you see playing three plus zero on
chess.com they're not just swindlers
they're not just flaggers they are
incredibly strong Grandmasters with the
proven track record and they give
everyone a run for their money we saw
all of the top guys have a run for their
money nobody had an easy run Danny and
at the end of the day every single one
of those six players who punch their
ticket to division one they deserve to
be joining Magnus Carlson and Wesley so
well at the end of the day we we often
have an interview despite how long this
day has been Donya Hikaru wants to pop
on and uh and say a few things and so
we're gonna do that why not be joined by
the man who punched his ticket in in the
most dramatic of possible fashions in
Armageddon we're going to take a very
quick break don't go anywhere when we
return it will be Hikaru Nakamura and
literally the final moments for the air
things Masters plan
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back everyone we are now joined
by the man who punched his ticket to
compete in the main event starting
February 6th perhaps in the most
dramatic Fashions of all Hikaru a lot to
unpack about today I'm going to start by
by just asking directly
was there getting out of the gate it
seemed like there was you were a little
slow going was there a moment where you
didn't feel your form was there and you
eventually found it was there was there
yeah you felt like you got in rhythm
yeah well I mean first of all thanks for
having me I certainly throughout the day
anybody who saw my Camp saw me shaking
my head a lot
um you know it got off to create sorry
one was very very nice first came
against Afghani tomashevski but in the
second round I lost this very tough game
uh to the Chinese player and after that
it just seemed like a slog I thought I
was missing a lot of stuff
um I mean even even in the final game
there's a moment when I I actually like
walked into this tactic which worked
against laquan but then after this Rook
C2 I just missed this bishop D3 Rook B2
Bishop E5 Bishop B1 and of course half a
second after I played uh Bishop takes A6
I saw it so you know I I think it was
sort of just trying to trying to keep it
simple towards towards the end of the
event because certainly it wasn't uh
wasn't going my way I mean I had many
promising positions but I also had night
positions that weren't great as well so
you know you take it take it as it comes
but luckily at the end of the day much
like in the great event Arena Kings
there was a knockout
um and I think in general I do better in
a knockout format than I do and um in a
uh I do much better in a in a knockout
format than just a regular Swiss
mm-hmm
Hikaru would you say that there's a case
to be made that these types of events
where the grind of stuff at the start
are more satisfying in a way when they
end well than tournaments where kind of
everything goes right from the beginning
yeah certainly I mean it's at the end of
the day if everything goes goes right
you feel really good but of course there
are a couple moments the final game or
not the final game Sorry the final game
against laquan then of course this final
game against do Bob I mean things could
have been very different but certainly
uh it's nice at the end but you feel
like you're gonna have a heart attack in
the middle so I probably lost some some
years off my life today but it's all
worth it I guess
hey Carl let's let's talk about that
Armageddon strategy you have because me
and Donya are sitting here just you know
singing your praises and also just
calling to the attention to the fact
that you had no doubts in your mind that
you wanted Armageddon it seemed that
when you got the white pieces you knew
that you were ready to take it to
armageddon's duboff how confident are
you in those winner take all chess
formats and why why do you feel that way
what is it about that format that you
feel good whether you're getting black
with the joint chances or white
well I mean I wasn't attending to do
that but when all of a sudden done after
we do our first game uh we weren't
really sure what the format was like we
waited like a minute then Dubai three
rematch I accept it we start the game
game gets aborted then there's like uh
like we're told five minutes is closer
to ten final I'm just like okay do Bob's
gonna send me the rematch I don't care
I'm just gonna accept the rematch and
just get out of town so uh probably
ordinarily I wouldn't have done that but
I was just kind of annoyed about the
situation in between the games
um so that's actually the reason that I
did it
um I mean uh well then yeah just told
being done to that no I'm teasing I'm
teasing but no but they had no idea
we're like why did you take care go
ahead well the point is like dubov sends
a rematch I accept it and then we get
two moves and it gets aboard and we're
told five minutes and like 10 minutes
have passed and and finally like I'm
just like what's going on I see the
dubov's rematch just sitting there so
it's like okay whatever they're not
gonna automatically start the game so
let's just get this over with
um so uh yeah that was actually the
reasoning behind it but that being said
I mean I felt pretty good
um going into the Armageddon I was
actually kind of I was impressed by
dubov's play though Nike me he had a
very good opening that he came up with
and um you know I thought my bit of 715
I was pretty decent because when I think
back to the uh rapid Chess Championship
I think in the uh the match against Yan
and the Armageddon he he did 10 minutes
I did something like I want to say 7 20
or 7 30 somewhere around there and I
mean the game went into a long end game
I was okay probably should have drawn
but I was kind of getting low on time
eventually blundered and lost the game
and um and so I thought the Dubose bid
was way too low but he he played very
very well um but luckily I was able to
find just a little just enough sort of
counter player complications when we had
about a minute or a little over a minute
left on the clock on things seem to go
my way
Cara we have a couple chat questions
before we let you go first from Andrew
for 48590 for newer players in general
terms could you describe the rationale
behind your Rook sacrifice at the end
and how excited were you uh when you
found it
well first of all Daniel you're a bullet
player and I would say it was actually a
horrible decision by me um I was very
fortunate that it worked out the reason
that I should not have done that is
because we both had about I would say I
had 30 seconds and do above had about 25
seconds if I keep Brooks on the board
there and we get to some kind of end
game like rookie Knight versus rookie
Knight or anything of that sort I can
probably flag him
um but by playing that move he actually
should have just taken on G4 and then
played Knight E6 and then figured it out
with 25 seconds I think there's a good
chance they would have saved it if he
had done it but the problem is dubov did
the other order where he tried to
calculate the draw and he didn't see the
draw
um and so then he had five seconds and
it was it was just too much
um I think that at the end we both well
I I didn't actually calculate it but I
think when he was calculating it what he
missed is he he missed it there's this
line where he gets the king to F6 and I
played G7 and you go King F7 not Knight
takes G7 H7 but King F7 to go King G8
and the other one was that instead of
playing his Pawn to H just in Kansas I
can also go G7 but then he takes I play
agents 98 F6
um which also draws but the problem with
that was with 25 seconds he should have
just snapped the Knight on G4 and then
use his time again probably he would
have drawn the game
um that was just a mistake from from not
having bull experience so while I'd like
to pretend that it was some great
decision it actually was a really really
bad decision from a practical point of
view
I feel like you're playing uh you're
playing a meta game here like five
levels deep and I'm just like you know
it's like Inception I don't understand
the dream anymore but no it's good
because but I mean okay like like first
things first we all know that dubov uses
a touch pad so in a pure time scramble I
should be faster than him that's just
simply the reality I should be fast
without him in a pure time scramble
um but the point is when I played that
the position so simplified that that he
can just like he can find those moves
and if I was playing uh your fellow
commentator I'm pretty confident he
would have played Rook takes G4 because
it's bulletin six and then use his time
and probably would it probably would be
a draw
Donya he was talking to you and that
he's saying no I know oh yeah of course
of course I appreciate that you're not
talking about you Danny I'm not talking
about you all right all right well all
right well let's let's talk about next
week uh a comment from chat comes comes
in saying that hey you beat Magnus in
the SEC recently we know that Magnus is
not your only opponent next week Ali
Reza farrugia so many others there but
talk about how you're feeling how
confident you are about the format as it
stands for The Knockout starting on
February 6th well I mean first things
first I don't actually know what the
format is so I'll probably go read what
the format is once you know like tonight
or tomorrow to figure out it's a
knockout double elim knockout oh it's
double elimination okay so so yeah I
mean
considering how poorly I felt like I
played today at critical moments
um I I feel uh I feel I feel pretty good
because I think I can only play better
than I did today I mean like I said
anyone who's watching the broadcast saw
me shaking my head a lot so I thought a
lot of my decisions were not the right
ones so I really feel like there's only
I can only only play better if I play
worse than I did well that's just life
and I don't deserve to win if that's the
case
well we wish you the best go ahead no no
I I I was I'm out of questions
we wish you the best of luck man it is
double elim I think it's exciting I'm
I'm gonna I'm gonna be uh watching as a
fan not commentating so uh dude it was I
know it didn't start the way you wanted
but watching you come back was uh it
felt like impending doom for the rest of
your opponents and I know it probably
didn't feel that way to you it was
nerve-wracking but congratulations on a
great day of Chess and uh good luck next
week man thank you so much you guys
appreciate it congrats all right see ya
see you man there he was the guy who uh
punched his ticket in dramatic fashion
let's remind everybody that uh what did
he punch his ticket to the air things
Masters it begins on Monday February 6th
like we said everyone is going to
recharge over the weekend oh my gosh we
are exhausted the players are exhausted
that was Non-Stop and uh it was chess of
the highest level we are bringing you a
week of more Chess at the highest level
The Knockout begins on Monday it starts
at 8 A.M Pacific time and it comes to a
head on Friday when one person is going
to be punching their ticket directly to
the championship at the end of the year
so don't miss a single thing history is
being made in every one of these events
and it's right here at twitch.tv chess
Donya
man
I did it
that was a long time I take them off
your extra sweet iced tea I love you too
my input we don't want to get too
emotional eight hour show one of the
longest I've ever done nobody I'd rather
do it with I think that's a hard symbol
you're doing right there you know you're
gonna make me you know reach for the
tissues here and I almost made it
through the entire show Danny that was
amazing and no inaugural show of
anything could possibly be better than
what we saw just then every minute
filled with action of a different kind
culminating until the very last moments
that's what we want from the start of
the CCT
uh we did we got everything we could
handle I'm I'm obviously sitting here
applauding Hikaru Nakamura finding a way
to get it done Armageddon feeling
heartbroken for Fabiano caruana uh it
seemed like in the beginning of the day
he probably was in the finest form of
everybody I don't think you would agree
he was just he was on a roll right finds
a way unfortunately to snatch defeat
from the jaws of Victory there and of
course Alexi Serrano gets all the credit
for getting that done I'm not going to
do the thing where I start unpacking
every match in my head like I want to
let's just say it was awesome if you
missed the show where have you been
watch the whole VOD it's worth it enjoy
your Friday night
um because what the cool kids do is they
they turn on chess shows and they watch
mods on Friday nights right Tanya that's
what they did this was this was amazing
you know I'm I'm totally fried I have no
more words left I've used all of them
for this show but Danny it's it's so
much fun to commentate with you it was
light outside it was dark when I woke up
and it was light now it's dark again and
I'm just so happy that I got to spend
these seven hours with you and with
these amazing chess players it's an
honor it was an honor to compensate the
first event really to set the tone for
what will hopefully be months and months
of Epic action Danny
I'm done and this was amazing thank you
everyone you're done no more words
needed good luck to the team hosting
from our studios in Oslo join them on
Monday as we've said shout out to the
team who worked super hard we got it
done kicked it off in in record server
record server fashion so much going on
in the chess Community it's only just
begun enjoy your weekend everybody we
will see you on Monday as the air things
Masters kicks off and the Champions
chess tour here in 2023 continues
foreign
[Music]
thank you